CALL OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON
PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE WILL BEGIN.
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE GET A
QUORUM ON THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
HAVE BEEN PULLED OFF CALENDAR.
ON ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SIX COOPER
PULLED BY AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT A. B.
TWENTY FOURTEEN. E. GARCIA PULL
BY AUTHOR.
OKAY FOR.
WILL BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE
WILL HAVE HEARINGS AND MISTER.
GRAYSON.
THE FIRST ONE HERE SO LET'S
BEGIN TWENTY TO FORTY.
BUT.
ITEM NUMBER TEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO FORTY.
RELATING TO TRIAL JURY
SELECTION.
AB TWENTY TO FORTY WOULD EXEMPT
PROBATION PAROLE AND CORRECTION
OFFICERS FROM JURY DUTY AND
CRIMINAL TRIALS ONLY.
DESPITE BEING SWORN PEACE
OFFICERS WHO PROVIDE CRITICAL
PUBLIC SAFETY SERVICES PROBATION
PAROLE AND CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
ARE NOT EXEMPT FROM SERVING ON
JURY DUTY THESE OFFICES DUTIES
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
SUPERVISING OFFENDERS. ON POST
RELEASE SUPERVISION MANDATORY
SUPERVISION PROBATION PAROLE AND
MONITORING ADULTS AND JUVENILES
SERVING TIME INSIDE A LOCAL AND
STATE DETENTION FACILITY.
THE LEAST IS THAT PULLING THESE
OFFICERS FROM THEIR ASSIGNMENTS
CAN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT THEIR
RESPECTIVE AGENCIES ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE AND
ADMINISTER PROGRAMS AND
SUPERVISION.
BUT THE MOST BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY PEACE PEACE OFFICERS
ARE OFTEN IN POSITIONS
WHERE THE DEFENDANT IN A
CRIMINAL TRIAL WHERE THEY ARE
SERVING JURY DUTY COULD
POTENTIALLY BE UNDER THE WATCH
JOE OR JURISDICTION IN THE
FUTURE. THIS CONFLICT CAN CREATE
A PUBLIC SAFETY RISK TO THESE
PEACE OFFICERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES BY REQUIRING THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION TO BE
SHARED DURING THE COURSE OF THE
JURY SELECTION AND OR TRIAL AND
FOR THESE REASONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
YOU HAVE TO WITNESS I DO HAVE A
WITNESS ALLOWED TO SELF
INTRODUCED.
TOTAL FIVE MINUTES IN HIGH SPLIT
UP.
SO FOR MANY SUBS ARE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA UP PLEASE
BE A SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE.
ALT ALTER FOR MY TIME AND TO
THE CHIEF WITH US HERE TODAY BUT
I DOJUST WANT TO MENTION A FEW
THINGS I THINK. OF THE ANALYSIS
DOES A GREAT JOB OF TALKING
ABOUT ON THE EGGS THE LIST OF.
EXIST STEAM EXEMPTIONS FOR
PEACE OFFICERS CURRENTLY IN THE
LAW AND SPECIFICALLY ON THAT
KIND OF PRETRIAL
RESPONSIBILITIES THEY PLAY I
WOULD NOTE THAT APPROBATION DOES
PLAY MANY OF THOSE KIND OF
PRETRIAL.
TAKE DUTIES IN ADDITION TO POST
CONVICTION ON SO PROBATION OF
COURSE.
IS WRITING PRE SENTENCE REPORTS
TO THE COURT THAT TALKS ABOUT
SUITABILITY AND ELIGIBILITY.
FOR PROBATION I'M WORKING ON
TASK FOR BAD TASK FORCES
INTERVIEWING WITNESSES I'M DOING
MANY OF THE SAME THINGS THAT
AGAIN ARE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
COLLEAGUES ARE DOING WHO ARE
CURRENTLY EXEMPTS.
AND THEN OF COURSE.
YOU KNOW KIND OF POST
CONVICTION APPROBATION IS PLAYED
A ROLE IN MANY OF THESE CASES
WITH THEIR DEPARTMENT
SUPERVISING.
THESE DEFENDANTS AND SO AS AN
ARM OF THE COURTS AND WE BELIEVE
APPROPRIATELY THAT.
PROBATION ON SHOULD BE IN THE
SAME CODE WITH EXEMPTIONS OF
EXISTING LAW ENFORCEMENT. I'M
ALL THE FOR MY TIME INTRODUCED
CHIEF MARK ANAEMIA CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER OF AMADOR
COUNTY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
AND.
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE THIS MORNING TO TESTIFYING
AB TWENTY TO FORTY. THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS AN ARM OF
THE COURT PROBATION OFFICERS
PREPARE REPORTS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BENCH.
IT CREATES AN INHERENT CONFLICT
OF INTERESTS FOR EXAMPLE
PROBATION IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PREPARING PRESENTS INVESTIGATION
REPORTS.
TO ASSIST THE COURT IN MAKING
SENTENCING DETERMINATIONS.
THIS INCLUDES INFORMATION ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE OFFENSE
INVOLVES A. TAKING TALKING TO
THE DEFENDANT VICTIM AND OTHER.
IMPACTED PARTIES.
THE ROLE PUTS OFFICERS IN A
POSITION WHERE THE DEFENDANT IN
A CRIMINAL TRIAL UNDER OUR
JURISDICTION IS LIKELY TO BE
UNDER THE JURISDICTION. ARE
JURISDICTION FOR SUPERVISION AS
WELL WHICH CREATES AN INHERENT
CONFLICT OF INTEREST TO OUR
DEPARTMENTS COMPLETING REPORTS
AND AT THE SAME TIME POTENTIALLY
WOULD HAVE SAT ON THE JURY. AT
THIS DOES CREATE A PUBLIC SAFETY
RISK.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT OUR
OFFICERS NOT BE PUT IN
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY HAVE TO
SHARE PERSONAL INFORMATION AS
PART OF THE JURY SELECTION
PROCESS.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN A ROLE WITHIN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
SUPERVISING OFFENDERS.
I PERSONALLY HAD THIS EXPERIENCE
WHERE IN A RARE CASE I WAS
ACTUALLY CHOSEN FOR THE JURY
POOL AMONG THE FIRST TWELVE
RANDOMLY SELECTED TO THE POOL.
AT THAT TIME I WAS REQUIRED TO.
.
PROVIDING SHARE PERSONAL
INFORMATION. ONLY TO THEN BE
REMOVED FROM THE JURY ONCE THAT
DEFENSE ATTORNEY AND USED ONE OF
THEIR CHALLENGES.
BUT BY THEN THE AND THE DAMAGE
WAS A LITTLE BIT HAD TO IT WAS
TOO LATE BECAUSE THE DAMAGE HAD
ALREADY OCCURRED.
NOT ONLY DID I PUT MYSELF IN
FAMILY POTENTIAL DANGER
SITUATION BUT HAVING TO SHARE
PERSONAL INFORMATION BUT ALSO
LOST A CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY
WORK TIME. THAT I DEDICATE TO MY
DEPARTMENT AND MY OFFICERS
DEDICATE TO OUR COMMUNITY.
AB TWENTY TO FORTY WILL FIX THIS
ISSUE AND HELP PROTECT OFFICER
SAFETY. REMOVE THE INHERENT FOR
CONFLICT OF INTEREST IN OUR ROLE
AS WITH THE CORD AND WILL ALSO
ASSIST US IN MAXIMIZING THE
RESOURCES TO FURTHER IMPROVE
CRITICAL. PUBLIC SAFETY NEEDS I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE PROBATION OFFICER
SUPERVISING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OVER THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND ADULT FELONS.
AND ROSS RESPONSIBLE FOR THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND YOUTH WITHIN OUR
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEMS AND
DETENTION FACILITIES.
SO TAKING TIME AWAY FROM OUR
CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY NEED IS
IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY. SO I
WOULD I REQUEST THAT. YOU
SUPPORT AB TWENTY TO FORTY AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME THIS
MORNING.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MONEY WAS SHOWN MEMBERS
COMMITTEE ALBERTO TO RECALL RIPS
IN THE STATE COALITION
PROVISIONAL RELATIONS IN
SUPPORT.
CHAIR GREG STUPOR FROM
SECONDHAND INFORMATION
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARCO GEORGE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THINKS.
LARRY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LEXI HOWARD ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TODAY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE. OUR JUSTICE PARTNERS
AND THE AUTHOR AND THE WORK THAT
THEY ARE DOING AND ARE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS WITH THEM.
AYE ON A NUMBER OF AREAS
IMPORTANT TO THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
VERY CONCERNED WHEN WE START TO
DIMINISH THE JURY POOL.
RESPECTFUL OF PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS IN THE COURTROOM ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO COMES
INTO JURY SERVICE IS ABLE TO
MEET PRIVATELY WITH THE JUDGE
AWAY FROM THE COURTROOM SETTING.
TO OFFER THEIR EXCUSE
WE ARE CONCERNED EVERY TIME WE
REDUCE THE SIZE OF THE JURY POOL
IT DIMINISHES OF THE PUBLIC'S
CONFIDENCE IN THE JURY SYSTEM
WHERE THEY ARE ASKED TO
REGULARLY SERVE. AND CREATES
MORE OF AN INCONVENIENCE
FOR THOSE WHO ARE REMAINING AND
REALLY JURY SERVICE IS NOT AN
INCONVENIENCE IMPEDIMENT TO OUR
DAY. THAT'S A FOUNDATIONAL PART
OF OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
SHARON RILEY ON BEHALF OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ALSO.
IN RESPECT FOR OPPOSITION.
TO THE BILL.
I ECHO THE STATE THE STATEMENTS
BY LEXI HOWARD AS FAR AS THE
CONCERNS ABOUT.
HOW?
THIS BILL COULD IMPACT THE JURY
POOL.
AND THE COUNCIL HAS A LONG
STANDING.
.
POLICY OF OPPOSING CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTIONS FROM JURY SERVICE.
AND HAS FOUND THAT.
STATUTORILY EXEMPTING CERTAIN
CATEGORIES OF PERSONS REDUCES
THE. NUMBER OF AVAILABLE JURIES
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
SELECT REPRESENTATIVE JURIES AND
UNFAIRLY INCREASES THE BURDEN OF
JURY SERVICE. ON OTHERS SEGMENTS
OF THE POPULATION AND SO WITH
THAT THERE'S A CONCERN AT
CONTINUING TO. EXPAND.
THE CATEGORIES OF PERSONS TO.
DO NOT HAVE TO.
SERVE ON JURIES.
FURTHER REDUCES THAT PULL.
AND THERE IS THE CONCERN THAT
COURTS HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION TO ENSURE THAT
TRIPLES. ARE REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE COMMUNITY. AND THAT THERE
ARE ENOUGH.
PROSPECTIVE JURORS IN THE
COURTHOUSE EACH DAY. TO AVOID
HAVING TO DISMISS.
LAST A CRIMINAL TRIALS FOR LACK
OF JURORS EXCITER HAVE.
AND AND IN RESPONSE TO CONCERNS
RAISED.
SPECIFICALLY BY THE PUBLIC
SAFETY HUMANITY THAT.
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ADOPTED
CALIFORNIA ROLLS RULE OF COURT
RULED TWO POINT ONE ZERO ZERO
EIGHT WHICH ALLOWS A HARDSHIP
EXEMPTION VARIOUS OUR CHIPS
EXAMS EXEMPTIONS. BUT THERE'S
ONE SPECIFIC TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNITY.
WHICH.
PROVIDES A EXEMPTION.
WHEN THE SERVICES THEIR SERVICES
ARE IMMEDIATE NEEDED FOR OR THE
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY.
AND IN CONCLUSION COURTS MUST
CONSTANTLY BALANCE THE NEED TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO. THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM WITH THE NEED TO RESPECT
JURORS TIMES.
HOWEVER WHILE JURY SERVICE
REQUIRE SACRIFICE ON THE PART OF
CITIZENS EXEMPTING CERTAIN
CLASSES OF INJURED INDIVIDUALS.
BASED ON THE BURN IT MIGHT PUT
ON THEM UNFAIRLY INCREASES THE.
BURDEN ON THE OTHERS THEM
WITHOUT WE RESPECT IT
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BUT ANY
OTHER WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
WELL WHAT.
BUT WE. DO HAVE.
LET'S.
ESTABLISH A CORE.
JONES SAWYER HERE.
LACKEY.
CARILLO.
TABLADA.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
ONE WAS PRESIDENT AND THE
WELCOME. WISH COME WATER DOVE TO
TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND ALSO WELCOME MISTER.
QUIRK WHO CAN'T TALK RIGHT NOW.
WHAT WILL FIGURE IT OUT?
I THINK. QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND.
YEAH THANK YOU YOU MENTIONED TWO
THINGS THAT.
.
THAT IN IN THE INSTANCE OF OF
THE EXAMPLE THAT YOU GAVE YOU
SAID BUT THAT IN THIS INSTANCE
THE DAMAGE WAS DONE SO I WOULD
JUST SORT OF WONDERING IF YOU
COULD EXPAND ON THAT BECAUSE.
NO I THINK MANY OF US MAY HAVE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE.
SERVE ARM M. ON A JURY.
AND.
WE ALL ARE TREATED THE SAME WAY.
WITH RESPECT TO YOU KNOW BEING
CALLED TO SERVE IN HAVING TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND.
SO JUST CURIOUS ABOUT THAT
STATEMENT BECAUSE I WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY CONSIDER IT TO BE
DAMAGING.
ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT SHARING.
PERSONAL INFORMATION BUT IT'S
ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
PARTICIPATE IN A PROCESS WITH
YOUR FELLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE. A PARTICULAR
PERSON.
OR TO REVIEW AN INSTANCE OR AN
INCIDENT ALARM. WITH FRESH EYES
OR A DIFFERENT KIND OF
PERSPECTIVE.
WELL WHEN IT WHEN I'M DONE MADE
THAT STATEMENT THAT THE IDEA IS
THAT.
BEING THERE WITH THAT A
DEFENDANT THAT I'M POTENTIALLY
GOING THERE.
HAVE TO SUPERVISE WILL BE UNDER
MY JURISDICTION I'VE PROVIDED
INFORMATION PERSONAL INFORMATION
THAT I'M NORMALLY AN ENORMOUS
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES I WOULD
HAVE HAD TO PROVIDE. AND THE US
I LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
THAT I ACTUALLY NAM HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER SO AND THE
POTENTIAL IS THERE FOR MY FAMILY
AND IN MY. CHILDREN TO BE AT AT
ELEVATED RISK OF AS OPPOSED TO
I'M SOMEONE THAT WASN'T CHARGED
WITH A PUBLIC SAFETY POSITION
AND SUPERVISING. A SAID
OFFENDER.
INADEQUATE FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAKE CLOSENESS TO GRAYSON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF FORT THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO PRESENT THIS BILL.
THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE ABOUT
CONVENIENCE OR EVEN AN ISSUE OF
HARDSHIP.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING AND THAT IS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OF OUR PEACE
OFFICERS CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
PROBATION OFFICERS.
AND IT IS TRUE THAT.
THAT.
POLICE OFFICERS DO HAVE
EXEMPTION AND ALL WE'RE ASKING
FOR IS TO INCLUDE THOSE THAT ARE
SUPERVISOR SUPERVISING.
THOSE THAT ARE RELEASED AFTER.
INCARCERATION TO ALSO BE ABLE
TO HAVE. EXEMPTION AS WELL FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY PURPOSES
THAT MEANS NOT TO HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO DELIVER PERSONAL
INFORMATION. THAT OTHERS DON'T
HAVE TO DELIVER AS WELL SO THIS
IS ABOUT A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE
IN KEEPING. OUR PEACE OFFICER
SAFE AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU CHAIRS RECOMMEND AYE
VOTE.
NOW KIM HIM I RESPECTFULLY. IS
THERE A MOTION.
THERE'S A.
BILLS OUT FOR LACK OF HELD A
COMMITTEE FOR LACK OF A SECOND.
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU
BUT YOU.
IT IS REVEALED HERE I DON'T
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR AND
THIRTY ONE TWENTY NINE.
S. ITEMS EIGHT AND TWENTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR I AM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BAKER AND I WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT ONE OF OUR CAUCUS
PARROTBILLS AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FOUR.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ONTINGENT
UPON FUNDING IN THE STATE BUDGET
TOWARD FUNDS UP TO ELEVEN DE A
OFFICES THAT EMPLOY. VERTICAL
PROSECUTION PROGRAMS FOR THE
PROSECUTION OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CRIMES.
VERTICAL. TEAMS ARE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN PROSECUTING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
VERTICAL PROSECUTION UNITS
INVOLVED ONE OR MORE STAFF
ATTORNEYS WHO HANDLE A SPECIFIC
TYPE OF CASE FROM ARRAIGNMENT TO
CONVINCE CONVICTIONS. RATHER
THAN DIFFERENT ATTORNEYS
HANDLING GIVE DIFFERENT STAGES
OF THE PROSECUTION.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE AN AWARD. OF
GRANT FUNDS UNDER THIS BILL A
PROSECUTING OFFICE MUST HAVE
SPECIFIC STAFFING DEDICATED FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VERTICAL
PROSECUTION PROVIDE ANNUAL DATA
ON THE NUMBER OF CASES FILED BY
THE COUNTY. AND THEIR OUTCOMES
AND HAVE A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE ADVOCACY
AGENCY THAT PROVIDES COUNSELING.
AND OR SERVICE TO VICTIMS
AS WE ALL KNOW HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IS A HUGE PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
WITH APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN. TO
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND VICTIMS A ARE
BEING TRAFFICKED INTO THE UNITED
STATES ANNUALLY. BETWEEN TWENTY
TEN TWENTY TWELVE CALIFORNIA'S
NINE REGIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING
TASK FORCE IDENTIFY AT ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN VICTIMS. IN NATION
INITIATED TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
INVESTIGATIONS ARRESTED
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED NINETY EVEN
THE VIGILS AND PROVIDED CRITICAL
TRAINING TO MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PERSONNEL PROSECUTORS VICTIM
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS. IT IS MY HOPE THAT
MORE SUCCESSFUL ARRESTS AND
PROSECUTIONS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS. WILL SERVE AS A
DETERRENT AND REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING OCCURRING
IN OUR STATE. THANK YOU AYE AND
WITH ME IS ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
CAPTAIN BAKER.
LAKE YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN PERSON
I THINK ARE GOOD COLLEAGUE OF
MISS RUBIO FURTHER A CO
AUTHORING LESS LEGISLATION AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS THE FASTEST
GROWING CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE
UNITED STATES.
AND IT DOESN'T JUST HAPPEN IN
FARAWAY LANDS OR FAR AWAY PLACES
AND OR TO PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT.
COUNTRIES NOT UNITED STATES
SEVENTY TWO PERCENT OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE DOMESTIC.
AMERICAN RESIDENTS AND.
I THINK CALIFORNIA ACCORDING TO
THE FBI HAS THREE OF THE FBI'S
TOP TEN HOT SPOTS FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VERTICAL PROSECUTION
HAS BEEN FOUND TO BE ONE OF THE
MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS FOR
COMBATING HUMAN TRAFFICKING. BY
FULLY PROCESS BY FULLY
PROSECUTING THE CASES OF THE
TRAFFICKERS.
AND IT'S PARTICULARLY BENEFICIAL
FOR TWO REASONS ONE THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS GET BETTER AT THE
CASES THEY'RE VERY VERY COMPLEX
CASES TYPICALLY BECAUSE THE
WITNESSES BEEN. DRAMATIC
EXPERIENCE THEY HAVE.
SIMILAR PROFILES TO THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN.
SUFFERING FROM DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ABUSE WITH RESPECT TO
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS FOR THEM TO
COOPERATE WITH THE PROSECUTION
AND THIS ALLOWS IDEAS TO GET
BETTER AT THE CASES BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT'S A VICTIM
CENTERED APPROACH TO PROSECUTING
THE CASES.
A VICTIM DOESN'T HAVE TO MEET A
NEW PROSECUTOR AT EACH STAGE OF
THE PROCESS BUT HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY BLESS YOU. TO MAKE
SURE.
TO DEVELOP A REPORT WITH THE
PROSECUTOR AND REALLY HAVE THAT
KIND OF RELATIONSHIP THAT MAKES
IT EASIER FOR.
JUSTICE TO BE SERVED AND THIS
IS FOUND TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
FIGHT HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
I THINK ALL OF US VOTED FOR A
RESOLUTION EARLIER THIS YEAR
INCREASING AWARENESS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND CALLING ON OUR
STATE TO DO MORE TO FIGHT IT
THIS IS ONE OF THE CONCRETE
TOOLS FOR DOING THAT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I
WITH US TODAY WE HAVE JOHN
HOFFMAN FROM THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION AND KATIE
DE FERRARI WITH THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. THE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL.
I SEE ONE.
BUT GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR SHAWN HOP IN WITH
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID.
VERTICAL PROSECUTION UNITS WITH
THE SAME PROSECUTORS HANDLING
THAT CASE FROM THE PRELIMINARY
HEARING THROUGH THE TRIAL A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY.
IN THE CASES OF VERY YOUNG
VICTIMS WERE TALKING ABOUT.
SEX AND LABOR TRAFFICKING CASES
WHERE WE'RE DEALING WITH VERY
VULNERABLE VICTIMS SO. CREAM
STRUCTURE WE WERE ABLE TO
DEVELOP THAT RELATIONSHIP OF
TRUST BETWEEN THE PROSECUTOR IN
THE VICTIM HAS PRUNING A VERY
EFFECTIVE METHOD OF PROSECUTING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. IN THE
COUNTIES THAT HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO DO IT THIS WAY.
I IN ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
WHERE WE HAVE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
NANCY O'MALLEY ONE OF THE.
NATIONAL EXPERTS ON ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
LEYVA RESEARCH INSTITUTE THAT'S
LOOKED AT THE TRAUMA SUFFERED BY
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN.
ONE OF THE COMMONALITIES THAT
THEY FOUND IN TALKING TO OVER A
HUNDRED SURVIVORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS THAT. YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TRAFFICKED
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO'VE BEEN
SEX TRAFFICKED
IS THEY HAVE MANY LAYERS OF
TRAUMA SO STARTING IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD HEADING HOME LIFE THAT
WAS NOT SAFE. IMMEDIATE
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT SEXUAL
ABUSE ON AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THE SURVIVORS OF SPOKEN AT
LENGTH ABOUT THE LACK OF
STABILITY OR CONSISTENCY
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIVES MOVING
FROM FOSTER HOME TO FOSTER HOME
HAVING SOCIAL WORKER. AND THEN
BEING REPLACED WITH ANOTHER
SOCIAL WORKER THAT SORT OF
CONSTANT CHANGE BREEDS CHAOS AND
VULNERABILITY THAT IS PREYED
UPON BY TRAFFICKERS SO.
THE EXPERIENCE OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DA IN HAVING PROSECUTOR
ALMOST SIX HUNDRED HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS IN THAT OFFICE.
IS THAT A VERTICAL PROSECUTION
MODEL ISN'T JUST HELPFUL IN
TERMS OF BRINGING THE
PERPETRATORS TO JUSTICE BUT IN
BEGINNING TO REPAIR THAT VICTIM
AND BRING SOME STABILITY TO
THEIR LIVES. WHICH LAST LONG
BEYOND THE OUTCOME OF TRIAL AND
SO. I'D ALSO POINT OUT AS THEY
SAID HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS NOT A
PROBLEM JUST IN THE URBAN AREAS
OF OUR STATE.
BUT IN IN RURAL COUNTIES IN IN
COUNTIES THAT DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO EMPLOY A VERTICAL
PROSECUTION MODEL SO THAT'S WHY
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR SO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO. ALLOW
OTHER COUNTIES THE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE IN THAT IN
THAT METHOD OF OF PROSECUTION SO
WE ASK YOUR AYE BUT. THANK YOU.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KATE DE FERRARI FROM THEIR
CONTRA COSTA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE I'VE BEEN A. PROSECUTOR
THERE FOR TWELVE YEARS I SPENT A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME IN
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE UNIT MY
HUSBAND'S ALSO PROSECUTOR AND
OUR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PROSECUTOR.
I CAN TELL YOU.
YOU'VE HEARD THE SAYING THAT.
THE MEASURE OF OUR SOCIETY IS
HOW WE TREAT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS THAT
COME THROUGH OUR OFFICE. THERE
ARE VULNERABLE THEY ARE SOME OF
THE MOST BROKEN PEOPLE THAT YOU
HAVE EVER ENCOUNTERED.
AND. VERTICAL PROSECUTION ALLOWS
THEM TO HAVE THAT CONSISTENCY TO
HAVE THAT PROSECUTOR THAT. IF
THEY'VE COME FORWARD FINALLY IN
THERE FOR AND THEY'RE
COOPERATING TO WITHOUT VERTICAL
PROSECUTION THAT FILE IS GOING
TO BE PLACED ON A SHELF
SOMEWHERE AND IF THAT VICTIM
BECAUSE IT'S LIKE WELL LET'S SEE
WHERE IS THIS CASE WHAT STAGE IN
THE PROCEEDINGS IS THERE.
WHAT PROSECUTOR CAN HANDLE THIS
PHONE CALL AND ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS THAT'S JUST SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE AND IT?
IT HINDERS A OF SUCCESSFUL
PROSECUTION AND IT'S NOT
FOCUSING ON WHAT WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON WHICH IS THE VICTIM.
SO THIS BILL IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL.
IT'S.
IT'S IN SOME WAYS IT'S UPSETTING
THAT WE WOULD EVEN NEED A BILL
LIKE THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY THE ONLY WAY TO
HANDLE THESE CASES. AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN IF YOU DON'T
THINK IT'S BECAUSE IT'S IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES IT IS IT IS IN. ITS
IN YOUR YOUR HOTELS IT'S IN YOUR
MASSAGE PARLORS IT'S IN YOUR
NAIL SALONS IT'S IN YOUR EARS ON
YOUR STREET.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING.
WHO CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IS SUPPOSING THIS
BILL UNLESS IT'S ALSO AMENDED?
TO PROVIDE FOR.
AT PUBLIC DEFENDERS
AS THE PROPONENTS OF SAID THESE
CASES ARE VERY COMPLICATED FOR
DEFENDANTS ON. THE US SENATE SO
SCAN OF SOMETIMES BEANS LIFE IN
PRISON.
AND WE NEED RESOURCES.
THE DISPARATE A TREATMENT A
PUBLIC DEFENDER OFFICES ALREADY
EXIST.
US STATEWIDE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OFFICES ARE FUNDED AYE THE
HIGHER LEVEL WITH BOTH OF COUNTY
FUNDS AND WAS STATE GRANTS.
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER OFFICES
CANNOT ADEQUATELY PROVIDE
CONSTITUTIONALLY MANDATED.
OUR CRIMINAL DEFENSE TO
INDIGENTS WHEN MORE MORE FUNDS
GO TO THE PROSECUTION.
NATIONWIDE APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
TWO PERCENT A FELONY DEFENDANTS
ARE IN LARGE STATE COURTS ARE
REPRESENTED BY PUBLIC DEFENDER
SETS THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
FIGURES.
AND URBAN COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
LIKE ALAMEDA THE PERCENTAGE IS
HIGHER.
ON IN ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
ON THE PROPONENT WAS TALKING
ABOUT ON THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ON PROGRAM THERE WILL IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. AND TWENTY SEVEN.
TEAM TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY HAD THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT POSITIONS.
AND A BUDGET OF ALMOST SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
ON THE PUBLIC DEFENDER HAD A OF
ON ALMOST A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
TWO FULL TIME EQUIVALENTS.
ALMOST ON HALF OF WHAT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY HAD.
AND THE PAD A BUDGET OF ABOUT
FORTY FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THOSE ARE NUMBERS
ALAMEDA COUNTY THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IS A
RELATIVELY WELL FUNDED COMPARED
TO THE REST OF THE STATE.
AND.
.
SOME COUNTIES IT'S JUST
OVERWHELMING AND FRESNO COUNTY
FOR INSTANCE PUBLIC DEFENDERS
HAVE CASELOADS BETTER FOUR
TIMES.
RECOMMENDED ON A MAXIMUM OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CASES.
THIS ON EQUAL FUNDING A ROADS
CONFIDENCE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THAT MAKES.
ON. AB DIVIDES CALIFORNIANS AND
IT MAKES PEOPLE FEEL THAT THE
DECK IS STACKED AGAINST THEM.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU TO
AMEND THIS BILL ALSO INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC DEFENDER
OFFICES. IN COUNTIES WHERE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OFFICES GET
GRANTS TO PROSECUTE.
.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
BUT
I BELIEVE IT WAS THE SUPPORT.
THAT I MISSED
IF I DIDN'T MOVE FAST ENOUGH.
MONEY VALENTINE FROM CALIFORNIA
PROTECTIVE PARENTS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK. YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I'M NOT.
WHICH A LOT OF BILLS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
OBVIOUSLY I THINK OF.
THIS THIS HOUSE CAESAR'S IS ONE
OF THE.
MORE DAMAGING SCOURGES HONOR
SOCIETY TODAY.
AND.
I'M JUST LIKE WELL YOU GUYS ARE
BRINGING HER BOTH BOTH TWO YOUNG
LADIES ARE BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
A BECAUSE REALLY.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE.
DHEA.
THE TRIAL OF THESE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE IN THEIR LIVES AND
RETURN THE BETRAYAL OF TRUST AS
DEFTLY ONE OF THE OUTCOMES.
THAT THESE VICTIMS WILL DEVELOP.
AND SO.
I THINK WE'LL GET THIS REMEDY
HELPS FOSTER TRUST.
AND BRING TRUE TO OUR JUDICIAL
SYSTEM.
BECAUSE.
THEY DESERVE THAT WE ALL DESERVE
THAT AND WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH A VERY
UNUSUAL SET OF.
DRAMATIC CIRCUMSTANCES SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS.
TO OUR OF VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
SEE ANOTHER FOR THE QUESTION TO
MAKE LOVE
I JUST I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ABOUT.
WE NEED A MOTION FIRST.
I'M WAITING ON A MOTION.
WE WILL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED. A.
JUST ENJOYS AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION.
I WOULD.
WOULD ADVISE YOU THE LEAST LOOK
INTO WHAT OF THE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ARE LOOKING INTO. WE
NEED WE.
A ASSEMBLYMEMBERS A YOU KNOW WE
NEED ALL THE HELP WE CAN GET TO
TO TO STOP THIS SO WHATEVER WE
CAN DO.
.
THE BRING FUNDING TO THE
SITUATION WOULD BE VERY GOOD AND
INCLUDE AS MANY PIC HELPERS AS
POSSIBLE. AND SAY THANK YOU
SHARES RECOMMEND AYE VOTE.
ON AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS DO PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
LACKEY AYE CARILLO.
CATALOGUER DUB.
CATALOG IT UP AYE KILEY. KILEY
AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THE BILL PASSED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND SECOND ITEM THIRTY ONE
TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS
I'D TODAY I'D LIKE TO.
PRESENT A. B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY
NINE A BILL TO ENHANCE.
PUBLIC SAFETY BY KEEPING GUNS
OUT OF THE HANDS OF THOSE
ALREADY PAID PROHIBITED FROM
HAVING THEM. IN LIGHT OF THE
MOST RECENT MASS SHOOTINGS THE
NATIONAL SPOTLIGHT HAS FOCUSED
ON GUN LAWS AND THEIR IMPACT ON
SOCIETY.
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY NINE ALIGNS
WITH FEDERAL LAW BY IMPOSING A
LIFETIME BAN ON THE POSSESSION
OF FIREARMS FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF A MISDEMEANOR.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OFFENSE.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE RARE
INSTANCES WHERE CALIFORNIA'S GUN
LAWS IS MORE LENIENT THAN
FEDERAL LAW.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOT CREATING A
NEW CLASS OF PROHIBITIVE PERSONS
NOT OWNING A FIREARM BUT MERELY
HELPING. KEEP GUNS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY
PER HEAD OF PROHIBITED FROM
HAVING THEM. CURRENT STATE LAW
IS AN ADEQUATE TO FULLY PROTECT
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
ACCORDING TO THE LA DA'S OFFICE
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
POINT NINE PERCENT OF THE FELONY
FIREARMS LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
EIGHTY FOUR POINT NINE PERCENT
OF THE FELONY FIREARM CASES THAT
THE FAMILY VIOLENCE DIVISION
FILED THE DEFENDANT HAD A PRIOR
MISDEMEANOR DV CONVICTION.
ABUSED WOMEN ARE FIVE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE KILLED IF THEIR
ABUSER OWNS A FIREARM AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ASSAULTS
INVOLVING A GUN ARE TWELVE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO END IN DEATH.
THEN ASSAULTS WITH OTHER WEAPONS
OR PHYSICAL HARM.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
COALITION AGAINST DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
ONE OF THE MOST CHRONICALLY
UNDER REPORTED.
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF ALL
PHYSICAL ASSAULTS PERPETRATED
AGAINST FEMALES BY THEIR
PARTNERS ARE REPORTED TO THE
POLICE.
ONLY TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
REPORTED.
LET ALONE ARRESTED PROSECUTIONS
PROSECUTED AND CONVICTED. THIS
MEANS THAT SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
GO UNREPORTED.
THERE IS A VERY REAL CONNECTION
BETWEEN PAST DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND A PROPENSITY TO FUTURE VOTE
VIOLENCE INCLUDING MASS
SHOOTINGS.
TRAGICALLY CHILDREN ARE THE MOST
COMMON VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC MASS
SHOOT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MASS
SHOOTINGS.
WHILE WE THERE ARE NO GOVERNMENT
STATISTICS ON HOW MANY CHILDREN
ARE KILLED IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATIONS. THE HOBBIT THE
HUFFINGTON POST FOUND THAT
CHILDREN UNDER SEVENTEEN YEARS
OLD MADE UP THE LARGEST GROUP OF
VICTIMS IN ITS STUDY.
AND WHILE WE SIT HERE AND
DISCUSS THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES NEARLY
THREE U. S. WOMEN EVERY DAY ARE
KILLED BY AN INTIMATE PARTNER
AND NEARLY FIFTY PERCENT OF
THOSE ABOUT THE VIOLENCE CRIMES
GO UNREPORTED.
THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF JUSTICE
STATISTICS SAYS THAT AN AVERAGE
OF ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND INSTANCES OF
NONFATAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WERE
REPORTED TO POLICE. ANNUALLY
OVER THE PAST DECADE AND FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND
INSTANCES WENT UNREPORTED.
FOR THE MEMBERS.
WHO FOR THE MEMBERS WHO QUESTION
WHY SINGLE OUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WELL? I HOPE I WAS ABLE TO SHED
LIGHT ON NOT ONLY THE DATA MOST
IMPORTANT HE THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF LIVES THAT HAVE
BEEN LOST OR AFFECTED BY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ABUSE IN BY
INVOLVING A FIREARM.
HERE WITH ME UP.
I'M REYES AS KRYSTEN EXEC WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE JOHN MYERS
FAMILY LAW ATTORNEY AND LOCAL
LAW PROFESSOR.
I I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
MAY BEGIN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KRISTEN NAMES THAT COME WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS TO
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO HIGHLIGHTED
THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND FIREARMS
IS A DEADLY.
IT IS WHY CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY TAKEN SO MANY STOPS AND
WHY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX THERE'S BEEN
A LIFETIME BAN ON MISDEMEANOR.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OFFENDERS FROM
POSSESSING OR OWNING A FIREARM.
BY TAKING THE STEPS TODAY
CALIFORNIA IS ABLE TO BRING ITS
PROHIBITION I'M MORE CLOSELY IN
LINE WITH THE FEDERAL LIFETIME
BAN.
AND HELP MAKE SURE THAT HERE AT
HOME IN CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
LEVEL PROSECUTORS IN CALIFORNIA
COURTS ARE ABLE TO.
ADDRESS OF THOSE WHO MAY HOW.
MAY CHOOSE TO TRY TO OWN OR
POSSESS A FIREARM TEN YEARS
ELEVEN YEARS TWELVE YEARS PAST
AND THEIR INITIAL MISDEMEANOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CONVICTION.
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE UP AND ONLY
EXISTS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND
IS ONLY FEDERAL PROSECUTORS THAT
CAN TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
MOVING THOSE FORWARD. WE KNOW
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS ARE OFTEN.
FOCUS ON OTHER PRIORITY IS
UNLIMITED AND THEIR RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THEY ALSO. WE APPRECIATE
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN BRING THIS
FORWARD AND CONTINUING TO LIFT
UP THIS THAT DEADLY AND OUR
SECTION OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EMPIRE ARMS RESPIRABLE.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MY NAME'S
JOHN MYERS I'M A PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF THE PACIFIC
MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND I'LL JUST VERY
BRIEFLY I'M. JUST ADD THESE
IDEAS YOU WHY A LIFETIME BAN
FOR.
MISDEMEANOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE A LIFETIME
BAN FOR MISDEMEANORS OF VIOLENT
CRIMES THAT ARE NOT. VIOLENCE I
THINK THE ANSWER TO THAT IS
SIMPLY THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
DIFFERENT. IT'S JUST DIFFERENT
THAN OTHER.
VIOLENT CRIMES AND THE REASON IS
YOU JUST CAN'T GET RID OF THE
GUY.
I SPENT A LOT OF MY TIME IN
FAMILY COURT REPRESENTING
CHILDREN IN HIGH CONFLICT
CUSTODY CASES AND REPRESENTING
WOMEN IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER CASES IN YOLO
COUNTY.
THE PROBLEM WITH FAMILY LAW AND
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IN INTIMATE
RELATIONSHIPS IS THAT THE
RELATIONSHIPS CONTINUE. EVEN IF
YOU'RE NO LONGER MARRIED HER IN
THAT RELATIONSHIP SO THE NEED
FOR PROTECTION GOING FORWARD
UNLIKE THEIR YOU KNOW THE
ASSAULT AND BATTERY ON THE
STREET.
IT'S DIFFERENT.
THE RELATIONSHIP IS STILL THERE
EVEN THOUGH IT MAY BE OVER
THAT'S WHY A BAND FOR A LIFETIME
IS ESSENTIAL IN THIS PARTICULAR
CONTEXT I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MISTY.
A AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN.
VIOLENCE WE ARE IN SUPPORT I'M
THE THIRD PERSON SHALL BE VERY
BRIEF IN GENERAL UP WE WOULD
LIKE CALIFORNIA. LAW AND
PROHIBITIONS TO MATCH FEDERAL
LAW IN THE RARE TIMES THAT
FEDERAL LAWS STRONGER AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS THAT.
THAT WAY WE CAN DO THE
ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA IMPISH
PARTICULARLY IN THIS HAS NOT
BEEN MENTIONED YET WITH OUR ARE
PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM PROGRAM
SO THAT SOMEONE WHO HAD A.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROHIBITION
IN AND UP THE FEDERAL
PROHIBITION IS IN APPS
A WEEK COULD ACTUALLY BE THE
ENFORCEMENT MEASURES TO DISARM
THE PERSON.
TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
YES ANY OTHER.
YOU WOULD HAVE SUPPORT JULIE
BORN HAFTAR REPRESENT WE'VE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY'S PRIMARY
PROVIDER OF SERVICES FOR
SURVIVORS AND VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CALVIN QUICK BAY AREA STUDENT
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT.
KIND OF VALENTINE CALIFORNIA
PROTECTIVE PARENTS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THINKING.
MICHELLE DUDLEY CALIFORNIA
PROTECTIVE PARENTS OF SOLANO
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU.
AND ME WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MORNING AND POLITICAL WITH A
CELLULAR CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION A. B. I THIRTY ONE
TWENTY NINE.
THAT WE DO NOT OPPOSE GUN
CONTROL MEASURES THAT PROTECT
PUBLIC WELFARE AND ARE NON
DISCRIMINATORY AND FAIR.
UNFORTUNATELY A. B. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY NINE DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST PEOPLE WITH A
MISDEMEANOR RIGHT AND WITH A
MISDEMEANOR ON THEIR RECORD BY
ENACTING A LIFETIME BAN ON
ANYONE WITH A MISDEMEANOR.
RELATING TO. TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NO MATTER HOW MUCH TIME
HAS PASSED THE MATTER WHAT THEIR
REHABILITATION HAS BEEN LIKE.
THIS PERPETUATES THE HARMFUL AND
UNFOUNDED STEREOTYPE THAT
SOMEONE WITH A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION IS FOREVER DANGEROUS
IS INHERENTLY DANGEROUS AGAIN
REGARDLESS OF HOW MUCH TIME HAS
PASSED.
AND I WANT TO KNOW THAT WHEN A
POLICE OFFICER HAS BEEN
CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THEY CAN PETITION TO GET THEIR
GUNS BACK IMMEDIATELY. AND SO
UNDER THIS BILL WHICH DOES NOT
CHANGE THAT UNDER THIS BILL AND
A POLICE OFFICER CONVICTED OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COULD PETITION
TO GET THEIR GONE BACK THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE TO WAIT TEN
YEARS. BUT A CIVILIAN WOULD HAVE
A LIFETIME BAN AND THE SPAN IS
NOT WITHOUT CONSEQUENCES ON IF A
PERSON WHO HAS EVER HAD A
MISDEMEANOR CONVICTION.
FOR THESE CRIMES AND COMES INTO
THE POSSESSION OF A GUN THEY CAN
BE ARRESTED PROSECUTED
INCARCERATED FOR A FELONY.
AND THIS WILL CERTAINLY HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATE HARMON ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ACCORDING
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
IN CALIFORNIA NEARLY A FOURTH OF
THE FELONY ARRESTS OR ARREST FOR
FELONY. A GUN OFFENSES WERE OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE BLACK AND NEARLY
HALF WERE PEOPLE WHO ARE LATINO
AND THESE POPULATIONS MAKE UP
SIX AND A HALF PERCENT AND
THIRTY NINE PERCENT OF THE
POPULATION CALIFORNIA
RESPECTIVELY.
AND SO.
WE AGREE THAT WE NEED GUN
CONTROL THAT PROTECTS THE
PUBLIC.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE THAT THIS WOULD WOULD
DO THAT THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT
TEN YEARS ATTEND YOUR BAND IS
NOT SUFFICIENT. I'VE THIS BILL
STIGMATIZES AND DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST PEOPLE WHO HAVE EVER HAD
A MISDEMEANOR CONVICTION FOR ONE
OF THESE OFFENSES. ON AND WILL
HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
ON PEOPLE OF COLOR AND I WILL
NOTE THAT I I'M RECOGNIZED THE.
OF THE DATA PRESENTED THAT OF
THE.
LOW RATES OF REPORTING HAVE OF
ABUSE AND VIOLENCE AND.
I AGREE WITH THAT I AGREE THAT
THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM THIS BILL
DOES NOT ADDRESS THAT. ARMED AND
INSTEAD IT IT WOULD JUST HAVE
THIS DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
PEOPLE SO. FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. ORDER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE MOST COMMON LAGER DOVE.
THANK YOU SO I AM.
I HAVE A QUESTION I KNOW THIS IS
A INCREDIBLY.
.
PERSONAL BELL AND.
AS A SURVIVOR IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
THAT WE HAVE UNCOMFORTABLE
CONVERSATIONS LIKE THIS AS IT
RELATES TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I
WAS WONDERING IF SOMEONE COULD.
HELP DEFINE FOR ME WHAT
POSSESSION MEANS.
FOR THIS BILL.
THIS BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
POSITION IT'S ABOUT.
OF DYING BEING ABLE TO BUY A
GUN.
RIGHT.
NOUN IT'S A LIFETIME BAN ON
OWNING A GUN IS.
NOT POSSESSING A GUN IT'S OWNING
A GUN.
WELL IN MY STATE.
IT'S NOT.
NO IF SOMEONE. IS IN POSSESSION
OF A GUN FORTY YEARS AFTER
MISDEMEANOR CONVICTIONS ONE OF
THESE OFFENSES THEY AN. BE
PROSECUTED FOR A FELONY.
POSSESSION WERE PROBABLY MEAN
KNOWING POSSESSION NON.
AND IN TERMS OF CRIMINAL
SUBSTANTIVE CRIMINAL LAW. IF
SOMEBODY SNEAKS INTO YOUR OFFICE
AND SLIPS A HAND GUN IN YOUR BAG
YOU'RE NOT IN POSSESSION OF IT
CSUS.
WHO DO NOT STANDARD CRIMINAL LAW
BUT YOU BUT IF YOU'RE KNOWING
POSSESSION THEN YOU'RE IN
POSSESSION BUT IF I'M?
WITH SOMEONE IN A CAR.
AND THE GUN IS IN THE CAR.
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S IN THE
CAR BUT IF WE GET STOPPED
BECAUSE I'M BLACK BECAUSE THE
TAIL LIGHT IS OUT BECAUSE.
I AM BLACK AND SOMEONE STARTS
LOOKING IN THE CAR AND THEY FIND
IT.
THE D. A..
MAY MORE LIKELY THAN NOT ONE TO
INTIMATE THAT I KNOW. THAT THE
GUN IS IN THE CAR.
BECAUSE.
I AM BLACK.
BECAUSE PROBABLE CAUSE BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW THEY WANT TO.
.
WELL I DON'T WANT TO MAKE ANY
ANALYTIC CASTING ASPERSIONS BUT
YOU SEE WHERE I'M GOING WITH THE
QUESTIONING HOW ARE WE DEFINING
POSSESSION BECAUSE IT CAN MEAN I
OWN IT. IT CAN MEAN I. KNOW
WHERE IT IS BUT IT CAN ALSO MEAN
I JUST HAPPEN TO BE IN THE WRONG
PLACE AT THE WRONG TIME AND
THERE'S A GUN NEAR ME. AND THEN.
ALL SORTS OF THINGS BEGIN TO
COME TOGETHER SO IS THERE ANY
SORT OF SPECIFIC.
DEFINITION OR.
DEFINED SCOPE OF WHAT POSSESSION
MEANS FOR THIS BILL.
WELL I THINK YOU.
I MEAN IT IS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
.
YOU'RE RIGHT DEMOCRATS WE HAVE
THE SAME ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO
FOR A POSSESSION OFA FIREARM BY
A CONVICTED FELON AND SO OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
AND JUDGES ULTIMATELY HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THAT ISSUE IN THE
CONTEXT OF CARS AND SO FORTH ALL
THE TIME I CONFESS I'M NOT. UP
TO SNUFF ON THE ON THE CASE LAW
AT THAT IMMEDIATELY GENERALLY
UNDER SUBSTANTIVE LAW TO BE IN
POSSESSION OF DRUGS ARE IN
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
POSSESSION OF IT HAS TO BE
KNOWING POSSESSION SO. THE ISSUE
THAT YOU RAISED IS IS IS THE
REAL SUBSTANTIVE ISSUE. THERE'S
UNDOUBTEDLY HAS A GREAT DEAL
ESTABLISHED LAW ON IT SINCE WE
HAVE SO MANY PROSECUTIONS FOR
FELON IN POSSESSION OF A FIREARM
BY A FELON.
AND WE FREQUENTLY FIND GUNS AND
CARS I'M SURE IT'S BEEN
LITIGATED BEFORE I WISH I HAD A
MORE DEFINITIVE ANSWER FOR YOU.
YEAH I WOULD SAY THAT THAT.
SCENARIO IS NOT AN UNUSUAL ONE
AND AS ONE THAT THAT COMES UP.
OFTEN IN PEOPLE ARE CONVICTED
FOR UPS.
FELON IN POSSESSION OF A FIREARM
FOR A GUN IN THE TRUNK.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YES
MISCREANT.
THANK YOU UP FIRST AND I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL TO.
THIS COMMITTEE AND KNOW THAT
SHARING REAL LIVED EXPERIENCE
THAT HAVE. DRAMATIC IMPACT IS
NOT.
AND TO ALL THE THE TESTIMONY
THAT CAME INTO DAY THAT AGREES
WITH YOUR BILL I ALSO BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED TO EMPOWER THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN.
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WHAT I APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS
BILL IS THAT IT ACTUALLY BRINGS
CALIFORNIA LYING TO FEDERAL
STANDARDS AND I THINK THAT'S THE
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER
HERE IS A POLICY COMMITTEE.
THAT WE REALLY DO NEED TO THINK
ABOUT WHERE CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
IS WHERE THE FEDERAL LAW IS.
AND ALIGNING.
POLICY IN THAT MATTER SO.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BRINGING IT
TO OUR ATTENTION.
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU BY
MISTER CHAIRMAN JUST SO YOU KNOW
THAT YOU IT IS DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ABUSERS MY I
HAVE A PERSONAL STORY MY SISTERS
OF THE VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND HER ABUSERS DOUBLE
HARASSING HER. AND.
NOT DIRECTLY BECAUSE HE'S UNDER
A RESTRAINING ORDER BUT I'M SURE
AS SOON AS A RESTRAINING ORDER
IS LIFTED THEY'LL BE SOME
ATTEMPTS TO TO HARM HER. AND SO
FOR ME IT IS PERSONAL AND I AM
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ABUSERS
BECAUSE.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS GOES
UNREPORTED MY SISTER WAS BRAVE
ENOUGH TO SPEAK AND EVEN BECAUSE
SHE SPOKE SHE STILL BEING
HARASSED
AND I. YOU KNOW WE CAN SIT HERE
AND TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW THE THE
THE THE RIGHTS.
OF OF THE ABUSERS ALL ALL WE
WANT WHAT ABOUT THE RIGHTS FOR
THE VICTIMS AND THE DANGER
STATISTICALLY EIGHTY FOUR. LA
COUNTY EIGHTY FOUR POINT NINE
PERCENT
ARE THE VIOLENT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
ARE CAUSED BY FIREARMS HAD
PRIOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE A
MISDEMEANORS I AM LOOKING OUT
FOR THE VICTIMS AND WE ALSO TALK
ABOUT HOWL.
.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THOSE
STUDENT THAT SPOKE OUT OF THE
AND.
AGAINST.
OWNING GUNS BUT IN THIS CASE
WERE NOT.
SUPPORTING THAT.
SING CONCEPT ABOUT RESTRICTING
GUN OWNERSHIP.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE BUT FOR ME THIS IS PERSONAL
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE
FOR VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND AGAIN I CAN APPRECIATE THE
RIGHTS OF EVERYBODY ELSE BUT
WHERE THE RIGHTS OF THE VICTIMS
AND I TO ME THAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DOESN'T SEE
COLOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT MC
GENDER DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DOESN'T
SEE SOCIAL ECONOMIC.
CONDITIONS AND.
FOR THAT I I.
I'M VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
BILL AND I WILL CONTINUE
ADVOCATING FOR VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE REGARDLESS OF.
.
IF I MAY SEEM DISCRIMINATORY
AGAINST DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ABUSERS ARE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ARE.
AND AND I DID I KNOW YOU HAVE
YOUR PASSION ABOUT THIS.
AND.
AND HOPEFULLY.
.
JUST THIS DISCUSSION HAD NOT
DEVOLVE INTO.
BEING.
PREJUDICE TOWARD DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS I DON'T THINK
THAT WAS THE INTENT.
OF THE OPPOSITION.
.
SO.
AT SOMEONE.
WHO'S BEEN PART OF THE
VICTIMIZED VIOLENT WHO GREW UP
IN THE BEST BEST A VIOLENT.
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME OF SIXTY
ONE YEARS OLD.
IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE EVER
MENTIONED.
I'M SIXTY ONE YEARS OLD IT
HAPPEN IN MY FAMILY LOW SEVEN.
IT WAS BECAUSE ALCOHOL IS.
AND UNTIL.
THEY GOT TREATMENT.
MY FATHER AND STEPFATHER.
LEARN THAT WHAT THEY WERE DOING
WAS ROUGH.
DO.
I HAVE IMAGES IN MY HEAD. THAT'S
MY HEAD EVERYDAY.
EVERY DAY THAT I CAN'T GET OUT.
WHEN PEOPLE ASK YOU WHY AM I SO
CLOSE TO MY MOTHER. BECAUSE WE
WENT TO AT HELD TOGETHER.
SO.
THIS COMMITTEE. NOT ONLY.
WE'LL DO WHATEVER WE CAN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
VICTIMS.
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE WINNER
SURE THAT THOSE TWO BLACK MEN.
MY FATHER AND STEPFATHER.
ARE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
EITHER.
AND THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THEY DID CHANGE YOUR
LIFE.
THEY DID BECOME RESPECTABLE
MEMBERS
SOCIETY DATE DID GO TO CHURCH
EVERY DAY.
THEY DID STOP DOING THAT.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU'RE HEARING
IS LET'S.
MAKE SURE ONE.
WE DON'T DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
EITHER ONE.
I WOULD PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO FOR ME AND I'VE SAID THIS A
MILLION TIMES
FOR ME IT'S ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND SO AS I SPOKE TO YOU.
IT'S ON THE BOOKS.
FEDERAL LAW TAKING CARE OF IT
AND SO MIKE MIKE MIKE QUESTION
MORE.
IMPORTANTLY THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
IF THERE'S SOME SOME HOLES IN
THE SYSTEM WHERE WE'RE NOT
BANNING.
PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE COMMITTED DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IF THE NUMBERS ARE
GOING UP BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
IT ON THE BOOKS IN CALIFORNIA?
ON THAT DAY THAT'S.
MY CONCERN TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE CAN IMPLEMENT THIS IN A WAY
THAT.
.
IT'LL BE MOST.
EFFECTIVE AND HAVE THE MOST
IMPACT
SO THAT WE DO MAKE SURE THAT.
GUNS DO NOT GET IN THE HANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE VIOLENT.
PERIOD.
I DON'T CARE IF DOMESTIC I'LL
GIVE THE HATE CRIME I HAD A
BILL.
BANNING HATE CRIMES.
ON MISDEMEANOR HATE CRIME
INDIVIDUALS FROM OWNING GUNS FOR
TEN YEARS I WANT TO MAKE A
LIFETIME BAN.
SO I.
I GET IT I'M WITH YOU.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE
THAT'LL GET WE IMPLEMENTED.
THAT WE JUST DON'T MAKE LOS.
I BET ON THE OTHER SIDE ON
IMPLEMENTATION WE MAKE LAWS AND
THEN IT'S EITHER NEVER REALLY.
LET ACTUATED IN A IN A WAY THAT
WE FULLY HELPS.
OR IT'S DONE INCORRECTLY AND IT
CAUSES MORE HARM THAN GOOD.
AND THAT'S THAT'S WHEREWE'RE AT
AND AND I NEED TO APOLOGIZE TO
THE AUTHOR BECAUSE I HADN'T HAD
ENOUGH TIME. SO MANY BILLS TO
SIT DOWN WITH YOU.
AND FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN WE IMPLEMENT
THIS.
WHAT?
WHATEVER WAY WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS FOLLOWS ALONG
FEDERAL LAW THAT THERE ARE NO
HOLES.
IN A CRACK THAT IT DOES. WORK
WITH ARE THE SYSTEM TO HALF OF
FIREARMS THAT WE DO GO AFTER.
AND IF WE HAVE TO RETRIEVE GUNS
FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ABUSERS THAT WERE ABLE
TO GET THERE. THEY HAVE GUNS OR
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION HOW DO WE.
GET GUNS OUT A DANGEROUS
PEOPLE'S HANDS.
AND THAT'S REALLY REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT.
AND I'M I'M.
I BELIEVE WE CAN DO THAT IF IF
WE WORK TOGETHER TO GET TO THAT.
I'M. NOT SURE BEFORE THEY'RE
THERE YET AND SO I'M A LAYOFF
TODAY HOPEFULLY.
WE CAN CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION BUT.
I I FEEL YOUR PASSION. I
UNDERSTAND.
I'M NOT VOTING BECAUSE I THINK
WE WERE.
WE ALSO GOT I THINK OF THIS AND
THAT AND A SYSTEMATIC LOGICAL
WAY.
SO THAT WHAT EVER DISK
COMMITTEE.
PROVES.
IT MAKES SENSE
AND MOST IMPORTANT WE CAN GET
THE JOB DONE SO WE CAN PROTECT.
NOT ONLY YOUR FAMILY BUT EVERY
FAMILY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THAT DOES CERTIFICATE YOU
MENTION THAT THEY GO DOWN.
OR THEY JUST DON'T STAY THE SAME
WE KEEP PILING LAW A COUPLE
LAWLER COUPLE LAW COUPLE LAW.
AND WE HAVE HIS MOUND. OF
PAPERWORK BUT NOTHING GETS DONE.
BECAUSE THE IMPLEMENTATION PART.
WE FEEL GOOD. THAT WE GET THIS.
BUT THE IMPLEMENTATION PART.
FALL SHORT.
AND THAT'S WHY.
.
I WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO BRING IT
BACK NEXT YEAR BUT.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS TODAY.
SO I'M LAYING OFF TODAY. THANK
YOU.
AB.
IN B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NOT VOTING LACKEY
LACKEY AYE CARDIO.
CARILLO AYE CATALOGUER DEATH.
CAN HUNDRED OF NOT VOTING KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING.
QUIRK NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURES ON CALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR LIST BAKER.
THIRTY SIXTY FOUR ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO.
GOING AGAIN MEMBERS THINK YOU.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
TODAY A. B. THIRTY SIXTY.
FOR.
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS THE NEED
TO BETTER PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
BY FAILING TO REPEATEDLY BREAK
OUR GUN LAWS REPEAT OFFENDERS.
CURRENTLY A FELON FOUND
ILLEGALLY POSSESSING A FIREARM
CALIFORNIA TO BE SENTENCED TO
SIXTEEN MONTHS TWO YEARS THREE
YEARS. AND A FELON IN POSSESSION
OF A FIREARM IS NOT CONSIDERED A
PROBABLE OFFENSE WHICH MEANS
THAT THE FELLOW WHO'S CONVICTED
OF THIS AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
IS NOT GOING TO SEE MORE SEVERE
PENALTIES FROM THE JUDGE THE
JUDGE IS UNABLE TO PROVIDE MORE
SEVERE PENALTIES FOR REPEAT
OFFENDERS. AND NO JAIL TIME IS
REQUIRED FOR REPEAT OFFENDERS.
IN PRACTICE WHAT CALIFORNIA'S
LAW DOES IS SLAP THESE OFFENDERS
ON THE REST.
AB THIRTY SIXTY FORWARD RAISE
THE SENTENCE FOR REPEAT
OFFENDERS TO A TERM OF FORCE
FIVE OR SIX YEARS IN PRISON AND
JAIL. IF THE FELLOW THAT'S BEEN
FOUND IN POSSESSION OF A
FIREARM.
AGAIN THIS BILL IS GEARED
TOWARDS REPEAT OFFENDERS NOTHING
IS CHANGED FOR THOSE WHO FIRST
TIME OFFENSE.
.
ARE FOUND TO BE IN POSSESSION OF
A FIREARM.
THE HIGHER TRIAD ONLY KICKS IN
IF THE PERSON WANTS.
CONVICTED OF VIOLATING THE GUN
LAWS DOES IT AGAIN. THIS GIVES
THE JUDGES THE DISCRETION THEY
NEED NOW. IN ORDER TO SENTENCE
APPROPRIATELY THOSE WHO DON'T
CARE ABOUT OUR GUN LAWS AND THEY
REPEATEDLY OFFEND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
AND RIGHT NOW MEMBERS IF IF YOU
TAKE A MOMENT TO. THINK ABOUT
THIS THESE ARE FOLKS WHO SAID I
DON'T CARE WHAT OUR LAWS SAY IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE MANY STRICT
RIGOROUS GUN LAWS I'VE SUPPORTED
ALMOST ALL OF THEM. AND AND
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS TARGETED
SPECIFICALLY AT THOSE REPEAT
OFFENDERS.
I'M IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I'M GRATEFUL FOR
BIPARTISAN COOPERATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I THOUGH
TODAY. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS KATIE DE FERRARI
FROM THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'VE BEEN ON THE FELONY FILING
DESK AT THE PITTSBURGH POLICE
DEPARTMENT NOW FOR TWO YEARS
I'VE I REVIEW ALL THE FELONY
CASES THAT COME OUT OF
PITTSBURGH ANTIOCH IN BRENTWOOD.
THESE ARE GENERAL FELONIES THESE
OF THE ROBBERIES THE SHOOTINGS
THE ASSAULTS AND OF COURSE THE
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM BY A
FELON.
IN VIOLATION A TWENTY NINE
EIGHT HUNDRED.
THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH DISCUSSION
ABOUT.
GUN VIOLENCE AND THE SENSELESS
LOSS OF OF LIVES.
AND I THINK.
WHAT WE CAN? I MEAN WE WANT TO
HAVE THE POWER TO STOP THAT AND.
I THINK THIS IS ONE STEP ONE
IMPORTANT STEP IS TAKING THE
FIREARMS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT SHOULDN'T HAVE THEM.
.
HOW DOES THIS BILL DO IT IT IT?
IT ADDRESSES TWO CRITICAL
SITUATIONS ONE IS INCREASING THE
TRIAD.
IF THE DEFENDANT IS GETTING
SENTENCED TO PRISON FOR GUN
POSSESSION.
AND WHEN I SAY POSSESSION I
MEAN.
CONSTRUCTIVE POSSESSION AND
ACTUAL POSSESSION BOTH OF WHICH
REQUIRE KNOWLEDGE THAT THE GUN
IS PRESENT.
.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT.
WILL MAY BE ALMOST ALL OF US
COULD AGREE THAT SOMEONE HAS
BEEN CONVICTED OF A FELONY.
SHOULDN'T POSSESS FIREARMS.
MAYBE I'M. I'M LOW OFF ON THAT
BUT I THINK I THINK THAT'S THAT
THE VIEW OF MOST CALIFORNIANS.
AND IN PEOPLE THAT ARE CAUGHT
WITH FIREARMS THAT SHOULDN'T
HAVE THEM NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE HOW DO WE SEND THAT
MESSAGE AND AND KEEP OUR STREETS
SAFE.
ONE WAY TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE IS GIVING THAT POWER
BACK TO THE JUDGES GIVING THE
JUDGES THE DISCRETION.
TO AND THE LATITUDE TIP
APPROPRIATELY SENDS THAT
INDIVIDUAL AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
GUN DOES.
YOU KNOW THIS ISN'T REQUIRING A
MANDATORY PRISON SENTENCE.
ALTHOUGH I WOULD SUPPORT THAT.
BUT I DO THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW JUDGES HOW
THE LATITUDES ON ONE END OF THE
SPECTRUM TO. PROPERLY SENTENCE A
DEFENDANT THAT'S THAT'S CAUGHT
WITH A FIREARM AND HAS BEEN
CONVICTED OF A FELONY.
AND THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME
PEOPLE ARE GETTING NO JAIL TIME
THEY'RE GETTING PROBATION
SENTENCES THE ACTUAL PRISON
SENTENCES ARE. I WOULD SAY RARE
IN IN MY COUNTY.
WE HAVE.
I I DO A LITTLE BIT OF RESEARCH
I FOUND THAT A DEFENDANT THAT
WAS JUST SENTENCED IN JANUARY HE
HAD FIVE PRIOR FELONIES.
AND HE WAS CAUGHT WITH A LOADED
FIREAM UNDER THE SEAT OF HIS
VEHICLE HE HAD A GUN HOLSTER.
.
TAPED HE HAD METHAMPHETAMINE
ANNEMASSE PIPE ON HIS PERSON AND
A NINE YEAR OLD SON IN THE
BACKSEAT.
AND FIVE PRIOR FELONIES.
AND HE RECEIVED PROBATION AND A
SIX MONTH JAIL SENTENCE
SO.
THAT END OF THE SPECTRUM IS
COVERED IT'S COVERED IN MY
COUNTY.
BUT WHAT IF YOU HAVE.
.
YOU NO ANOTHER EXAMPLE MIGHT BE
SOMEBODY THAT HAS.
A REALLY OLD CONVICTION A
FELONY FOR COCAINE POSSESSION.
AND THAT PERSON IS CAUGHT WITH A
FIREARM IN NAY HAVE NO CRIMINAL
RECORD BETWEEN THAT CONVICTION
IN THE EIGHTIES OF THE COCAINE
POSSESSION AND NOW THEY'RE
CAUGHT WITH A FIREARM. MEAN THE
JUDGE HAS THE DISCRETION TO
APPROPRIATELY SENTENCED THAT
PERSON.
BUT NOW AT THE OTHER END OF THE
SPECTRUM HOW ABOUT THE VIOLENT
FELONS THAT WAS CONVICTED OF YOU
KNOW DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR.
IS REPEATEDLY CAUGHT WITH A
FIREARM AGAIN AND AGAIN THE MOST
THAT PERSON CAN GET IS THREE
YEARS OF OF STATE PRESENT AND
NOT A SERVICE FIFTY PERCENT SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS.
AN EIGHTEEN MONTH SENTENCE IS
THE MOST THAT THAT PERSON CAN
GET.
.
SO I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY ANOTHER
WAY THIS BILL DOES IT. TALKING
ABOUT MISDEMEANORS PEOPLE THAT
MIS USE WEAPONS MISUSE FIREARMS
AT THE MISDEMEANOR LEVEL
SHOOTING AT AN INHABITED
DWELLING.
ASSAULT OR BRANDISHING A
FIREARM IN THE PRESENCE OF A
POLICE OFFICER.
THOSE OUR MISDEMEANORS WHERE
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
JUST HAVE THE TEN YEAR BAN.
SO I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER
IMPORTANT ADDITION THAT THIS
BILL BRINGS.
.
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO PEOPLE.
ENCLOSING PEOPLE THAT HAVE
COMMITTED FELONIES THEY
SHOULDN'T. THAT YOU KNOW THAT IF
SHOT IN PEOPLE'S HOMES HAVE
BRANDISHED FIREARMS AROUND
POLICE SHOULDN'T BE PERMITTED TO
EVER HAVE A FIREARM PUBLIC
SAFETY DEMANDS THIS SO IF WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT REDUCING. GUN
VIOLENCE.
I THINK WE NEED TO GIVE THAT
THE JUDGE HAS THE DISCRETION TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITY SAFE AND I
THANK YOU FOR. THIS BILL.
CLARK THANK YOU. DON'T ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DETERMINE MEMBERS THANK YOU ROY
GRIFFITH CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION STANDING STRONG WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT DA'S OF THE
STRAIGHT AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON HALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SPORT FAQ.
CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN OF THE VELVET
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SEAN UNDER WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND.
MORE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CORSO'S ALONE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
SO.
THANK YOU.
TIM MACMAHON STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
BUT ARE GO GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. ARM WHERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
FIRST IT'S NOT NEEDED ON THE
PROPONENTS I WAS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
AND.
THERE IS ALREADY ADEQUATE
SENTENCING DISCRETION TO.
PUNISH REPEAT OFFENDERS REPEAT
OFFENDERS USING THAT DEFENDERS I
DON'T WANT TO BE PUNISHED.
BUT OF SOMETIMES I FEEL THAT
WAY.
FIRST UNDER PENAL CODE SECTION
SIX SIX SEVEN POINT FIVE.
.
SOMEONE CAN BE PUNISHED WITH
THEM ONE YEAR PRIOR FOR EVERY
TIME THEY'VE BEEN TO STATE
PRISON IF THEY'VE BEEN CHARGED
WITH A FELONY.
TWO IF THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN ARE
CHARGED AND CONVICTED WITH A
VIOLENT FELONY SUCH AS A
ROBBERY.
IT IS A STRIKE AND THEY CAN BE
THAT THE NEW FELONY THE BASE
TERM CAN BE DOUBLED SO. INSTEAD
OF SIXTEEN TWO THREE IT COULD BE
DOUBLED TO. US SIX YEARS BY THE
JUDGE SO GOOD. AND THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CHARGES THE STRIKE
THE JUDGE CANNOT.
DISMISS THE STRIKE OUT OF HAND
WITHOUT THE PROSECUTION'S
COOPERATION AND THREE ARM UNDER
THE FEDERAL SYSTEM THERE'S
TRIGGER LOCK FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
VIOLENT FELONIES AND THEN ARE.
FOUND IN POSSESSION OF GUNS AND
THEY CAN BE GIVEN LIFE SENTENCES
SO THERE'S ALREADY ADEQUATE
DISCRETION ACROSS THE BOARD.
ON THIS IS NOT.
I THINK WE HAVE FOUND THAT WE
HAVE NOT SUCCEEDED AS AND AS A
SOCIETY. IN JUST CONTINUING TO
TRY TO LOCK PEOPLE UP TO SOLVE
OUR PROBLEMS ALL WE HAVE BEEN A
CREATED IS MASS INCARCERATION. A
BOMB PRISON INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
AND WE'VE LEFT OUR COMMUNITIES
STARVING FOR RESOURCES FOR
EDUCATION FOR HEALTH FOR MEDICAL
CARE.
SO I WOULD ASK THAT IF YOU TRULY
WISH TO.
ATTACK THE COMMUNITY AND MAKE
THE COMMUNITY SAFER.
THAT YOU START.
WITH NOT PASSING BILLS THAT.
PUNISH PEOPLE WITH LONGER
SENTENCES THE JUDGES ALREADY
HAVE THAT DISCRETION. AND THAT
WE TURN TO THE ROOT CAUSES OF
OUR PROBLEMS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT THE GOOD MORNING TWENTY ONE
BACCUS FOR ELEVATOR CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS I WILL BE BRIEF.
THE. AS THE COMMITTEE KNOWS THE
RESEARCH IS CLEAR THE DETERRENT
TO CRIME IS THE HIGH LIKELIHOOD
OF APPREHENSION AND NOT THE FEAR
OF A LONGSENTENCE SO LONG
SENTENCES ONLY ARE COSTLY.
ADDITION TO OUR OVERCROWDED
PRISON JAIL SYSTEM WITH VERY
LITTLE POSITIVE. GENERALLY NO
POSITIVE EFFECT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY WHAT DOES WORK IS IS FEAR
OF APPREHENSION THE OTHER
WORKERS COMMITTEE REINVESTMENT
WHICH.
OF THE PRIOR WITNESS SPOKE TO.
THINGS ARE WORKING CLUED
INVESTING IN PRE K. INVESTING IN
EDUCATION INVESTING AFTER
SCHOOLS INVESTING IN MASS
INCARCERATION IS A FAILED
POLICY.
WILL NOT MAKE IT OUR STREETS
SAFER WILL NOT MAKE OUR HOMES
SAFER.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT COMMITTEE
REINVESTMENT WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
INCREASE PENALTIES THAT HAVE NO
POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALI ANY OTHER
WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION.
KATHY SHARON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU BREAK QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES LIST
KILEY.
I GOOD MORNING I'D JUST QUICK
QUESTION FOR THE OPPOSITION TO
STEP CLARIFIER TESTIMONY SO WHAT
IMPACT DO YOU THINK THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE ON GUN VIOLENCE.
I DON'T THINK YOU BELIEVE THERE
BE ZERO IMPACT ON GUN VIOLENCE
FROM THE SPELL.
EITHER YOU HAVE FOR THE
OPPOSITION.
WE DO WELL.
YOU NEED TO SPEAK INTO THE MIKE
I'M GOING TO ANSWER I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE WOULD BE ANY
IMPACT BECAUSE AS THE.
MISTER BACCHUS SAID ON THOSE
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT IT'S
APPREHENSION NOT THE PUNISHMENT
THAT IS THE DETERRENCE.
AND.
GIVING PEOPLE LONGER AND LONGER
SENTENCES. IS NOT THE DETERRENT
TO GUN VIOLENCE WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN THAT IF THAT WERE THE CASE
THEN CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE BEEN.
THE SAFEST PLACE IN THE WORLD
UP FOR THREE STRIKES FOR NON
VIOLENT NON SERIOUS FELONIES.
YES I KNOW I THERE'S CERTAINLY
SOME MIXED EVIDENCE AND A LOT OF
IT IS DEPEND ON CONTEXT IT'S OF
THE DETERRENT EFFECT OF ENHANCED
PENALTIES BUT EVEN IF WE. IF YOU
OF THERE WERE NO TO TURN AT
LEAST THESE PARTICULAR GUN
OWNING FELONS ARE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED LONGER THERE BE
SOME IMPACT ON GUN VIOLENCE FOR
THEM NOT BEING.
AT OUT THERE TO COMMIT MORE
CRIMES RIGHT EVEN IF IT'S A
SMALL ONE.
THROUGH THE CHAIR. I'M NOT AWARE
OF ANY STUDIES TO THAT SPEAK TO
THAT THAT THAT WOULD SUPPORT
THAT STATEMENT I'D BE HAPPY TO.
A REVIEW THEM IF YOU'RE.
BROUGH HAS SOME.
OKAY. OKAY EYES ZERO YOU DON'T
BELIEVE THAT HAVING THE AYE
FELONS WHO.
ARE REPEATEDLY FOUND TO BE
POSSESSING GUNS ILLEGALLY
INCARCERATED LONGER WOULD
NECESSARILY LEAD TO.
ANY REDUCTION IN GUN VIOLENCE
AND I AND I GUESS I UNDERSTAND
SECURITIES EXPERT QUICKNESS ONE
OF MY FINANCES.
ANY OTHER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YES.
I'D HOPE I DON'T SOUND LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD BUT COULD YOU ONCE
AGAIN SHARE.
WITH ME WHAT THE DEFINITION OF
POSSESSION IS.
FOR THIS BILL AS WELL I THINK
YOU MENTIONED BUT IF YOU COULD
SHARE TOGETHER. SURE IT ISN'T
KNOWING POSSESSION THERE'S ALSO
SOMETHING CALLED CONSTRUCTIVE
POSSESSION.
BUT BOTH REQUIRE KNOWLEDGE OF
THE FIREARMS PRESENTS SO.
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT'S ON
YOUR PERSON BUT ALSO.
OF A WEAPON OF A FIREARM IN A
VEHICLE.
.
YOU NO I I I HESITATE TO SAY
THIS FOR ALL THE.
POTENTIAL PEOPLE WITH FELONY
CONVICTIONS THAT WATCH THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
BUT.
YOU KNOW I REVIEW THOSE CASES
ALL THE TIME THAT THE FIREARM
THAT'S IN THE CENTER CONSOLE.
AND THERE'S FOUR OCCUPANTS OF
THE VEHICLE THOSE CASES ARE
GETTING FILED THOSE ARE. YOU
KNOW UNLESS WE ARE SEEM LIKE A
FURTIVE MOVE OF A FURTIVE IT ON
TO MY OWN IN YOUR COUNTY OR THEY
DON'T GET FILED AT ALL THEY'RE
NOT GETTING FILED BY ME.
IF I'M GONNA NEED D. N. A. OR
FINGERPRINTS ON THAT FIREARM OR
I'M GONNA NEED AN OFFICER TO SEE
SOME FURTIVE MOVEMENT BY A
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL WHERE YOU
KNOW. PUTTING THE THE.
FIREARM PERHAPS UNDERNEATH THE
SEAT BUT SIMPLY A FIREARM WITH
FOUR PEOPLE AROUND IT.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE THAT I'VE I
FEEL ETHICALLY THAT I COMPILE.
THEN YOU SHOULD BE HOW DID YOU
WE NEED YOU IN MY HEART THAT IT
DOES.
COURT ROOMS.
I GUESS MY SECOND QUESTION HAS
TO DO WITH ENFORCEMENT.
OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
ARE THERE WAYS TO GUARANTEE
CONSISTENCY OF ENFORCEMENT.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ACROSS ALL
COUNTIES.
I THINK THE WAY THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE TO DO THAT IS TO MAKE A
MANDATORY SENTENCE IT ON THIS ON
THE BOOKS WHICH I THINK.
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY FEELS A
LITTLE BIT UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
RIGHT NOW IT REALLY THE
DISCUSSION BALLS WITH THE
JUDGES.
YOU KNOW IT. UNLIKE MY MY
COLLEAGUE HERE.
YOU KNOW JUDGES CAN'T STRIKE
STRIKES FROM A COMPLAINER
INFORMATION.
AS LONG AS IT'S NOT WHAT WE
CALL A NICOLE PRIOR THE SIX SIX
SEVEN A ONE THAT A JUDGE CANNOT
STRIKE.
THAT ALL THE OTHER STRIKES GET
STRICT AND ALL THE TIME.
I SEE IN MY PRACTICE.
YOU KNOW ALL THOSE WITH THE
ROBBERIES THE ASSAULTS THE
SHOOTINGS THAT I'M FILING.
I MEAN.
I I DON'T KEEP STATISTICS I
SHOULD'VE GONE THROUGH MY FILING
LOG BEFORE COMING HERE BUT. I
WOULD GUESS THAT NINETY PERCENT
OF THOSE CASES I'M FILING THEN
THE TWENTY NINE EIGHT HUNDRED
IT'S LIKE.
AN AUTOMATIC CONSIDERATION AND
YOU KNOW I'M LOOKING AT THE RAP
SHEET AND I MAKING SURE IT'S
THERE OF COURSE BUT.
THE SHOOTINGS THE THE ROBBERIES
YOU KNOW CASES THAT ARE ARE
HARMING VICTIMS.
.
YOU KNOW THOSE ARE ARE NINETY
PERCENT OF MY PRACTICE I WOULD
SAY ARE OR PEOPLE THAT SHOULDN'T
BE HAVING THOSE FIREARMS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ON YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S I I APPRECIATE THE TIME
I I CERTAINLY AGREE THAT THERE'S
A LOT WE CAN BE DOING TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE FOR AND
PROVIDING MORE OPPORTUNITY. OF
FOR EVERYONE K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PATHWAYS TO CAREERS
AND OTHERWISE.
BUT I I STRONGLY DISPUTE.
STUDIES THAT SAY IF YOU'RE A
FELON.
AND YOU REPEATEDLY BREAK OUR GUN
LAWS.
THAT YOU CANNOT BE MADE SAFER BY
BEING TAKEN OFF THE STREETS.
AWAY FROM THE GUNS.
THE REASON WHY APPREHENSION.
IS WHAT WORKS IS BECAUSE YOU'RE
OFF THE STREETS.
YOU'RE NOT USING THE GUNS YOU'RE
NOT VICTIMIZING OTHER PEOPLE
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO
ONLY FOR REPEAT OFFENDERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVER.
I IT WILL ALWAYS WE SPOKE.
EXTENSIVE LOOKS.
BUT.
WE HAVE.
PROMOTION AND A SECOND.
THE KILEY SECOND BY MISTER
LACKEY.
BOB.
I KNOW WE SPOKE.
ON THIS FOR FOR QUITE SOMETIME.
.
SO.
SO MIKE MY CHALLENGES.
FOR ME AS CHAIR.
WHETHER OR NOT JUDGES.
AND SMART DE A.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THIS AND
HAD ENHANCEMENTS ANYWAY.
AND I KNOW THAT FOR ME THAT'S
MORE THE ARGUMENT THEN WHAT ARE
NOT PUTTING SOMEONE IN.
FOR TWO YEARS TO SIX YEARS OR
WHATEVER.
AND WE CAN DEBATE THAT ALL DAY
WE DO ALL THE RESEARCH AND WE WE
CAN FIGHT THAT ANOTHER TIME. BUT
FOR ME JUST JUST PHYLLIS NOT
PHILOSOPHY JUST ME AS. A SOMEONE
I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
WHAT IMPLEMENTING THE LAWS WE
HAVE ON THE BOOKS RIGHT NOW?
THAT WOULD DOING IT TO THE BEST
OF OUR ABILITY.
THAT'S MORE OF A CONCERN I
THINK THAT THE JUDGES.
HAVE THE DISCRETION
AS WAS STATED EARLIER TO TO ADD
ENHANCEMENTS DID DO YOU HAVE
SOME THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. AND THAT SADDAM
OF.
THE ENHANCEMENTS ARE NOT
NECESSARY WE DID TALK ABOUT SOME
OTHER THINGS.
BUT THE FORTUNE RAN OUT OF TIME
TO TO TO REALLY DEVELOP THAT.
SO THE CHURCH RECOMMEND A NO
VOTE BECAUSE I BELIEVE WE
ALREADY.
HAVE.
WHAT WE NEED TO TO TO BE ABLE
TO?
AT ENHANCEMENTS WITH THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
IF NOT MAYBE WE WORK TOGETHER TO
COME BACK NEXT YEAR.
BONTA TO WORK WITH THE JUDICIAL%
SYSTEM AND ASK THE JUDGES WHAT
DO THEY NEED TO WHAT'S BINDING
THEM FROM.
FROM FROM BEING ABLE TO KEEP.
THESE REPEAT OFFENDERS.
PEOPLE WHO MAY WANT TO BE CAREER
CRIMINALS
THAT MAY NOT WANT TO BE
REHABILITATED HOW DO WE KEEP.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE
GETTING TO HOW DO WE KEEP THEM
OFF THE STREETS AND AWAY. FROM.
GETTING.
POSSESSING GUNS AND THAT'S
USUALLY ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS
MCCONNELL SHOTGUN BLANKET WAY OF
DOING IT AND IN THE COURT WITH
THE JUDGE LOOKING AT THE
INDIVIDUAL.
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION LOT MUCH MUCH
BETTER THAN WE. CAN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WHICH KIND OF AN OVER
ARCHING VIEW.
SO UNFORTUNATELY CHAIRS
RECOMMEND AND NO VOTE.
AB THREE THIRTY SIXTY FOR THE
MOTION IS DE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY
LACKEY AYE GARCIA.
CATALOGUER DEATH.
CAN WATER DEPTH NO KILEY KILEY
AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
IMAGES ON CALL.
IF YOU GO UP.
DO LOW.
HOW MANY YOU GOT? YES.
IF I MIGHT BE EXPEDITIOUS IN
THE PRESENTATION OF THE OPIOID
PACKAGE BILL OF BILLS. THAT
THREE THREE.
BUT ALL YOURS.
I HEARD YOU CITED FOR SOMEBODY
OR THAT THIS IS NOT MINE YES
OKAY THIS IS.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ONE IF I MIGHT MISTER CHAIR YES.
I THIS IS WITH RESPECT TO
INTERSTATE PRESCRIPTION DATA
SHARING AND ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE THE INFORMATION. UP BEFORE
US FOR A PROVIDERS IN WITH
RESPECT TO PER. PRESCRIBING
MEDICATIONS IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
OF THE PREVENT AS MUCH DOCTOR
SHOPPING AS POSSIBLE WITH
RESPECT TO. OUR BORDERS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE HAVE
WITNESSES SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M VIRGINIA HEROLD
ON WITH THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
PHARMACY WE ARE THE ORIGIN OF%
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE WE ARE THE
SPONSOR OF SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO.
AND THE BOARD HAS NOT YET TAKEN
A POSITION ON THE THIRD BILL AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE. WE WILL
MEET NEXT WEEK TO DO SO.
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER WOULD HAVE.
MARY MCCARRON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AND ON OUR SIDE
DENTAL ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
OVER TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS. THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE
ARE ALSO SUPPORTING AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE. AYE WE BELIEVE
ENHANCING CURES TO ALLOW
CALIFORNIA'S PRESCRIBERS AND
DISPENSERS ESPECIALLY THOSE
PRACTICING ALONG THE STATE'S
BORDERS. OF SAID NEVADA OREGON
AND ARIZONA BY ALLOWING THEM TO
SHARE INFORMATION ACROSS STATE
LINES WILL HELP CURVED OVER
FIRST OVER PRESCRIBING OF
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. AND
PREVENT UNLAWFUL DOCTOR
SHOPPING.
AS AN ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
PROVIDERS COMMITTED TO SERIOUSLY
COMBATING THE URGENT OPIOID
CRISIS WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
THIS IS ONE OF THE MANY
SOLUTIONS TO THE PRESCRIPTION
DRUG ABUSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HARPER HAD ON BEHALF OF
SHATTERPROOF FOR NATIONWIDE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION A
DEDICATED TO OPIOID.
ABUSE PREVENTION. BUT WE
ACTUALLY SUPPORT ALL THREE BILL
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE FIFTY TWO
AND FIFTY THREE THESE WERE ALL
ISSUES THAT.
WE TRIED TO.
PUT INTO A BILL A COUPLE YEARS
AGO AND WE'RE VERY THANKFUL.
THAT MR LOW HAS DONE THIS.
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED BY THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS CONSUMER WATCHDOG TO
OFFER THEIR SUPPORT ON THOSE
THREE BILLS AS WELL SO DOES THIS
MEAN YOU DON'T HAVE TO COME UP
FOR THE NEXT TWO.
I YEAH BUT I'LL JUST SAY I'M
HERE THANK YOU OR OUTLAST
EVERYONE DITTO TO STAND UP A ONE
TIMER. I DON'T. DEPRIVE ANYBODY
OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS ON
FIFTY TWO FIFTY THREE BUT.
OKAY.
I'M JENNIFER SO MOST OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WERE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND RENTS PORTABLE
THREE.
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS ALL OVER A
GREAT CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE AND FIFTY
THREE. THINK A.
* MICHELLE REAVIS WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU.
ALISON RAINY WITH BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE AND
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MAUREEN HIGGINS REPRESENTING
VIACOM IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THANK YOU.
MAX PERRY ON BEHALF OF OCEAN IN
SUPPORT OF SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU.
A MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PRICE
STOCK IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS FOR IN A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION WE
THINK THE INTER OPERABILITY WILL
HELP PREVENT DOCTOR SHOPPING. AT
THE SAME TIME WE WANT TO WORK
THE AUTHOR ON IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE PATIENT PROTECTION
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL.
DRIVE VOTE TODAY ON THAT AND
HOPE TO GET TO UNCONDITIONAL
SUPPORT AND ALSO AN
UNCONDITIONAL SUPPORT OF
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO. LIKE STYLE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
SHARE MEMBERS CORSO'S ALONG TO
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE AND AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY. QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M GOING REAL FAST TOO FAST.
GOOD MY NAME BECAME A MATTER ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AND
I'VE BEEN ASKED BY THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
TOSS EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION.
HAS I THINK ANYONE WOULD ADMIT.
MEDICAL INFORMATION TO SOME OF
THE MOST SENSITIVE PRIVATE
INFORMATION THAT WE
HAVECALIFORNIA LAW RECOGNIZES
THAT
WITH THE MIA WHICH IMPOSES.
STRICT PRIVACY REGULATIONS ON
MEDICAL INFORMATION FEDERAL LAW
ASO HAS UNIQUE PRIVACY
REGULATIONS FOR MEDICAL
INFORMATION. UNFORTUNATELY THOSE
MEDICAL PRIVACY LAWS DO NOT
COVER CURIOUS OR THE DOJ BECAUSE
NEITHER THE DOJ OR CARRIERS ARE
COVERED ENTITY MEETING THE
DEFINITION.
THEREFORE THOSE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS DO NOT APPLY TO THE
INFORMATION AND CARES.
WHILE SOME WOULD ARGUE THAT
CARES JUST CAPTURES PRESCRIPTION
INFORMATION AND IS THEREFORE NOT
AS SENSITIVE AS MEDICAL
INFORMATION. PRESCRIPTION
INFORMATION CAN REVEAL MEDICAL
CONDITIONS INFORMATION AND CURES
ON WHO IS RECEIVING TESTOSTERONE
FOR EXAMPLE CAN REVEAL WHO MIGHT
BE A TRANSGENDER. MAN UNDERGOING
TRANSITION IT ALSO CAN REFER AT
CARES INFORMATION CAN ALSO
REVEAL IF SOMEONE IS A PERSON
LIVING WITH HIV OR AIDS OR WITH
CERTAIN MOTHER. MENTAL HEALTH.
CONDITIONS THEREFORE IT'S
INCREDIBLY PRIVATE SENSITIVE
INFORMATION AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOULD NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION WITHOUT A WARRANT.
TO SHOW THAT THEY HAVE REASON TO
NEED THIS INFORMATION.
SO WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS THIS
BILL AS AMENDED TO INCLUDE A
WARRANT REQUIREMENT FOR ALL
GOVERNMENT ACTORS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS MEGAN ARE TO BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO POSE UNLESS
AMENDED WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
CHAIR HAS BEEN. WILLING TO TALK
WITH US ABOUT THIS ITEM AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR.
QUITE SOME TIME BUT WE SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF THE ACLU. I'M AND
THE WARRANT REQUIREMENT AND I
JUST LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DIALOGUE.
THANK YOU AND THE OTHER. IN
OPPOSITION.
RYAN SPENCER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CADMIUM FAMILY PHYSICIANS REGRET
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE UNLESS
SUBMITTED FOR THE REASONS STATED
BY MY COLLEAGUES AT THE TABLE
LIKE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
GOOD MORNING DANIEL KENDO KAISER
ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE IS STILL YOU
OUTLINED WHERE OPPOSE THE LESS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RESEARCH I JUST WANT TO
MAKE A THREE POINTS WHICH IS
THAT PICKED A TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
ADDRESSED THE SUPREME COURT HAS
RULED. THAT IT IS LAWFUL TO
ACCESS.
THE CURES A DATABASE AND THAT
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT SEARCHES ARE
VERY RARE CASE NUMBERS ARE
ALWAYS NEEDED AND WARNS ARE
REQUIRED FOR SEARCHES OF
PATIENTS I JUST WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR. ON THAT AND WITH RESPECT
TO ASK FOR A VOTE.
CHEERS RECOMMENDING I AND I
THINK IF YOU.
NOT THAT DIETING AND I THINK.
BOTH OUR MOTION. THOUGH IT.
SECOND.
AND.
I KNOW ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO OF AIDS. TRANSGENDER AND.
DISCUSSION I'M SURE YOU VERY
SENSITIVE TO THAT.
SO I KNOW YOU WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THAT DOES NOT BECOME A
PROBLEM WITH THE CARE SYSTEM.
CHECK IT OUT.
ON AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. CHEN SIR I LACKEY LACKEY
I CARILLO.
CATALOGO DEATH.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING.
SANTIAGO.
MEASURES ON CALL.
THE TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS WITH RESPECT TO
DATA REPORTING. AND ADDS
SCHEDULED FIVE DRUGS TO THE
DATABASE WHICH IS OFTENTIMES OF
PRESCRIPTION ONLY CARVE SERVICE
WHICH CONTAINS CODING.
OF THIS IS ALSO ABOUT REQUIRES
THAT AND PHARMACISTS
HAVE. TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO
REPORT.
SUBSP
DESCRIPTIONS INTO THE DATABASE
AWARE AS RIGHT NOW IT DID IS
REQUIREMENT OF SEVEN DAYS A SO
WE WANT TO JOIN THE TIMELINE IN
REAL TIME. TO PREVENT AS MUCH
DOCTOR SHOPPING AS POSSIBLE AND
ADDITIONALLY HAVE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IN VIRGINIA HERALD CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF PHARMACY WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THE FOR THE WITHIN ONE
WORKING DAY TIMEFRAME FOR
REPORTING GET INTO CURES WILL
BETTER PHAM ENABLE
PRACTITIONERS.
AT THE TIME THEY HAVE TO CHECK
YOUR SYSTEM BEFORE WRITING A
PRESCRIPTION FOR AN OPIATE TO
KNOW THE BACKGROUND OF THE
PATIENT IN FRONT OF THEM.
AND SO CONSEQUENTLY WE FEEL
STRONGLY THAT'S IMPORTANT AND
AGAIN ALL IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM.
JEFF.
MARY MCKENNA OR CDA ALSO IN
SUPPORT FOR THE SIMILAR REASONS
AS BOP.
AND MAKE AN ORIGAMI HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT AS WE THINK THIS
IS A CRITICAL TOOL FOR DOCTORS
AND WE APPRECIATE THE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR TURNAROUND.
A CONFUSING ME OKAY.
BERRYHILL OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
HELLO MICHELLE REAVIS CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION WELL THE
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION WE
WANNA THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR WORKING WITH US. AND WE
TRUST THAT WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS OUR HOW
MINOR CONCERNS AS THE BILL MOVES
POWERED THANK YOU.
MAKE YOU.
OTHER ANY.
WHEN IN OPPOSITION.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF CALIFORNIA AGAIN AND
THAT IS RESPECTFUL OF HAS A MUCH
AMENDED POSITION. OPPOSITION IS
TO.
THE PEACE ADDING SCHEDULE FIVE
DRUGS HE CARRIES WE DON'T THINK
THAT WE SHOULD I HAD ADDITIONAL
PRIVATE MEDICAL INFORMATION TO
CARRIERS WITHOUT A WARRANT
REQUIREMENT TO PROTECT THAT
INFORMATION. HOME I WOULD ADD
THAT WHILE ADAM VARIOUS COURTS
HAVE RULED ON PIECES OF CARERS
AS THE ANALYSIS FOR THESE CARES
BELLS ACTUALLY NOTED THE COURTS
HAVE PUNTED ON WHETHER SEARCH OF
CARRIERS. CONSTITUTES A FOURTH
AMENDMENT SEARCH AND SO IT IS
QUITE POSSIBLE THAT COURTS COULD
RURAL THAT ANY SEARCH OF CARES
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD REQUIRE
A WARRANT ADDITIONALLY WHILE THE
DOJ'S GUIDELINES REQUIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO GET A WARRANT.
WHEN THEY'RE ACCESSING PATIENT
INFORMATION THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO GET A WARRANT WHEN
ACCESSING PROVIDER INFORMATION
WHICH IS A LITTLE CONFUSING
SINCE PROVIDER INFORMATION IN
ITSELF CONTAINS. PATIENT
INFORMATION AND SO IT IS A WAY
OF ROUNDS GETTING I'M A WARRANT
FOR PATIENTS SPECIFIC
INFORMATION AND STILL GETTING
PATIENT INFORMATION SO AGAIN FOR
THESE REASONS WE REQUEST THAT.
THE BILL BE AMENDED TO INCLUDE A
WARRANT REQUIREMENT FOR
GOVERNMENT ACTORS BEFORE ADDING
ADDITIONAL MEDICATIONS TO CARES
THINK YOU. THINK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
DANIELLE CAN A KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AS MY COLLEAGUE
OUTLINED WE REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS SEMANTIC THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OF ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. CLASS YES.
YEAH I'D I CLEARLY ADMIRE WHAT
TRYING TO BE ACCOMPLISHED YOUR
TO THE SECURITY DATABASE AND I
AND I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS.
IMPORTANT REMEDY TO THE TABLE
BUT I HAVE SOME CONCERN. OVER
THE ONE DAY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE.
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE
THERE'S QUITE A DISTANCE TEST TO
BE TRAVELING NOT EVERYBODY HAS.
AS EFFICIENT.
WITH ELECTRONICS STILL THE
PRESCRIPTION PADS ARE STILL.
BUT IT JUST SEEMS LIKE ONE DAY
AS A VERY VERY VERY FAST TURN
AROUND EVEN IF IT WAS.
CHANGE OF THREE DAYS IT SEEMS A
LITTLE MORE REASONABLE BUT I SEE
THAT THE PHYSICIANS ARE
OPPOSING.
BUT I I JUST HAVE.
SOME CONCERNS OVER THE
PRAGMATICS OF THIS
S. PRESENTATION IF YOU COULD
JUST ADDRESS THAT BEFORE.
WE WRAP THIS UP BY DEPRECIATE
THAT.
HOME CURRENTLY THE THAT TIME
PERIOD WITHIN WHICH YOU SUBMIT
DATA INTO CARE IS A SEVEN DAYS
MANY MANY PHARMACIES ARE THEY
DOING IT IN MUCH SHORTER PERIODS
OF TIME AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHERE WE HAVE FORTY NINE OTHER
STATES WELL FORTY EIGHT OTHER
STATES. FORTY NINE OF US HAVE PD
MPS.
FORTY FIVE OF THEM ACTUALLY HAVE
WITHIN ONE WORKING DAY AS A TIME
FRAME EXCEPT FOR ONE STATE THAT
HAS ONLINE REAL TIME. ENTRY.
AND THAT'S OKLAHOMA.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S TIME TO
TO READ THE PROGRAM UP CHAIRS TO
PUT THOSE POSITION AND READY TO
MOVE FORWARD TO ACCEPT THE DATA
AS IT COMES AND. MANY OF THOSE
ENTITIES IN THE HEALTHCARE
MARKET ARM ALRIGHT ALREADY
COMPUTERIZED AND PHARMACIES ARE
PERHAPS THE MOST COMPUTERIZED
AND HELP TO HAVE ONLINE
ADJUDICATION. BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THEY BILL FOR THEIR INSURANCE
COMPANIES SO WE THINK THAT IF
THEY CAN DO ONLINE ADJUDICATION
WITH RESPECT TO PAYMENT THEY
SHOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO PUT.
OPTION DRUG INFORMATION INTO THE
SYSTEM SO THE STATE'S
PRESCRIBERS AND DISPENSERS
CONCEIVE WHAT IT IS BUT I I
BELIEVE THE ASSOCIATION HAS
STARTED DISCUSSIONS AS WELL AS
WITH US SO THAT WE CAN. RESOLVE
THIS.
THANK YOU AND YOU MAY.
INCLUDE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT UP THERE
AND.
I NEED A MOTION.
YOU CAN'T.
FOR THE SECOND AB SURE.
WITH HIS BOOT WITH THAT THE
TEACHERS RECOMMEND I AND I
WOULD.
RECOMMEND THAT THAT SECTION YOU
READ ABOUT.
WARRANTS IN ENGLAND IF
HOPEFULLY SHARE WITH THE
OPPOSITION TACTIC IT KIND OF
ADDRESSES. A LOT INFUSE MORE IT
YOU NEED TO TALK TO.
TO MR MR LOW AND I CAN SHARE MY.
STEAM VICE CHAIR DATA ON.
WHETHER IT'S A HORSE AND WAGON A
PONY EXPRESS WE'VE WE'VE
IMPROVED ON THAT A LITTLE BIT IN
RURAL AREAS. I THINK WE GET THAT
INFORMATION TO. LOT OF WHAT IT.
THANK YOU.
CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
AYE CARILLO.
CATALOGO DOT.
CAN LONGER THAT I KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
THERE'S A LOCAL.
AND THE LAST ONE
SEVENTEEN FIFTY DURING.
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE
PRESCRIPTION PADS AND THE
CONTROLLING THEM RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE OFTENTIMES
CAN BECOME SIERRA ENTERPRISES IN
WHICH PRESCRIPTION CATS MAY GET
INTO THE BLACK MARKET. OF THIS
BILL A PROVIDES THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
FOCUSES ON THE SERIALIZATION OF
THESE PRESCRIPTION PAD SO THAT
WE CAN EFFECTIVELY TRACK THEM
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH RESPECT
TO ASK FOR A VOTE.
YES.
WHEN MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SHAUN OFTEN WITH CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION A
GENERAL COMMENTS BY SOMEONE
NUMBER LOW WE THINK THIS IS A
BALANCED MEASURE THAT. HELPS TO
IDENTIFY AND AND PREVENT
PRESCRIPTION PAD THEFT AND FRAUD
WHICH IN TURN FACILITATES OPIATE
ABUSE ASK YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU.
ALREADY A WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
XPERIA MATH LOW CHIN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER DAVID'S ALSO
THE CALIFORNIA Y. SITES
ASSOCIATION AND AMERICA'S
POSITION GROUPS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU A WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OUR ITEM BE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ACTUALLY
REMOVING OPPOSITION OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN SO WE
APPRECIATE. ALL THE OTHERS WORK
ON THIS THINKING.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
VERY MCKENNA CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO REMOVING
OPPOSITION AND WE LIKE TO THINK
THE OTHERS OFFICE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THOSE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ABOUT GERBIL.
THE SECOND.
REMOVED A* MUMS COME LATER.
TOUGH.
YES COLOR OF AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER AYE GENSLER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE CARILLO.
CATALOGUER DEATH KELLOGG ADEPT
AYE KILEY.
QUIRK
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
NOW HAVE.
GLORIA.
BACK OVER THAT AGAIN.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
ONE THIRTY ONE.
TO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MAY BEGIN
I MAY PROCEED EXCELLENT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS WELL
JUST IN TIME.
HOUSE OF THE LONG PAUSES FOR
AYE.
BIG MISTER CHAIR I THINK YOU FOR
ALLOWING MYSELF TO MY CO AUTHOR
BY JOINT AUTHORED A TO PRESENT
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE.
THINK ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE
WELL AWARE THAT IS A SENSE OF
UNREST IN COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AMONG THE
MANY REASONS CONTRIBUTING TO
THIS. SENTIMENT IS THE
INCREASINGLY COMMON ACQUISITION
OF MILITARY STYLE EQUIPMENT BY
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
RECOGNIZING THE HEIGHTENED
TENSIONS BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA
CONVENED A FEDERAL INTERAGENCY
LAW ENFORCEMENT EQUIPMENT
WORKING GROUP.
UNDER EXECUTIVE ORDER NUMBER
THIRTEEN SAY
EIGHT EIGHT AND TWENTY FIFTEEN.
THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER EMPHASIZE
THE NEED TO BETTER COORDINATE
FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF CERTAIN FEDERAL
COMMITMENT BY STATE LOCAL AND
TRIBAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AMONG OTHER ISSUES THE WORKING
GROUP A DEVELOPED A LIST OF
ITEMS THAT THEY DETERMINED AFTER
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION SHOULD BE
SUBJECT TO ADDITIONAL CERTAIN
CONTROLS PRIOR TO THEIR TRANSFER
TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
LATE LAST SUMMER HOWEVER THAT
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
RESCINDED EXECUTIVE ORDER
THIRTEEN SIX EIGHTY EIGHT ALONG
WITH MANY OF THE POLICIES AND
PROTOCOLS GOVERNING APPROPRIATE
CONSTITUTIONALLY SOUND USES. OF
THE CONTROLLED EQUIPMENT.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
REQUIRES ALL OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO OBTAIN
APPROVAL BY THEIR GOVERNING
BODIES MEANING CITY COUNCILS OR
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS PRIOR TO
APPLYING. A TO RECEIVE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT MADE AVAILABLE UNDER
THE FEDERAL MILITARY EQUIPMENT
SURPLUS PROGRAM.
BY REQUIRING A PUBLIC FORUM FOR
OPEN TO ALLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS THE BILL INTENDS TO
IMPROVE THEIR RELATIONSHIPS
COMMUNITIES HAVE WITH THEIR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. SO THAT
THEY'RE SEEN AS A PUBLIC SAFETY
SERVICE PART OF AN OCCUPYING
FORCE.
THROUGH THE CHAIR LIKE TO TURN
NOW TO OUR JOINT AUTHOR AND
MISTER CHIU OF FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ALONG WITH
OUR WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU OF MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THIS IS A COMMITTEE THAT
UNDERSTANDS HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO BUILD PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. AYE AND I'M
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE PERSPECTIVE
THAT THE WEAPONS THAT ARE
CARRIED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT ARCH
REFLECT THAT PARTNERSHIP. OUR
CITIZENS ARE NOT ENEMY
COMBATANTS OUR POLICE ARE NOT
MILITARY GENERALS IT'S IMPORTANT
AND THIS BILL DOES IS TO PROVIDE
THE PUBLIC WITH THE NECESSARY
TRANSPARENCY. ARE ON WHY AND
WHEN LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WOULD NEED TO ACQUIRE
MILITARY GRADE WEAPONS. UP WE
ARE HERE IN PART BECAUSE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAD REPEAL.
A PREVIOUS EXECUTIVE ORDER.
FROM OUR PRIOR PRESIDENT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
THAT HAS NECESSITATED THE
IMPORTANCE OF STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO STEP IN AND WITH
THAT. OUT ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND ALSO THANK THE
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL AS WELL.
INCLUDING INDIVISIBLE THAT HAD
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION.
THIS WAS SOMETHING I HAD
THOUGHT ABOUT MOVING FORWARD
UNTIL THEY FOUND OUT THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO IS
DOING IT WE'VE DECIDED TO JOIN
FORCES.
YOU MAY COME GO IT.
THE MONEY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE MY NAME IS YOU
NEED A CONSISTENT WITH THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA. WHERE THE
NATION'S LARGEST MUSLIM CIVIL
RIGHTS GROUP IN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
MUSLIMS?
AND A THIRD OF OUR MUSLIM
COMMUNITY IS ACTUALLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE A VERY LARGE.
REFUGEE POPULATIONS.
CENTERED AND THE SACRAMENTO
AREA OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY AS
WELL SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND
THIS BILL IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
MY COMMUNITY BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE
SEEN LATELY IN IN IN THE NEWS
REGARDING SO FONG CLARK AND MANY
OF OUR OTHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THE REALLY THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY. RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE
ARE IN A TIME WHERE WE NEED TO
MEND.
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE COMMUNITY
AND TRANSPARENCY IS IMPORTANT
AND IN REGARDS TO A REFUGEE
COMMUNITY WE HAVE MANY COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO ARE NEW TO THIS
COUNTRY FLEEING WAR. WAR ZONES
SEEING TANKS FREQUENTLY IN IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES SEEING
MILITARY STYLE WEAPONS AND LIKE
HAVING THAT. POTENTIALLY IN OUR
STREETS WITHOUT PUBLIC COMMENT
WITH A PUBLIC FORUM WITHOUT
TRANSPARENCY. I I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT IS REALLY CONDUCIVE TO
A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE THINK OF BRINGING OUR
COMMUNITY TOGETHER AND AND
CREATING SAFE SPACES.
AND REALLY WHAT THIS BILL WOULD
DO WHAT IT WOULD PREVENT THE
BLURRING OF THE LINES REACHING
OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
MILITARY LIKE REALLY
RECOGNIZING.
LIKE WHO IS SERVING US VERSUS
WHO IS PROTECTING US OVERSEAS
AND AND WHAT NOT. AND WE AT CARE
A SUPPORT.
A. B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE AND
WE WOULD URGE IVA.
THANK YOU.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS  THE BATON ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE'RE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY ONE BECAUSE IT BRINGS
NECESSARY LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE PROCESS OF
ACQUIRING DANGEROUS COSTLY
DIVISIVE MILITARY EQUIPMENT.
IT FILLS AN IMPORTANT GAP IN AS
YOU KNOW AS WE'VE HEARD
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER PARTLY
RESPONDING TO THE CRISIS IN OUR
NATIONAL POLICING OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND THE EXECUTIVE ORDER HAD TWO
CATEGORIES OF EQUIPMENT ONE LIST
OF EQUIPMENT WAS TRANSFERRED WAS
PROHIBITED TO TO.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND THEN
THE OTHER WAS A LIST OF ITEMS
FOR WHICH MUNICIPALITIES HOW TO
SUBMIT A DETAILED JUSTIFICATION
OUTLINING THEIR NEEDS FOR THE
EQUIPMENT. AND THE CERTIFICATION
THAT TRAINING AND USE POLICIES
WERE IN PLACE PRIOR TO RECEIVING
EQUIPMENT.
AND THE SAFEGUARDS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH BEST PRACTICES
FOR MAINTAINING PUBLIC SAFETY AS
YOU ALL KNOW BY BUILDING TRUST
AND ACCOUNTABILITY BETWEEN
COMMUNITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS.
SO UNFORTUNATELY AS WE'VE HEARD
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
RESCINDED THE EXECUTIVE ORDER.
UNDER THE TEN THIRTY THREE
PROGRAM CALIFORNIAN AGENCIES
HAVE ALREADY ACQUIRED TEN COMBAT
WHEELED VEHICLES FORTY FOUR MINE
RESISTANT VEHICLES THIRTY NINE
ARMORED TRUCKS ALMOST SIX
THOUSAND FIVE POINT FIVE SIX
MILLIMETER RIFLES AND ALMOST
FIVE HUNDRED SEVEN POINT SIX TWO
MILLIMETRE RIFLES.
THIS IS Y. A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE IS SO CRITICAL.
IT WOULD PLACE THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER TO ACQUIRE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT IN THE HANDS OF THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO ARE
CLOSEST TO THE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES.
IT WOULD PERMIT THESE OFFICIALS
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE COST OF
ACQUIRING USING AND MAINTAINING
MILITARY EQUIPMENT IS TRULY
WARRANTED. IT WOULD REQUIRE
AGENCIES TO CONSIDER AND WORK TO
PREVENT THE DISPARATE IMPACT THE
POLICE EQUIPMENT HOUSE ON
CERTAIN MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
MOST OFTEN AS WE KNOW PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO ASSIST IN
THE CRITICAL WORK OF ENCOURAGING
OUR PEACE OFFICERS TO ENGAGE
WITH THOSE THEY SERVE.
IS OPPOSED TO ADOPTING A
WARRIOR MENTALITY FROM WITHIN A
TANK OR BEHIND A GRENADE
LAUNCHER.
THE CRITICALLY IT WOULD NOT
PREEMPTIVELY BAND TRANSFER OF
ANY SPECIFIC KIND OF EQUIPMENT
WHICH IS A DEPARTURE FROM THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER. RATHER IT WOULD
PLACE THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
THE EQUIPMENT IS TRULY NEEDED IN
THE HANDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
FOR THESE REASONS THAT THE SO
YOU THINK THE AUTHORS FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP STANDS BEHIND THE
BUILDING URGES YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S TOGETHER HEARING
I'M I'M HERE WITH INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG OR A
COALITION OF OVER. HUNDREDS OF.
LOCAL GRASSROOTS GROUPS
REPRESENTING OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CONSTITUENTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT AND COSPONSORED LISTA.
YES.
MARGOT GEORGE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM WEINBERGER ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR AND IN
SUPPORT URGENT AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK S FOR
THE ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANIEL CANDA KAISER ON BEHALF OF
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT.
YESTERDAY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RICH
POOR SOULS ALONG HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
THE CONCERN WE REYES WITH THIS
ISSUE.
AND PREVIOUS ATTEMPTS. TO HACK
THE SORT OF POLICY AT THE STATE
LEVEL. ON IS THAT. THIS
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS OF
APPROVAL POT WILL SLOW DOWN LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO ACQUIRE
THIS EQUIPMENT AND THE
PROPONENTS WILL SAY WELL YOU
ONLY HAVE TO DO IT ONCE OR YOU
HAVE TO COME UP WITH A POLICY
AND THEN IT'S NOT. REQUIRED FOR
EACH TIME YOU ATTEMPT TO ACQUIRE
EQUIPMENT BUT EVEN FOR THAT
FIRST TIME YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THIS ARDUOUS PROCESS OF
SAYING WHAT YOU WERE GOING TO
ACQUIRE. THIS PARTICULAR TYPE OF
CAMOUFLAGE UNIFORM OR THIS
PARTICULAR TYPE OF FIREARM OR
HELICOPTER OR AIRPLANE.
IN TWO TO IMPOSE THAT ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS BURDENSOME NUMBER
ONE.
NUMBER TWO.
HELICOPTERS AND AIRPLANES.
I MEAN THERE ARE SOME THINGS ON
HERE THAT SOUND SCARIER THAN
OTHERS LIKE TRACKED ARMORED
VEHICLES BUT HELICOPTERS AND
FIXED WING AIRCRAFT OR USE
ROUTINELY IN POLICE WORK. FOR
THE SAFETY AND BENEFIT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROTECTS.
THE DEFINITIONS IN THIS BILL ARE
VAGUE AT BEST FOR SOME ITEMS.
A FIREARM OR A FIREARM ACCESSORY
THAT IS DESIGNED TO LAUNCH SMALL
EXPLOSIVE PROJECTILES I DON'T
KNOW A TON ABOUT GUNS BUT I'M
PRETTY SURE THAT QUALIFIES AS
THAT EVERY FIREARM.
IS INCLUDED IN THAT DEFINITION
THAT'S WHAT FIREARMS DO THEY
LAUNCH SMALL EXPLOSIVE
PROJECTILES.
SO IF THAT'S NOT THE INTENT THAT
AT THE VERY LEAST WE NEED TO
CLARIFY THAT.
THE BILL ALSO IMPLICATES LONG
RANGE ACOUSTIC DEVICES.
THAT A BULLHORN.
THE HERB SO WE CAN ACQUIRE BULL
HORNS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
I AYE IF THAT'S NOT THE INTENT
AGAIN THE BILL SHOULD BE
pNOT WHAT THIS BILL INTENDS TO
COVER THAT IT'S SOMETHING ELSE.
BUT AGAIN THE DRAFTING OF IT
NEEDS TO BE FIXED AT THE VERY
LEAST.
AND EVEN IS ALL OF THESE
LOGISTICAL OR DRAFTING ISSUES
ARE CLARIFIED THE BOTTOM LINE
IS.
SHERIFFS ARE INDEPENDENTLY
ELECTED OFFICIALS
AND THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
DETERMINE WHAT'S BEST IN TERMS
OF POLICING TECHNIQUES
EQUIPMENT.
AND THEY SHOULD NOT BE SUBJECTED
TO THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
APPROVAL OR OVERSIGHT
NECESSARILY THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAS BUDGETARY
AUTHORITY. THAT'S ONE ISSUE BUT
SHERIFFS HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
POLICE AND TO DO WHAT THEY
BELIEVE IS RIGHT AND APPROPRIATE
FOR THE SAFETY OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND WE DISAGREE WITH
THE NOTION OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SHOULD HAVE.
APPROVAL AUTHORITY OVER TACTIC.
TECHNICAL ISSUES AND TACTICS AND
FOR SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK
FOR A VOTE PICTURE.
THANK YOU.
YES.
JEFF MATTHEWS ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
PRETTY PAYER THERE AND READ HIS
HOUSE HAD SOME HALF A POINT I
CAN OPPOSITION.
JOHN THE VILLAIN CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
APOLOGIES TO THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR LETTER WAS NOT
SUBMITTED IN TIME WE TOOK LA
POSITION BUT WE ARE OPPOSED
THANK.
THANK YOU.
RANCHERO THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
BUT I'M NOT YOU CYBERLINK WE
HAVE THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND.
ARE YOU QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YES MISTER LACKEY.
YOU'RE NOT SURE EXACTLY HOW TO
ADDRESS THIS OTHER THAN TO BE A
FAIRLY DIRECT.
.
FIRST OF ALL I'D I TAKE.
OVER ITS WITH THE FACT THAT I I
THINK THAT. THIS KIND OF BILL
FEEDS THE TENSION.
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS.
AND THE COMMUNITIES THEY HAVE
BEEN ASKED PROTECT.
IT SENDS.
THIS.
AND YOU CAN SHAKE YOUR HEAD OUT
THERE ALL YOU WANT BUT I JUST IS
TRULY WHAT I BELIEVE.
AND. I THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT WE.
TAKE A POSITION THAT.
.
LAW ENFORCEMENT EXISTS TO DEFEND
A NOT TO ATTACK.
AND WE HAVE THIS REALLY UGLY
PHENOMENON IN THE WORLD TODAY
CALLED TERRORISM.
AND JUST TO THINK THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE EXEMPT FROM
THESE KINDS OF ATTACKS.
IS RIDICULOUS.
AND WE NEED.
TO JUST BE MORE DIRECT EVERYBODY
AND WE NEED TO HAVE WE NEED TO
BUILD RELATIONSHIPS IS WHAT WE
NEED TO DO.
AND. I THINK OF THESE KINDS OF
MEASURES.
VALIDATE.
THE.
.
THE YOUNG FORTUNATE.
CIRCUMSTANCE OF PEOPLE SEE. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS.
OPPRESSORS AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
THERE TO.
UNDERMINE THEIR HAPPINESS WHEN
IN FACT OF THEIR TO DEFENDED AND
DIE.
FOR THOSE PEOPLE.
THAT.
DON'T TRUST THEM.
AND SO I.
MY SECOND OPPOSITION IS THE
EXTREME CHARACTERIZATION WHAT'S
MILITARY GRADE.
CAMOUFLAGE.
YEAR.
BATONS.
AND THAT THESE TYPES OF TOOLS
ARE NECESSARY TO DEFEND.
INNOCENT PEOPLE AND SO I I WOULD
WISH THAT. WE COULD.
.
TAKE A DIFFERENT APPROACH TWO OF
MENDING RELATIONSHIPS ARE SORT
OF THIS KIND OF BILL.
THANK YOU.
BUT ANY OTHER COMMENT.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I. FIGURES CHAIRMAN I I WILL LE.
I THINK THE BILL SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF I STILL RESPECT MY
COLLEAGUE WHO HAS IT PERHAPS A
DIFFERENT POINT OF VIEW A
DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCE FOR
WHY THIS BILL MAY BE NECESSARY.
OF MY TIME ON THE CITY COUNCIL
I'M I WOULD WANT THIS AUTHORITY
TO BE GIVEN TO ME A TO MAKE THAT
DECISION IN A PUBLIC A
TRANSPARENT MANNER. OUR MAKE
PERFECTLY CLEAR THERE IS A
DISTINCTION IN THIS BILL THAT
WAS NOT IN THE FEDERAL EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT THE
ACQUISITION OF ANY OF THESE
KINDS OF PIECES OF EQUIPMENT BUT
IT DOES REQUIRE A PUBLIC HEARING
FOR IT. AND MUCH AS A SHARE OF
HAS TO GO BEFORE THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO REQUEST HIS OR
HER BUDGET I'M WHICH DOES
DICTATE THE NUMBER OF.
AT ALL EVERY KIND OF TACTICAL
AND OPERATIONAL CONCERNED THAT
THEY MAY HAVE YOU KNOW MONEY IS
HOW THOSE THINGS ARE OFTEN
PLAYED OUT. A JUSTIFICATION
ASKING FOR SOME THE PROCESS I
THIS IS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY IS
NOT ABOUT PROHIBITION IT'S BY
ASKING PEOPLE WHETHER THEY
SHOULD HAVE THIS EQUIPMENT BY
THAN SIMPLY JUST COLLECTING THE
EQUIPMENT.
LOW HAPPY GOING FOR THE DATE
DETAIL FOR THE COMMITTEE ANY
TIME ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND WE
CAN CERTAINLY WORK UP TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF.
THAT SOME OF THE DEFINITIONS I
THINK THAT'S A FAIR OBSERVATION
UMP IN TERMS OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS.
THESE ARE THE UP PUBLIC HEARING
IS WHAT IS TAKING TO CONFIRM A
POLICE CHIEFS
OUR PUBLIC PROCESS IS WHAT'S
TAKEN TO CONFIRM OR APPROPRIATE
A BUDGET. ON THIS IS NO
DIFFERENT ON BUT THIS DOES
INCREASE THE PARTS OF PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION WHICH I THINK IS
SO VERY IMPORTANT THIS POINT IN
TIME.
PARTICULARLY AFTER THE RECENT
RECESSION OF THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
SO RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE IS AN
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
JUST A COUPLE OF OF OF QUICK
THOUGHTS A I ALSO VERY MUCH
RESPECT OF THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE VICE CHAIR AND AND YEAR
EXPERIENCE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARM. AND AS SOMEONE WHO ALSO
WORKED ON LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THE
DA SIDE I THINK WE DO HAVE JUST
A LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENCE OF
PERSPECTIVE AND HOW WE LOOK AT
THIS. THAT WE ALL SHARE THE
GOALS OF ENSURING THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE FROM
TERRORISM.
BUT IN MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
THERE SIGNIFICANT DISTRUST
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE AND
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS AND. ARE I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE TENSION
THAT I THINK YOU ALLUDED TO HAS
BEEN REALLY FUEL BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ADMINISTRATION
REVERSED THE EXECUTIVE ORDER. OF
THAT HAD ALLOWED FOR SOME
TRANSPARENCY FOR COMMUNITIES TO
KNOW WHAT TYPE OF A MILITARY
GRADE A EQUIPMENT IS GOING INTO
OUR OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO JUST ADDRESS
THE ISSUE AROUND PROCESS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE CAN'T
MOVE QUICKLY ON IF THEY ARE SO
COMPELLED AND COULD SET UP
PROCEDURES OUGHT TO PRE APPROVE
OR OTHERWISE ADDRESS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT IF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. WANTED TO PASS
ON.
MILITARY GRADE EQUIPMENT THAT
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE READY TO DO
THAT THAT IS.
NOT FORBIDDEN UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION AND I WOULD JUST
REITERATE AS MY.
COLLEAGUES AT FROM SAN DIEGO
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS BILL
THAT PREVENTS ANY OF THIS
EQUIPMENT FROM GOING TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OR SAYING IS THAT WE
NEED. A LITTLE BIT OF
TRANSPARENCY A LITTLE BIT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY A LITTLE BETTER
PROCESS AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU HARM AND I AGREE WITH
THE VICE CHAIR. THAT THAT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS ARE HERE TO DEFEND.
AND NOT ATTACK.
AND WE NEED TO TO WORK MORE ON
THAT.
.
IRONICALLY I THINK YOUR BILL
COULD HELP US GET TO THAT FOR
EXAMPLE WOULD TRANSPARENCY.
EVEN IF.
OF A BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OR
LOCAL CITY COUNCIL APPROVES.
SOME TYPE OF MILITARY GRADE OR
WHATEVER FALL TO TED DEFINITION.
IF THEY BELIEVE THAT IT IS
NECESSARY IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND IS VOTED ON AND RESIDENTS
SEE IT AS A UNNECESSARY.
PART OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THINK IT WOULD BE BETTER THAN
HAVING TO SHOW UP.
AND A COMMUNITY AND THEY NOT
KNOW BAD.
THAT IS THE TYPE OF.
.
FORCE PROTECTIVE SAID THEY WILL
BE USING.
TRANSPARENCY IS ALWAYS VERY
IMPORTANT AND I DO KNOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN MOVE QUICKLY.
I WOULD SAY THE NOTION.
THAT.
LAWMAKERS.
COULD NOT DECIDE WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES IS IS KIND OF
LOCUSTS.
I'VE BEEN HEARING THAT FOR QUITE
AWHILE. AND IT'S.
.
AT I KNOW IT THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT.
HOWEVER YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT PEOPLE WHO MAKE LAWS ALSO.
ON DECIDE TO BUDGETARY
IMPLICATIONS OF THOSE LAWS AND
DECIDE HOW THOSE RESOURCES ARE
DISPERSED. SOBRE RATHER HAVE US
WORKING.
HARMONIOUSLY TOGETHER. TOOK TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH WITH THAT I
THINK THIS BILL HELPS US GET TO
THAT.
AS OPPOSED TO BEING MAKE IT
MORE PROBLEMATIC THE MORE OPEN
WE ARE WITH WITH.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS ON HOW TO SPEND THE
MONEY. AND THE MORE OPEN YOU ARE
WITH THE PUBLIC.
I THINK YOU WILL FIND THAT THAT.
WHATEVER EQUIPMENT IS NEEDED TO
KEEP NOT ONLY CITIZENS SAFE BUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT OF OFFICERS
SAFE.
WILL BE ON A GREAT ASSET SO THAT
THAT THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDED AYE
VOTE.
MR MOST.
TAKEN BY MISTER QUIRK.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY NO CARDIO.
CATALOGUER DEATH GALLAGHER DEATH
AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURES ON CALL TANK YOU.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT MISS MELENDEZ
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT TO YOU THIS
MORNING. AFTER SEVENTEEN PEOPLE
WERE KILLED IN PARKLAND FLORIDA
THE SCHOOL SHOOTING IN FEBRUARY
NEARLY FIFTY SCHOOLS REPORTED
VIOLENT THREATS THAT SAME MONTH
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALONE. A
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD HELMET HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT WAS ARRESTED FOR
WRITING HIM AT HIGH WILL BE SHOT
UP ON FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BY SOPHOMORE
GIRL. NO CHARGES WERE PRESSED
AGAINST HER EVEN THOUGH PARENTS
DID NOT SEND THEIR CHILDREN TO
SCHOOL ON THE FOLLOWING DAYS
BECAUSE OF THEIR FEAR. A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD MIRA COSTA MESA. ARMS
ARE A NEAR COSTA HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT WAS ARRESTED AFTER HE
POSTED A PHOTO OF HIMSELF
POINTING A GUN AT HIS CLASSMATES
ON SNAPCHAT. NO CHARGES WERE
PRESSED AGAINST HIM. AND A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD EL CAMINO
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT WAS ARRESTED
AFTER SECURITY GUARD OVERHEARD
HIM TELLING HIS FRIEND HE WAS
GOING TO SHOOT UP THE SCHOOL
SOMETIME WITHIN THE NEXT THREE
WEEKS.
NO CHARGES WERE PRESSED AGAINST
HIM EVEN THOUGH THEY FOUND THEY
ARE FIFTEEN RIFLES IN HIS HOUSE.
HE CLAIMED THE GUNS WERE HIS
BROTHERS AND HIS BROTHERS HAVING
CHARGES AGAINST HIM FOR OWNING
ILLEGAL WEAPONS.
SO IF WE REALLY WANT TO PREVENT
THESE HORRIFIC ACTS OF VIOLENCE
IN OUR SCHOOLS THEN WE HAVE TO
BE VIGILANT AND PROACTIVE ON
IDENTIFYING LEGITIMATE THREATS
AND THOSE WISHING TO CAUSE HARM.
CURRENT LAW MAKES IT A CRIME
ONLY TO SPECIFICALLY THREATEN A
PARTICULAR PERSON OR MEMBER OF
THEIR FAMILY BUT NOT TO THREATEN
A GROUP OF PEOPLE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT
MAKES IT ILLEGAL FOR A PERSON TO
MAKE VIOLENT THREATS VERBALLY IN
WRITING OR BY SOCIAL MEDIA AGAIN
SCHOOLS AND PLACES OF WORSHIP.
IF THE SIGNS ARE THERE INACTION
SHOULD NOT BE AN OPTION THE
PRICE IS A MATTER OF LIFE AND
DEATH IN MANY CASES.
THIS OTHER THIS BILL ALSO OFFERS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MEDICAL
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS TO
INTERVENE TO GET SOME OF THESE
KIDS THE HELP THAT THEY MAY VERY
WELL NEED THEY WOULD OTHERWISE
NOT GET IN THE HOPES THAT THEY
DON'T CONTINUE DOWN A ROAD. OF.
DESTRUCTION.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
TARA URBAN ON BEHALF OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY MY CAST TRAIN AND
VIVIAN WHITE TO WILL TESTIFY
SECOND SHE WAS AS SHE IS A
STUDENT MCCLATCHY HIGH SCHOOL.
ISSUE WE SHARING HER PERSONAL
STORY OF THE VIOLENT THREAT MADE
MCCLATCHY HIGH SCHOOL IN
FEBRUARY. BY A STUDENT WHO ALSO
WAS NOT ARRESTED FOR THAT
THREAT.
THANK IT WHEN THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
GOOD MORNING AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS TARA URBAN AND I GET
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
TODAY CHILDREN. ARE AFRAID TO
ATTEND SCHOOL.
FOR FEAR OF BEING SHOT
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS ARE PLAGUING
OUR SOCIETY.
IN THE ECHOES OF FIRE JUST OF
SHOTS FIRED ARE THREATS
THESE SCHOOL THREATS ARE
INCREASING IN NUMBER.
AT AN ALARMING RATE.
EVEN GREATER THAN THE ACTUAL
NUMBER OF SHOOTINGS ARE THE
THREATS THAT ARE OCCURRING TO
OUR SCHOOLS. WHICH HAVE.
AND SIGNIFICANT OF FACTS PARENTS
THE STUDENTS.
IN THE MONTHS FOLLOWING THE PARK
WHEN SHOOTING THAT OCCURRED JUST
IN FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR THEIR
OVERSEE FIFTY THREATS IN ABOUT
THIRTY THE CURRENT CRIMINAL
THREATS
STATUTE THAT WE HAVE DOES NOT
PROTECT. OUR MOST VULNERABLE
VICTIMS OUR STUDENTS IN THE MOST
VULNERABLE PLACES OUR SCHOOLS A
PLACE WORST SHOULD FEEL SAFE.
THE CLARIFYING LANGUAGE ADDED TO
THIS AND AMENDMENT IN THIS BILL
IS NARROWLY TAILORED.
TO CLOSE THE GAP IN CURRENT LAW.
THIS LANGUAGE HAS NOT BEEN
DECIDED BY OUR JUDICIARY.
SYSTEM.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW
PROSECUTORS CAN NOT FILE A FOUR
TWENTY TO CHARGE THE CRIMINAL
THREATS.
AGAINST.
WHEN THE SCHOOL OR CHURCH IS
LISTED VICTIM THE LAW REQUIRES A
PERSON TO BE THREATENED THAT
PERSON TO BE AFRAID FOR HIM OR
HERSELF.
OR THEIR IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBERS IT DOES NOT OFFERS THE
ABILITY TO BE AFRAID FOR THEIR
CONGREGATION OR THEIR STUDENTS.
AFTER MASS SHOOTINGS LIKE THE
ONE LAST FRIDAY THAT JUST
OCCURRED ON THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE COLUMBINE SHOOTING.
AND SCHEDULE PROTESTS AGAINST
VIOLENCE IN SCHOOLS WE SPEND
COUNTLESS HOURS ASKING OURSELVES
WHAT CAN WE DO TO PREVENT THIS
TYPE OF SHOOTING THIS TYPE OF
VIOLENCE.
THE ANSWER IS WE MUST INTERVENE.
WE MUST INTERVENE BY CHANGING
THE LANGUAGE AND FOR TWENTY TO
TO FACILITATE PREVENTION. AND TO
ELIMINATE THE DISPARITY IN THE
LAW THAT PROTECTS ONLY ONE
PERSON AND POTENTIALLY NOT
THOUSANDS.
WE NEED TO ANSWER THE SUSPECTS
CRY FOR HELP BEFORE THE THREAT
BECOMES AN ACTUAL SHOOTING.
THIS AMENDMENT A SIGNIFICANT IN
IT PROVIDES A STEP TO HELP GIVE
OUR CHILDREN.
OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR COMMUNITY
THE PROTECTION THAT THEY
DESERVE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
THOUGH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
NECESSARY AMENDMENT TO PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS VIVIAN
Y. AND I'M STILL NOT SEEKING
MCCLATCHY HIGH SCHOOL HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
ON THE MORNING OF THE SHOOTING
THAT IN MY SCHOOL I WASN'T
WORRIED I'D SEEN POSTS ABOUT THE
THREATEN PEOPLE WARNING US BE
SAFE BUT I WAS SURE THAT THE
SCHOOL WOULD HAVE IT UNDER
CONTROL.
SO I WENT TO SCHOOL AS USUAL.
WHEN I GOT MY FIRST PERIOD
CLASSROOM I WASN'T EXPECTING TO
SEE ONLY HALF OF MY CLASS
SITTING THERE BUT MOST PEOPLE
HAD STAYED HOME. AND BEFORE THE
BELL RANG TO START OUR FIRST
CLASS STUDENTS ARE ALREADY BEING
PULLED OUT OF SCHOOL BY THEIR
PARENTS.
I WATCHED JURASSIC PARK FIRST
PERIOD TALK TO MY PARENTS
FRIENDS SECOND AND THIRD AND
PLAY MATH GAMES FOURTH THE
TENDONS BEING TOO LOW FOR
TEACHERS TO GET ANYTHING DONE.
BY LUNCH THE HALLWAYS WERE
ALMOST EMPTY.
I FELT FAIRLY SAFE THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE DAY.
BUT AT LUNCH WE GOT A CALL FROM
A FRIEND WHO HAD GONE HOME.
SAYING THAT THEY JUST BEEN
CONTACTED ABOUT THE THREAT.
SHE HAD ONE OF HER CLASSES WITH
THE BOY WHO MADE THE THREAT.
SO THEY ASK YOUR QUESTIONS
BEFORE.
BUT THIS TIME IT SCARED US ALL.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
THREAT WAS STILL GOING ON JUST
MINUTES BEFORE FIFTH PERIOD WHEN
THE SHOOTING WAS SAID TO HAPPEN.
WE WERE ALL TERRIFIED.
EVERY TIME THE LOUDSPEAKER WENT
OFF CALLING OTHER STUDENTS GO
THE OFFICE TO GET PICKED UP BY
THE RIGHT FEELING WORRIED
PARENTS WE FLINCH BECAUSE IN THE
BACK OF OUR BRAIN WE THOUGHT THE
INTRUDER ALARM MIGHT BE GOING
ON.
WHEN THE BELL RANG TO GO TO OUR
AND BE SAFE PARTLY IS A DARK
HUMOR JOKE IN AN ATTEMPT TO
LIGHTEN THE MOOD AND PARTLY
BECAUSE WE'RE SCARED WE MIGHT
NOT GET ANOTHER CHANCE TO TELL
THEM.
FIFTH PERIOD STARTED. MY BIOLOGY
TEACHER LOCK THE DOOR AND WAS
THAT THE TEACHERS AND GIVING HAD
BEEN GIVEN CROWBARS JUST IN CASE
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT SAFE THEY
SAID YET THEY KEPT SAYING JUST
IN CASE THERE SHOULD KNOW BETTER
JUST IN CASE. IT WAS TRULY ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT SAFE THERE
SHOULD NEVER BE JUST IN CASE ONE
HUNDRED OF STUDENTS LIVES ARE AT
RISK.
WE MADE IT THROUGH FIFTH PERIOD
SAFELY BUT WE LOST A DAY OF
EDUCATION WE LOST FAITH IN THE
ADULTS BUT SHOULD BE PROTECTING
US AND WE WHAT'S THE SENSE OF
SECURITY WE SHOULD FEEL WHEN
GOING TO SCHOOL. THE SADDEST
PART IS THAT IT WASN'T THE FIRST
TIME THIS HAPPENED AT OUR SCHOOL
AND UNLESS SOMETHING CHANGES IT
WON'T BE THE LAST.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARI FILA COMBATANT GIFFORD LAW
SENATE PLAGUE OF VIOLENCE IN
SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATTHEW SOME HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
ORDER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION.
ON I AGREE THAT SOMETHING NEEDS
TO DO BE DONE BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE PROFESSORS.
FOUND THE RIGHT THING TO BE DONE
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT.
THE CURRENT STATUTE PENAL CODE
SECTION FOR TWENTY TO. IS
ALREADY ONE OF GREAT CONCERN FOR
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ACROSS THE
STATE.
OF PENAL CODE SECTION FOR TWENTY
TWO WAS THE SERIOUS FELONY AND
IT'S A STRIKE
SO THAT MEANS SICK ITS OWN CAN
BE USED TO DOUBLE OR TRIPLE A
NEW SENTENCE.
IT'S ALSO A STATUTE THAT'S ALSO
OFTEN MISUSED TO PENALIZE
CONDUCT THAT DOESN'T TRULY
BELONG IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
ARM AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY
TRUE FOR CLIENTS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS. WHO OFTEN
SUFFER FROM CRIPPLING PARANOIA
AND DELUSIONS NOT TO INTERRUPT
YOU MIGHT WEDNESDAY FOR TWENTY
TWO IS TERRORIST THREATS?
THANK YOU.
PRISCILLA TERRORIST THREATS.
THANK YOU BUT.
SOMEONE TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES FROM LOS ANGELES.
OUR ROGER WHO IS A MARINE CORPS
VET AND SUFFERS FROM PTSD AND
BIPOLAR DEPRESSION. ON HE LIVES
IN FLORIDA. BUT HE WAS HERE FOR
OUR MARINE CORPS REUNION.
HE DIDN'T BRING ENOUGH OF HIS
MEDICATION AND AS A RESULT HE
HAD AN EPISODE OF HEARING VOICES
AND SMELLING DEAD BODIES.
THAT REQUIRED HIM TO BE A FIFTY
ONE FIFTIES THEN THAT'S TO GO TO
THE HOSPITAL A MENTAL HOSPITAL.
ON THEM OVERNIGHT.
AFTER BEING HOSPITALIZED HE WAS
TRANSFERRED TO ANOTHER FACILITY
WHERE HE SAID VALUE WAITED BY A
DOCTOR WHO TOLD THEM. THAT THE
SYMPTOMS DIDN'T MEET THE
CRITERIA AND THAT HE WOULD
NEITHER BE ADMITTED NOR GIVEN
ADDITIONAL MEDICATION.
THE VET COMPLAIN THE MARINE VET
COMPLAINED TO THE DISCHARGE
PLANNER TELLING HER HE WAS IN
NEED OF HELP AND WHAT COULD HE
DO.
SHE TOLD THEM WELL THERE'S
NOTHING YOU CAN DO.
YOU DON'T MEET THE CRITERIA FOR
FIFTY ONE FIFTY ANYMORE.
HE'S ASKED WHAT IS THE CRITERIA
AND SHE TOLD HIM IT'S A DANGER
TO HIMSELF OR OTHERS.
HE TOLD HER HE THOUGHT ABOUT
GETTING A GUN AND SHOOTING
HIMSELF FOR THE STAFF.
SHE CALLED THE POLICE
THEY ARRESTED HIM FOR A FELONY.
TERRORIST OR CRIMINAL THREATS.
BRIAN WAS IN HIS FIFTIES AND
MENTALLY ILL HE WAS OFFICE
MEDICATION AND HE TOLD HIS
FRIEND HE COULD BLOW THE
BUILDING UP.
SIMILAR TO THE SCHOOL ISSUES.
HIS FRIEND CALLED THE DEPARTMENT
OF MENTAL HEALTH.
ASKING FOR HELP CAN WAS
TRANSFERRED MOVE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
THE POLICE ARRIVED AND PROMPTLY
ARRESTED HIM FOR FOR TWENTY TWO.
FOR TWENTY TO IS A STATUTE THAT
ONLY REQUIRES WORDS NO ACTIONS
IN FURTHERANCE OF THE THREAT.
AND THAT APPLIES EVEN IF THE
PERSON WHO WAS SAYING THE WORDS
HAS NO INTENT OF ACTUALLY CARING
ABOUT.
FURTHER EXPANDING THIS ALREADY
EXPANSIVE DEFINITION WELL WE
FEAR ONLY AND SNEER MORE PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE'RE CERTAINLY SYMPATHETIC.
TWO THE INTENT BEHIND THIS BILL
AND VOTE REAL FEAR THAT
MOTIVATES SET.
I UNDERSTAND THAT COMPLETELY.
BUT I JUST DON'T THINK THIS IS
THE ANSWER AND I ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU.
YES. BRITTANY.
OTHER.
IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SCOTT WALKER.
QUESTION SO.
I THINK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
AND FOR. YOUR STORY.
WE ARE CERTAINLY.
IN ARE TIME WHERE.
.
WE HAVE TO TAKE THESE THINGS
SERIOUSLY.
AND ALSO AT A TIME WHERE WE
HAVE TO BE HAVING ALL SORTS OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH ARE PARENTS
WITH OUR SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
WITH THOSE WHO WERE SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT US.
ABOUT HOW WE CAN CREATE THE
ENVIRONMENTS IN WHICH WE WANT TO
LIVE WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT. A
NECESSITATE MORE LAW.
BUT REALLY HOW WE DECIDE WE'RE
GOING TO TREAT PEOPLE AND CO
EXIST.
MY QUESTION REALLY IS ABOUT THE
BURDEN OF PROOF FOR THIS BILL
AND WITH WHOM DOES IT LIE.
SO IF I AM GOING TO SCHOOL.
AND.
.
I.
I AM HAVING CHALLENGES WITH A
TEACHER OR WITH A COUNSELOR OR
EVEN WITH A FRIEND.
AND SOMEONE MAKES AN ALLEGATION.
THAT I HAVE SAID SOMETHING OR IN
THE HEAT OF THE MOMENT.
I SAY SOMETHING THE BURDEN OF
PROOF LIES.
WITH WHOM CAN SOMEONE JUST
DECIDE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO SAY
HEY. SYDNEY TOLD ME SHE WAS
GONNA BLOW ME UP IN THE BATHROOM
BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW OF X. Y. AND Z..
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S AN
INTERESTING QUESTION AS WITH ALL
CRIMINAL CASES THE BURDEN OF
PROOF INITIALLY LIES WITH THE
POLICE OFFICERS DOING THE
INVESTIGATION TO HAVE PROBABLE
CAUSE TO ARREST THE SUSPECT.
SO DON'T WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
EACH AND EVERYONE OF THOSE
ELEMENTS IS THERE'S PROBABLE
CAUSE TO ARREST.
NOW.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE FOR FILING AND
I SHOULD SAY DID SERVE.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND ARE
FILING UNIT REVIEWING CASES TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT WE
SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT PROSECUTE
CASES.
AND OFTENTIMES WHEN WE'RE
REVIEWING THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
CAN WE PROVE BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT WHETHER OR NOT THE
ELEMENTS ARE MEANT AND IT
REQUIRES EACH AN HOUR EVERY
ELEMENT OF THE CRIME. TO BE MET
WITH ITS KIND OF PEOPLE LIKE IT
TO A RECIPE AFTER HAVE ALL THE
INGREDIENTS YOU CAN'T LEAVE OUT
ONE. SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE ALL OF
THEM WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT
YOU HAVE TO DETERMINE.
CAN THE ELEMENTS OR BROKEN DOWN
INTO JURY INSTRUCTIONS IS THEIR
FACTS THAT GO TO EACH AND EVERY
ELEMENT.
WHEN LOOKING AT SPECIFICALLY A
CRIMINAL THREAT STATUE WHICH WAS
AMENDED SEVERAL YEARS AGO TO
INCLUDE ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS BECAUSE OF THE
CHANGING TIMES.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT.
NOW THAT THEY CAN BE DONE BY
SOCIAL MEDIA SO WE HAVE TO LOOK
AND SEE EACH AND EVERY ELEMENT
IS THERE.
THE BURDEN IS ON THE PROSECUTION
TO PROVE THOSE ELEMENTS BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT.
WHEN THE ONLY THING THAT THIS
BILL WOULD CHANGE IS NOT THE
BURDEN OF PROOF OR ANYTHING
ABOUT THE LA OTHER THEN IT WOULD
SIMPLY ALLOW.
THE TARGET OF THE THREAT TO
INCLUDE.
SCHOOLS AND CHURCHES.
CURRENTLY YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
SPECIFIC THREAT AGAINST A
SPECIFIC PERSON.
SO I WAS TALKING TO MY TWELVE
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER WHO IS ALL
INTO POLITICS OF SHE'S GOING TO
BE SUPER EXCITED TO WATCH THIS.
WAVING AT HER RIGHT NOW.
SO.
SHE IS I WAS TALKING TO HER
ABOUT IT AND I SAID OKAY IF
SOMEBODY CAME TO YOUR SCHOOL.
AND THEY THREATENED YOUR
PRINCIPAL AND THEY SAID I'M
GONNA KILL THE PRINCIPLE.
AND THE PRINCIPAL WAS AFRAID
THAT COULD BE POTENTIALLY
CHARGED UNDER FOR TWENTY TWO OF
A CRIMINAL THREAT. UNDER OUR
CURRENT LAW.
HOWEVER IF THAT SEEMS STUDENT
SAID I'M GOING TO GO AND BLOW
UP.
HER ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
IT WOULDN'T QUALIFY AND NOT
SIMPLY BECAUSE IN THE CURRENT
LEGISLATION IT HAS TO BE A
PERSON. THAT IS THE TARGET OF
THE OFFENSE AND THE PERSON THAT
IS.
HAS TO BE AFRAID FOR THEMSELVES.
OR FOR SOMEONE IN THEIR
IMMEDIATE FAMILY IT DOESN'T
APPLY TO THE SCHOOL. SO WHAT
THIS WHAT THAT MY DAUGHTER SAID
WHEN SHE HEARD THIS WAS WELL
HOLD ON A SECOND.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT ONE IF A
KID THREATENS ONE KID THAT ONE
KID IS PROTECTED. BUT IF THE.
KID THREATENS ALL OF THE KIDS TO
ALL TWELVE HUNDRED OF THEM THEN
ALL TWELVE HUNDRED OF THOSE KIDS
ARE NOT PROTECTED.
AND SHE WENT.
ARE YOU SERIOUS MUM AND THAT'S
WHO YOU KNOW SHE CAN TALK
STATIONS LIKE WELL THAT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE. AND I'M LIKE
WELL RIGHT NOW THE LAW REQUIRES
THE PROSECUTION TO IDENTIFY. A
VICTIM
SOMEBODY WHO CAN SAY HEY THIS IS
THE VICTIM OF THIS CRIME AND
THIS PERSON WAS AFRAID FOR
THEMSELVES OR THEIR IMMEDIATE
FAMILY.
THIS PROPOSED AMENDMENT ALLOWS
US TO WIN AS A THREAT IS MADE TO
A SCHOOL FOR IT TO BE
CONSIDERED.
UNDER THIS SECTION NOT
AUTOMATICALLY PROSECUTED BUT
CONSIDERED BECAUSE NOW THE
TARGET CAN BE THE SCHOOL.
FOR THE CHURCH
AND IT CAN BE THE ADMINISTRATOR
THAT IS IN FEAR FOR THE
CONGREGATION OR FOR THE SCHOOL.
AND SO THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
THAT IT PROPOSES. AND SO DOESN'T
NECESSARILY CHANGE THE BURDEN.
THANK YOU.
IT DOESN'T EXPAND THE REACH IT
JUST ALLOWS EIGHTIES.
PERSON TO NOT BE ABLE TO GET
AWAY WITH THREATENING TWELVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS VERSUS WHAT.
MISTER LECHNER MISTER KILEY
WHICH ONE.
MIND BE QUICK I JUST WONDER AS
THE GENTLEMAN IN THE WHITE SHIRT
HOWARD THREATS HAVE IMPACTED HIM
OBVIOUSLY CAME A DISTANCE TO
SHARE SOMETHING SO IF I COULD
HEAR THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
HARRIS.
I'VE ACTUALLY JUST HERE MOSTLY
IN SUPPORT OF MY DAUGHTER BUT I
AM A A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
HEARINGS EGGMAN.
AND.
.
IT DEFINITELY HAS. AFFECTED ME
NOT AYE ONGOING BASIS I I TEACH
FOURTH GRADE.
I TEACH FOURTH GRADE AND.
HAVING TO DISCUSS SCHOOL
VIOLENCE WITH THE CHILDREN THAT
AGE IS A.
CONSTANT BURDEN AND.
.
I THINK IT'S INEXCUSABLE THAT.
WE COULDN'T PROSECUTE.
PEOPLE WHO.
.
MAKE THESE THREATS NAY THEY
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED WHERE WE
SHOULD HAVE THE OPTION RESCUE
SHARE.
MISTER KILEY.
I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS I'VE
HEARD AFTER AND D. A.'S OFFICES
IN MY OWN DISTRICT ABOUT THIS
VERY PROBLEM THAT REALIZE THAT.
THERE IS THIS GAP IN THE LAW
THAT WE HAVE NO WAY.
TO TO TACKLE THIS INCREASINGLY.
YOU KNOW.
SERIOUS PROBLEM AND I YOU KNOW
THIS IS EXACTLY THE WAY THE LAW
SHOULD OF ALL WE'RE NOT YOU
KNOW.
.
EXPANDING THINGS WERE JUST
CORRECTING FOR AN OVERSIGHT.
WITH THIS BILL AND THAT YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT WE ALL KNOW AS
WE HEARD FROM THE TESTIMONY HOW
SERIOUS THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THESE THREATS COMMITTEE IN TERMS
OF THE FEAR THAT INSPIRES AMONG
THE STUDENT BODY IN TERMS OF THE
DISRUPTION.
TO THE SCHOOL AND THAT SO I
THINK THIS IS A REALLY SOLID AND
COMMON SENSE MEASURE AND I
MISTER CHAIR I AM VERY PLEASED
TO MOVE ABOUT.
NO THE COMMENTS OF.
YOU MAKE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
APPRECIATE YOUR 'M ATTENTION TO
THE WITNESSES WHO CAME ON BOTH
SIDES.
I THINK.
MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR ME IN THIS
BILL THAN ANY OTHER THING THAT
IT DIES IS THE ABILITY THAT IT
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO INTERVENE
WITH RESPECT TO MENTAL HEALTH.
THIS THIS ALLOWS US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TO GET TO A
STUDENT PERHAPS AND GET THEM THE
HELP THAT THEY NEED BEFORE THIS
GOES DOWN THE WRONG PATH RIGHT.
AND THIS IS A BILL THAT COIN.
THIS JUST CHANGES IT TO.
IT'S A WILD BOAR COULD BE
MISDEMEANOR COULD BE A FELONY
IT'S A LOT MORE BUT THIS THIS
GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A
JUDGE TO SAY OKAY YOU NEED TO GO
AND GET SOME TYPE OF TREATMENT
BECAUSE WE THINK. YOU ARE SAY
EXPERIENCING SIMILAR ISSUES
HERE.
SOME VIOLENT TENDENCIES AND WE
WANT TO GET THAT CORRECTED
WORRIES RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE
THAT ABILITY.
WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT UNLESS.
IT WAS A STUDENT GOES TO SCHOOL
AND SAYS I'M GOING TO SHOOT.
JANE DOE.
THEY CAN'T THEY CAN'T CHARGE.
THE WAY WE WOULD LIKE FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO DO UNDER THE
SPELLING INTERVENE.
AND THAT'S I THINK IT WAS.
REALLY A GREAT STATEMENT TO MAKE
BY.
MY WITNESSES DAUGHTER THAT.
IF YOU THREATEN ONE STUDENT.
VAN LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL
INTERVENE IN MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS CAN INTERVENE IF
YOU THREATEN THE ENTIRE SCHOOL.
EVERYONE IS LEFT
TO WORRY.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S A FAIR
THING TO DO OUR STUDENTS IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT A FAIR THING TO DO
OUR PARENTS.
THIS HAPPENED AT MY OWN
CHILDREN'S SCHOOL WHERE I MEAN
ONE THREAT COMES DOWN AND THE
NEXT THING YOU KNOW.
ALTHOUGH THE PARENTS ARE LOSING
THEIR MINDS ARE PULLING THEIR
KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL THERE'S THEN
THEY TAKE TO SOCIAL MEDIA AND
THEN IT GROWS BIGGER AND BIGGER
AND BIGGER IN THIS IN THE FEAR.
JUST CONTINUES TO SPREAD SO I
THINK WE HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER
IN THIS THAT WE DON'T DO.
THE INTENT ISN'T TO.
.
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO GET ARRESTED OR INCARCERATE
THAT'S NOT IT THE INTENT IS TO
STOP THESE. TYPES OF THINGS FROM
HAPPENING IN INTERVENE WHEN WE
CAN'T TO GET THESE KIDS THE HELP
THAT WE.
BECAUSE REALLY IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT SOMEONE WHO MAKES.
A THREAT LIKE THAT AGAINST THEIR
SCHOOL OR THEIR CHURCH
OBVIOUSLY.
SOMETHING'S WRONG IN THEIR
MINDS.
WHICH IS CAUSING THEM TO FEEL
THE WAY THEY DO.
I'D LIKE FOR US TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT THAT.
SO THAT A TRAGEDY DOESN'T TAKE
PLACE IN THAT PERSON.
I.
GET BACK ON THE RIGHT TRACK
THE TELEMATICA FOUR AM WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AND
I A GET ON ONE OF LUIS THANK THE
WITNESSES.
FOR COMING IN TODAY YOUR
ELOQUENT.
VERY PASSIONATE YOUR DIRECT
AND I'D.
AND I'VE ALWAYS SAID WE PROBABLY
NEED TO LISTEN.
TWO MORE YOUNG PEOPLE THAN TO
ADULTS.
ON ON PROBABLY MOST OF THE BILLS
WE DO.
AROUND HERE.
BECAUSE YOU'RE FRANKLIN USED.
A POINT AND.
YOU SPEAK FROM HONESTY.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
TODAY.
OF.
AND TO THE FATHER THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE ALSO.
YOUR SEVERAL LEGISLATORS AND I
WERE IN THE AIRPORT RIGHT AFTER
PARKLAND SHOOTING.
AND A FATHER OVERHEARD US
TALKING ABOUT LAWS AND DIFFERENT
THINGS WERE WORKING ON.
AND HE SAID ARE YOU GUYS.
LAWMAKERS ARE YOU GUYS SENATORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO'S EVER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALONG WITH
SENATOR ANDY ASKED. SO WOULD YOU
DOING ABOUT THE PARKLAND.
SHOOTINGS AND WE SAID WELL WHAT
WE GET THIS BILL IN THAT BILL
AND I. OUR OUR CHESTS WERE ALL
POKED OUT.
REALLY PROUD OF WHAT WE'VE DONE
IN THE PAST.
AND HE LOOKED AT HIS SAID.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT WOULD
YOU DOING NOW.
AND IT KIND OF EMBARRASSED
ASSAULT GROUP
YOU SAID YOU NEED TO DO MORE
BECAUSE I HAVE TWO. KIDS ARE
GETTING READY TO GO TO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
AND I'M SCARED TO DEATH.
TO HAVE THEM GO TELEPICTURES AND
WE'RE SCARED FOR THEM ALSO.
SO OF AYE AYE AYE CREATE. ON
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE GUN
VIOLENCE. PLAN TO HAVE MY OWN.
BRIEFING ON THIS.
FAIRLY SOON US WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
TO ME AND WHEN WE. DO WE ALSO
NEED TO HAVE MORE MORE
DISCUSSION SO.
OF THE WORD WE DISCUSS IT BUT I
THINK THE BETTER.
I'M CULTURAL.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NOT BOATING LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CATALOGUER DATA.
CATALOGUER DOT NOT VOTING KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING.
SANTIAGO.
IMAGES ALL CALL.
ATTY.
I DON'T.
OUT
BEFORE HAVE A SEAT WAS SITTING
BEFORE WE DO THAT WE HAVE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
A PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY TO ALL
SEVEN EGGMAN ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB TWENTY TO FIFTY SIX SANTIAGO.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE RUBIO AND I
DON'T I'M A FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR RUBIO.
IS THERE A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
STATED BY MR QUIRK.
JONES SAWYER.
I COULD HEAR PLOY QUIRK JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE TABLADA.
KEVIN OTHER DEATH AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THE SECOND WAS APPROVED THANK
YOU.
KING.
IF IT'S OKAY WITH THE CHILD LIKE
TO TAKE UP A. B. TWO NINE FOUR
TWO FIRST OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY TWO
PROVIDES PROSECUTORS ANOTHER
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
TO REDUCE SENSES FOR DEFENDANTS
THAT HAVE THE POTENTIAL FOR
REHABILITATION.
CALIFORNIA'S YOU KNOW HOUSES
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND INMATES WE SPEND MORE
THAN ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS EACH
YEAR. ON STATE PRISONS AND WHILE
PUBLIC ST GERMAIN TO KEEP
PRIORITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
EMERGING RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT
WE. SHOULD REVISIT PALACE
POLICIES FAR THOUGHT NECESSARY
TO ACHIEVE THE BEST PUBLIC
SAFETY OUTCOMES.
IN FACT RESEARCH FROM THE
BRENNAN CENTER FOR JUSTICE FROM
THAT PRISON SENSES COULD BE
SHORTENED BY TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
ACROSS THE BOARD. WITHOUT
CAUSING A NEGATIVE EFFECT ON
PUBLIC SAFETY.
TODAY THERE ARE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS WHO HAVE FOUND A
CERTAIN PRISON SENTENCE UPON
FURTHER IF YOU ARE NO LONGER. IN
THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE AND WORE
A LESSER LEGAL SENSE.
HOWEVER PROSECUTORS DO NOT HAVE
ANY DISCRETION TO REMEDY THESE
CASES.
ABOUT THIS SPELL ALLOWS
PROSECUTORS TO TAKE MATTERS INTO
THEIR OWN HANDS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR RECALL. AND
RESENTING OF DEFENDANTS PROVIDED
THAT THE DEFENDANT'S BEHAVIOR IS
NOT A THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY
AND THAT THERE IS EVIDENCE
INDICATING THEIR REHABILITATION.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY TWO IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO REALLY
ENSURE THAT PROSECUTORS CONTINUE
TO. DO THEIR PART AND PROTECTING
OUR COMMUNITY AT THE SAME TIME
UNDERSTANDING THEIR
REHABILITATION AND.
DEFENDANTS ARE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO.
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES WITHOUT
I'VE TWO WITNESSES BY DAVID
ANGELL WHO'S REPRESENTING SANTA
CLARA COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
JEFF ROSEN AND HILLARY PLOT.
YES.
I GOOD MORNING THANK YOU OUT
FIRST.
OF MY JOB MY BOSS DISTRICT
ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN HAD INTENDED
TO BE HERE BUT HE SAID.
ATTENDING TO HIS FATHER WHO WAS
GRAVELY ILL ASA SENDS HIS
REGRETS BUT WAS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR HIM. TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL
WHICH IS WHY HE ASKED ME TO
SPEAK ON HIS DAD.
.
I WANT TO TOUCH ON ESSENTIALLY
TWO POINTS IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
OUR OFFICE WAS ACTUALLY BE I
BELIEVE THE FIRST THE COUNTRY
CERTAINLY THE FIRST IN THE STATE
TO ESTABLISH A CONVICTION
INTEGRITY UNIT.
AND DOT BACK AND WE DID THAT WE
WE GOT ACTUALLY FOR AMOUNT OF
PUSH BACK.
FROM FOLKS WERE CONCERNED
SINGLE WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS IS
A DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
ISN'T THIS JOB FOR A PUBLIC
DEFENDER OR OR A GOVERNOR IF
THEY WANT COMMUTER SENTENCE.
BUT WE REALIZE THAT THERE WERE
RARE CASES A BOTTOM VITAL
IMPORTANT ONES WE HAD NEW
EVIDENCE THAT MADE US REALIZE
THAT THERE WAS A PROBLEM WITH
THE CONVICTION.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID GIVES US
THE TOOLS TO DO IT?
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
RARE BUT VITAL CASES WERE NEW
EVIDENCE IS GOING TO COME TO
LIGHT THAT SUGGESTS THE SENTENCE
ITSELF WAS ON JUST.
LET ME GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE FROM
OUR COUNTY THAT WE JUST RECENTLY
WORKED ON. AND THAT WAS THE CASE
OF AN MISTER OR NO FULL GARCIA.
HE WAS SERVING A LIFE SENTENCE
IN SAN QUENTIN DUE TO A SERIES
OF DRUG INDUCED BURGLARIES FROM
EARLIER IN HIS LIFE.
OVER TIME MISTER GARCIA FACED
HIS INNER DEMONS AND TAMED HIS
HEROIN ADDICTION AND HE WORKED
HARD BECAME A CHANGED MAN I
ACTUALLY MET HIM WHEN HE WAS IN
SAN QUENTIN.
HE WAS EVEN WETTER EDITOR OF THE
AWARD WINNING SAN QUENTIN
NEWSPAPER.
AND PERHAPS MOST INSTRUCTED ME
AS A PROSECUTOR IS ONE OF THE
TOP TO THE CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
FROM SAN QUENTIN MEN.
WHO SAW HIM EVERY DAY?
THEY WONDERED WHY HE WAS STILL
THERE DIDN'T FEEL LIKE THERE IS
REALLY A NEED FOR IT.
AND YET THERE IS REALLY KNOW A
CLEAR LEGAL PATH TO BRING THAT
CASE BACK IN FRONT OF A JUDGE
THAT.
EVALUATION TO BE MADE BASED ON
THE NEW THOSE NEW FACTS.
THIS LAW WHICH CHANGE THAT IT
WOULD GIVE US THAT LEGAL
MECHANISM.
I KNOW MY FELLOW DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND PROSECUTORS HAVE
MANY DIFFERENT OPINIONS OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
BUT. FROM TALKING TO FOLKS I
KNOW THAT EVERYONE HAS AN ARE NO
FOR GARCIA.
THAT THEY KNOW THAT THEY'VE
PROSECUTOR THEIR OFFICES
PROSECUTED WHERE THEY PONDERED
WHETHER HE REALLY OF THAT PERSON
REALLY NEEDS TO BE IMPRISONED
ANYMORE.
I.
THE LAST ISSUE I JUST WANT TO
TOUCH ON IN THIS BRIEF TIME. I
IS JUST ABOUT LOCAL GOVERNMENT I
MEAN JUST TO REMINDER DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
I EASE USUALLY HERE SHE IS
USUALLY THE HIGHEST RANKING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. IS OFFICIAL
AND I COUNTY AND AS SUCH I THINK
UNIQUELY SITUATED TO TO BALANCE
THE EQUITIES AS THE COMMUNITY
SEES FED.
SO I DON'T SEE THIS IS A.
A RADICALIZED IT IS A A CHANGE
IN THE LAW THAT ADDS A TOOL.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR CONVICTIONS AND
SENTENCES.
BUT IT'S ALSO IF YOU SUPPORT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. CURRENTLY WE
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH THE BOARD OF
PAROLE WHO IS THE POWER TO
RECALL A SENTENCE ALL THIS WOULD
DO WOULD BE TO ADD ANOTHER
MEMBER OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
BUT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. SO I THINK
FOR BOTH THOSE REASONS THIS
WOULD BE REALLY GOOD LAW THANK
YOU. THANK YOU.
IF YOU HAD GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADD JUST A FEW ADDITIONAL POINTS
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. MY NAME
IS HILARY BLOW OUT I'M A FORMER
PROSECUTOR HERE FROM CALIFORNIA
BUT I SPENT THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS NOW WORKING.
DIRECTLY IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM EFFORTS POLICY
INITIATIVES REALLY TRYING TO
STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN WHAT I
BELIEVE IS. IT CRITICAL FOR ALL
OF US TO CONSIDER IS PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT ALSO BALANCING THAT
WITH THE INTERESTS OF JUSTICE
AND ALSO TRYING TO MOVE AWAY
FROM OUR OVER RELIANCE ON
INCARCERATION AS A MEANS OF
MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER. SO
THIS BILL REALLY STRIKES A
BALANCE OF ALL OF THOSE GOALS
I'M WE WERE CAREFUL IN DRAFTING
THIS BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE KEEPING IN MIND THE
SENSITIVITIES AROUND COURTS AND
THE SCARCE RESOURCES THAT THEY
HAVE. ON AND SO THIS BILL DOES
NOT CREATE ANY NEW PROCESSES
INSTEAD IT LEVERAGES AN EXISTING
PROCESS.
THERE WHERE COURTS ARE ALREADY
CONSIDERING THE THE INTEREST OF
JUSTICE IN CONSIDERING PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT ALL IT DOES MERELY IS
ADDED THE DA'S TO BE ABLE TO
EXERCISE THE SAME DISCRETION
THAT THE EXERCISE AT THE OUTSET
OF THE CASE. AT THE FRONT END
BUT ALSO AT THE BACKEND.
THANKFULLY WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
DIFFERENT LAWS THAT HAVE BEEN
PASSED THAT CREATE ADDITIONAL
PATHWAYS TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE IN
OUR PRISONS WHO ARE SUITABLE FOR
RELEASE BUT I THINK WE ALL CAN
AGREE THAT THAT BURDEN THAT
FALLS ON THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS. IS A GREAT ONE AND SO
ANY OTHER ENTITY ESPECIALLY SOME
AN ENTITY LIKE THE DA'S OFFICE
THAT CAN PARTICIPATE IN
IDENTIFYING OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WHERE IT FURTHER CONFINEMENT
ISN'T WARRANTED. IS A IS A
BENEFIT AND CAN HELP TO ACTUALLY
EASE THE BURDEN ALSO MOVE IN
DIRECTION OF REDUCING OUR
OVERRELIANCE ON INCARCERATION.
WHILE DEA'S IN IN THIS BILL ARE
AFFORDED BROAD DISCRETION TO
ADDRESS ANY INJUSTICE ANY UNJUST
CONFINEMENT. ON IT IS LIKELY
THAT.
THE THE THE POPULATIONS THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO ELEVATE AND
HIGHLIGHT ARE THOSE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE SERVING LONG
TERM SENTENCES. PEOPLE THAT ARE
SERVING LONG TERM SENTENCES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE THE HIGHEST
NUMBER THE HIGH SHEAR NUMBER IN
THE COUNTRY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT NUMBER
ALSO INCLUDES A VERY HIGH NUMBER
OF THOSE WHO ARE SERVING. LONG
TERM SENTENCES FOR NONVIOLENT
OFFENSES AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A
QUICK SNAPSHOT OF THAT
POPULATION WE'VE GOT A THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN PRISON RIGHT NOW WHO
ARE SERVING BEEN CENSORED TWENTY
YEARS OR MORE. FOR NON VIOLENT
OFFENSE HALF OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ALREADY SERVED
FIFTY PERCENT OF THAT TIME WHICH
IS TWO DECADES ALREADY. SO THIS
GIVES YOU A SNAPSHOT OF SOME OF
THE POPULATIONS THAT COULD
REALLY BENEFIT FROM A LAW LIKE
THIS AND AS.
THE AS IT.
ATTORNEY.
ANGEL HAD MENTIONED WHILE IT
MIGHT BE A MODEST NUMBER WHO
WILL BENEFIT FROM THIS IT WILL
IN FACT VERY MEANINGFUL SO WITH
THAT WE. HOPE THAT THE D. THAT A
COMMITTEE HERE CONSIDERS THIS IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
IT WAS A BEACON WITH A SO YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MARCO GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TIFFANY IRAQIS ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE INSPIRED.
GOING BACK IS FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EARLY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CNN ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OR CONDUCT.
YEAH I JUST HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION.
IF ANYBODY CAN ANSWER TO WHAT
LEVEL AT WHAT POINT IN THIS
PROCESS WOULD VICTIMS.
OF OF THE CRIMINAL OFFENSES BE
ENGAGE WITH.
WELL I CAN PROBABLY ANSWER THAT.
.
FOR FIRST WILL WONDER MARCY'S
LAW AS A VICTIM IS ENTITLED TO
BE NOTIFIED WHENEVER THERE'S
GOING TO BE A CHANGE IN THE
SENTENCE OR OR HEARING THAT
COULD IMPACT THAT SENTENCE.
AND CERTAINLY BY PRACTICE AND I
SHOULD SAY PASSION AND CALLING
THEM AYE I KNOW EVERY PHILLIP
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS WE GOT
INTO THE WORK THAT WE DO. IN THE
CASE OF MISTER GARCIA THAT I
SPOKE ABOUT AND I IN OTHER CASES
WE'VE WORKED UPON.
WE WOULD NOTIFY.
THE VICTIMS HAVE CERTAINLY
REMEMBER FOR THIS IT'S A RE
SENTENCING SO IF THE SENTENCE IS
RECALL.
IF THE JUDGE.
ALL THIS HAS GONE FROM A JUDGE
SO THEN LEGAL YOUR PLACES IF NEW
SENTENCING AND YET HAPPENS THE
CONVICTION STAYS IN PLACE.
NOW YOU'RE THE TIME SENTENCING
SO ALL THE SAME RIGHTS.
THAT EVERYONE HAS INCLUDING THE
VICTIM WOULD STAY IN PLACE
THEY'D BEEN TITLE TO NOTICE AND
TO HEARING. A BUT CERTAINLY
BEFORE WE EVER DID IT ANYTHING
WE WE'VE DONE WORKING CONVICTION
INTEGRITY LIKE THIS WERE USUALLY
WORKING WITH THE VICTIMS VERY
EARLY ON TO MAKE SURE THEIR
VOICES ARE HEARD AND. AN HONOR.
AND IF IT STAR ONE LAST THING I
CAN SAY I'M ONE OF THE BREEZE
ONCE I'VE WORKED ON.
.
IT WAS A SERIES OF BURGLARIES
FOR VERY LONG TIME AGO.
OF ALL THE VICTIMS I CONTACTED
YOU TO A PERSON THEY HAD SAID
THAT THE SUPPORT OF THIS
INDIVIDUALS RELEASE WITH ONE
ELDERLY GENTLEMEN.
WHAT IS GRANDDAUGHTER SAID THAT
IT ACTUALLY WE'D VERY MUCH ON
HIS CONSCIOUS THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL STILL IN PRISON? A
DECADES AFTER WHAT HE HAD VIEWED
AS A CRIME THAT I DIDN'T DESERVE
IT SO THAT DIDN'T DECIDE IF IT
WAS SOMETHING.
WE TOOK INTO ACCOUNT AND IF YOU
WE EXPRESSED.
OKAY MISCARRY.
THANK YOU UM LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS TO OUR
ATTENTION.
WHAT I APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS
BILL IS THAT IT ACTUALLY BRINGS
TO LIGHT THE?
NATIONAL CASE.
WHEN THE HIP HOP ARTIST NAME
MAKE MALE WHO.
HAS ALSO SPARKED THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE NATIONAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM EFFORTS
AND I THINK THAT CALIFORNIA
COULD CERTAINLY SET A ROLE IN
IN.
ENSURING. THAT WE ARE THINKING.
ABOUT NATIONAL REPERCUSSIONS US
TO WHAT WE DO WITH CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM. AND HOW WE DON'T
INCARCERATE OUR WAY OUT OF
PROBLEMS ARE INTO MORE PROBLEMS
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS TO
OUR ATTENTION. I WILL BE VOTING
YES ON THE SPELL AND AND SUPPORT
AND I WOULD REALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON IMPROVING
IT AND REALLY HELPING. HOW THOSE
ARE WORKING TOWARDS PROMOTE
JUSTICE REFORM?
THANK YOU.
IF YOU WISH CON LAGER. THEY TWO
ONE I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS TO OUR ATTENTION I
WOULD ACTUALLY ARGUE THAT.
CASES LIKE MR GARCIA'S ARE NOT
RARE IN DEED THEY ARE PROBABLY
MORE COMMON THAN WE CARE TO
ADMIT.
BUT IF WE WERE TO ADMIT THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
IMPLICIT BIAS THAT IS INHERENT
IN MANY OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEMS.
I JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS I
WANTED TO KNOW ARE THERE ANY
RESTRICTIONS.
.
THAT I I DON'T KNOW IF MAYBE I
DIDN'T SEE THEM BUT IN TERMS OF.
.
WILL THE I BELIEVE THE WAY THE
RESTRICTIONS OF WORK AND IT'S
REALLY.
A.
MERE ANSWER TO THE ONE I GAVE
BEFORE SINCE LEGALLY THIS BRINGS
US BACK TO THE TIME PRIOR TO
SENTENCING.
THERE ARE MANY RESTRICTIONS THAT
EXIST.
DEPENDING ON THE CHARGES SO IN
OTHER WORDS SOME CHARGES CAN'T
BE LEGALLY STRICT AND SOME
CHARGES CAN'T BE.
IT MUST BE RUN CONSECUTIVE
OTHERS CAN BE RUN CONCURRENT SO
ALL THE SAME RESTRICTIONS THAT
EXISTING CURRENT LAW WOULD
REMAIN.
SO THAT PART OF THEY WOULD OUR
MAIN HOWEVER THERE IS NO
RESTRICTION ON THE TYPE OF CASE
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY COULD RIP
REQUEST FOR RECALL. NOW SOME
WILL BE POINTLESS IF SOMEBODY
HAS. MANDATORY LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE SENTENCE YOU GO BACK TO
SENTENCING WHAT'S GOING EXACT
SAME SENTENCE ALL OVER AGAIN BUT
OTHERS AS IN THE CASE OF MISTER
DARCY AND OTHERS A SIMILAR TO
HIM.
.
YOU KNOW THERE OF THEIR BE A LOT
MORE THERE'D BE ALL THE SAME
FLEXIBILITY THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST.
IS THERE ANY REAL ARE THERE ANY
I'M SORRY.
ON FOR JUST JUST A POINTER ON
PAGE ONE THE ANALYSIS.
SPECIFIES* DO NOT APPLY TO
ANY INMATES SERVING A. SENTENCE
FOR FIRST DEGREE MURDER OR FOR
ANY CONVICTION HAVE REQUIRES
REGISTRATION AS A SEX.
SO THAT ARE I BELIEVE THAT WOULD
BE THE.
YOU'RE AND THEN ARE THERE ANY IS
THERE ANY RELIEF FOR DENIAL.
WELL I I THINK IT'S AGAIN GO
BACK TO IT SENTENCING SO
SOMEBODY CAN ALWAYS. AYE IT WILL
DEPENDING ON THE POTTERY TO
REPEAL OR READ THE DECISION BY
THE JUDGE IN THIS IS LIKE ANY
OTHER JUDICIAL DECISION.
AND I CERTAINLY WOULD HOPE THAT
AS WE TALK ABOUT OF MORE BILLS
LIKE THIS WERE ALSO LOOKING AT
THE CONSISTENCY IN WHICH THESE
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED ACROSS DE
A.
WELL THROUGHOUT DE A OFFICES
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND ALSO NOT JUST
IMPLEMENTATION BUT TRAINING.
IN TERMS OF HELPING DA'S.
USE A DIFFERENT LANDS AS THEY
LOOK AT THE CASES THAT COME
BEFORE THAT GOT ME AGAIN THIS
THIS LAW IT GIVES DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS OFFICES DISCRETION. SO
REALLY IS.
UP TO INDIVIDUAL OFFICES TO
IMPLEMENT THIS AS THEY.
AS THEY CHOOSE FED OUT OBVIOUSLY
WE KNOW THAT NOT.
ALL OFFICES OPERATE IN THE SAME
WAY BUT OBVIOUSLY.
WE HOPE THAT BY SOME OFFICES
LEADING BY EXAMPLE OTHER OFFICES
OR FALL.
DID.
KILEY.
I'LL SO I'M PRIDE GENERALLY
PRETTY FAVORABLE TOWARDS THIS.
THIS IDEA I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS I THAT I WAS A BIT OF
CLARIFICATION ON AND. ONE IS
THAT KIND OF THE UNIVERSE OF OF
FOLKS THAT IT IT WOULD APPLY TO
I THINK YOU MENTIONED THERE ARE
A THOUSAND PEOPLE. EITHER
INCARCERATED RIGHT NOW.
THEY WOULD BE ELIGIBLE WHO ARE
NON VIOLENT IS THAT RIGHT.
THAT'S JUST ONE POPULATION AYE
CITIZENS RIGHT NOW THAT I THINK
WOULD PROBABLY RISE TO THE TOP
OF THE PRIORITY LIST AND READ
ABOUT PEOPLE THAT ARE SERVING
LONG TERM SENTENCES. TWENTY
YEARS OR MORE.
FOR A LOW LEVEL NONVIOLENT
OFFENSE.
BUT THAT DOESN'T BUT THERE'S A
OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN OUR PRISONS SO AND AS
IT WAS MENTIONED.
THERE'S NO EXCLUSION FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL OR A TYPE OF CASE
THAT COULD BE UNDER REVIEW BY
IDEA.
I SEE AND WE HAVE SOME DEBATES
HERE ABOUT WHAT'S VIOLENT WHAT'S
NONVIOLENT SO AYE I. WHAT TYPE
OF TYPE OF OFFENSE THAT WE
GENERALLY DON'T THERE WHEN IT'S
A LONG ENOUGH SENTENCE FOR THE
PERSON TO BENEFIT FROM THIS
RELIEF?
YOU KNOW WHAT ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON CRIMES OUT OF THE FOLKS
WHO MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE.
IF YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT THE
REFERENCE TO THE ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT ARE SERVING DOES ARE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN CONVICTED
FOR THEFT OFFENSES BOTHERS PETTY
THEFT OR DRUG RELATED OFFENSES
FRAUD AND FORGERY THOSE ARE
THAT.
THAT'S A THAT'S A VERY SMALL.
AND SUBSET OF THE LARGER
POPULATION BUT I RAISE THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IT'S.
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE KNOW THAT
THERE'S STILL THAT AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE SERVING.
SOME LIFE TERM SENTENCES IN OUR
PRISON FOR A LOW LEVEL
NONVIOLENT OFFENSES PETTY THEFTS
I GUESS THIS VIDEO THAT WAS
RIGHTS CASES MUST. HAVE WITH THE
PRIOR A DRUG POSSESSION AND DRUG
SALES YES I SEE. I'M IN AND WHEN
IT COMES TO THE ACTUAL US TO THE
DA MAKES THAT IT'S GOT AGREES TO
PETITION THE COURT AND YOU KIND
OF SAID IT'S BASICALLY LIKE THE
SENTENCING HEARING ALL OVER
AGAIN RIGHT.
YET WILL I MEAN IN REMEMBER ALL
OF THE SCHOOLS IN FRONT OF THE
JUDGE THE DA COMMIT TO REQUEST
THE JUDGE HAS TO.
ACTUALLY DECIDE TO RECALL THE
SENTENCE
AND THEN YOU HAVE.
YOU WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE A
SENTENCING DATE NEW SENTENCING
HEARING SO LEGALLY TO SORT IT
TAKES BACK IN TIME. AS IF THE
SENTENCING HADN'T HAPPENED BUT
YOU DON'T EVEN GET THERE IF THE
JUDGE DOESN'T AGREE TO RECALL
THE SENTENCE AND WHAT'S THE
STANDARD FOR THE JUDGE AGREEING
TO RECALL IS THAT THE INTEREST
OF JUSTICE OR. SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
I YOU KNOW I'M NOT POSITIVE I
BELIEVE SO.
ALRIGHT.
.
YEAH I THINK I'M TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY I HAVE I I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT AYE.
SOME OF THE FOLKS THIS MIGHT
APPLY TO AND I GUESS MY SECOND
CONCERN WOULD BE.
WHETHER D. AIDS ARE NECESSARILY.
PEOPLE BASS POSITION TO.
DO SOME OF THE ANALYSIS
REQUIRED BY THIS BILL IS TO THE
EXTENT OF REHABILITATION.
AND THAT SORT OF THING SO I
HOPE THAT THOSE CONCERNS WILL BE
KEPT IN MIND THROUGHOUT THE
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND I
THINK. THAT IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
EXCLUDE SEX OFFENDERS AND FIRST
REMARK READ THE BILL DOES SO.
THANKS WRITTEN FOR.
THANK YOU BYE DANIAR QUESTION.
OUT YOU MAY CLOSE TO THE I THINK
IT WAS A CHAIR I AGAIN.
TO REITERATE THAT THERE IS
THERE IS A SEPARATE PROCESS
THROUGH THE.
PAROLE BOARD AGAIN THIS ALLOWS
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO BE
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS AS
WELL.
I BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE.
ABILITY IN THE.
DISCRETION INVOLVED TO TO
REALLY PARTICIPATE IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY AND REALLY
APPRECIATE.
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVE OUT.
OKAY CHAIRS REGULARLY I NEED OF
AYE MEDIA.
MOTION THE SECOND.
RENT SCHECTER CULTURAL.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY ABOUT BOATING CDVA.
CARILLO AYE CATALOGUER DEATH
CATALOGUER DEATH AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
BILL PASSES.
THANK YOU.
AND.
.
REMIND MEMBERS WE HAVE ABOUT
EIGHT.
MORE BILLS BEFORE WE GET TO
DEVOTE ONLY.
SO LET'S.
OTHERWISE WILL BE.
WORKING PASSED.
TWELVE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AND.
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I AM BRINGING BACK A BILL THAT
I FIRST INTRODUCED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WHICH EXPANDS.
AB TEN FOURTEEN OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS THE GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER WHICH WAS. I CARRIED BY
DAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER SKINNER NOW
SENATOR SKINNER. EXISTING LAW
ALLOWS A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
OR AN IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER TO
ASK FOR A GUN BONTA STRAINING
ORDER FROM A COURT OF LAW.
SIMILAR TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS I BELIEVE
THIS PROCESS SHOULD BE EXPANDED
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE EMPLOYERS
COWORKERS I TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS PROFESSORS
FACULTY MEMBERS WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IS. A NUMBER OF SHOOTINGS MASS
SHOOTINGS HAPPENED IN WORKPLACES
AS WELL AS AT SCHOOLS.
OFTENTIMES WHEN YOU ARE AT
COLLEGE YOU ARE AWAY FROM YOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS LAW ENFORCEMENT
DOESN'T ABLE TO ISN'T ABLE TO
SEE EVERY PARTICULAR SITUATION.
A WE HAD A SHOOTING AT A
WORKPLACE AT THE UPS.
CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO AGAIN
WHERE INDIVIDUAL WHEN ENDED AND
HOW THE MASS SHOOTING WITH SOME
OF HIS COWORKERS. SO WE BELIEVE
THAT IN THIS SITUATION IT MAKES
SENSE TO DO EXPANSION ON THE ONE
ISSUE WITH THE BILL FROM LAST
TIME WHICH WE REMEDIED. WAS ON.
WE HAVE INCLUDED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WE HAVE NOW TAKEN
THAT PART OF THE BILL OUT OF THE
WHITE ITS ARE FAIRLY IDENTICAL
TO WHAT WE PRESENTED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT.
SIR THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CALVIN QUICK.
FROM BAY AREA STUDENT ACTIVISTS
OR PASTA.
FOR SHORT.
WE REPRESENT SEVERAL HUNDRED
ENGAGED HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
FROM ALL OVER THE BAY AREA AND
WE ARE AN ENTIRELY STUDENT LED
ORGANIZATION. CREATED IN THE
WAKE OF THE UPHEAVAL OF STUDENT
ACTIVISM THAT IS FOLLOWED THE
TRAGIC SHOOTING IN MARJORIE AT
THE MARJORY STONEMAN DOUGLAS
HIGH SCHOOL IN FLORIDA.
SO. AS STUDENTS WE KNOW FIRST
HAND THAT SOMETIMES THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO KNOWS THE MOST
ABOUT ONE PERSON'S STATE OF
MIND.
YOU CAN CONNECT WITH THEM BEST
IS A TEACHER R. CO WORKERS
SOMEONE WHO THEY SEE EVERYDAY
WHO IS VERY PRESIDENT IN THEIR
LIFE WHO. ISN'T MAYBE A FAMILY
MEMBER OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS
AREN'T ALWAYS THERE. A IN A
FAMILY. AND SO FOR EXAMPLE
NICHOLAS CRUISED THE SHOOTER AT
PARKLAND WAS KNOWN BY HIS FORMER
TEACHERS. AS AN UNSTABLE
TEENAGER A DANGER TO HIMSELF AND
TO OTHERS.
BUT THEY WERE UNABLE TO COME
FORWARD AND.
ACT TO PREVENT THIS TERRIBLE
TRAGIC SHOOTING.
DOWN SO I STUDENTS WE ARE.
REALLY AFRAID FOR OUR VERY LIVES
WHEN WE GO TO SCHOOL AND WE LIVE
IN WE GO TO SCHOOL AND WE KNOW
THAT OUR TRUSTED TEACHERS THESE
PEOPLE THAT WE TRUST.
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO PROTECT US
TO THE BEST OF THEIR ABILITIES
AND SO WE THEREFORE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AMANDA WILCOXSON BEHALF FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
I WAS VERY INVOLVED IN ON THE
PASSAGE OF THE ORIGINAL
COMPLIANCE RESTRAINING ORDER
LAW.
HALF AFTER SO MANY OF THESE
HORRIFIC SHOOTINGS AS WELL AS
THE DAILY. INCIDENTS OF GUN
VIOLENCE WE OFTEN HEAR THAT
THERE WERE THOSE AROUND THE
PERSON WHO SAW WARNING SIGNS AND
HAVE CONCERNS. BUT THEY HAD NO
LEGAL TOOL TO DISARM.
WHEN WE PASS THAT ORIGINAL LAW
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN ARE THERE WAS
OF COURSE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LAW BEING OVER USED. OR ABUSED.
AND OUT OF THAT.
THE LAWS BEEN IN EFFECT FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS WE SEE THAT THAT
HAS NOT BEEN THE CASE THERE'S
ONLY BEEN ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY. I THINK GUN VIOLENCE WE
OR.
RESTRAINING ORDERS OBTAINED.
MOST OF THOSE HAVE BEEN OBTAINED
BY THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WE'RE
FINDING THAT FOR FAMILY MEMBERS
IT IS A VERY BIG STEP.
TO GO TO THE COURT AND AND.
FILED A PETITION FOR GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER IN
FOR SO MANY. BY THE TIME THEY'RE
ALL HAVE THAT MUCH CONCERN TO
TAKE THAT STEP DURING A CRISIS
SITUATION THEY'RE CALLING LAW
ENFORCEMENT INSTEAD SO THAT'S
HOW. HOW THE LAW IS PLAIN OUR
AND CERTAINLY DOES NOT APPEAR TO
BE OVER USED OR ABUSED?
HOWEVER THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT MAY NOT BE
RESPONSIVE TO A CONCERN AND THAT
CONCERN MAY NOT BE FROM FAMILY
MEMBERS BUT AS WAS STATED
EARLIER. COULD BE.
FROM SOMEONE FROM THE SCHOOL
SETTING OR FROM THE WORK
SETTING.
AND RIGHT NOW OF COURSE THEY
CANNOT PETITION THE COURT THE
OTHER THING IS THAT SOME
FAMILIES EVEN THOUGH THIS IS A
CIVIL ORDER NOT A CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING. SOME OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE RELUCTANT TO GO TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND INVOLVE THEM ANY
KIND OF.
FAMILY CRISIS OR SITUATION SO
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOT.
WILLING TO RESPOND OR IS NOT
RESPONSIVE AND WHEN THE FAMILY.
A CONCERN INDIVIDUALS NOT A
FAMILY MEMBER IS RELUCTANT TO GO
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT ODD THEN I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
OPTION TO HAVE AVAILABLE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE IS THE COMMITTEE.
MENEM'S ARE A FAIRLY
COMPETITIVE DIFFERENCE LAW
CENTER TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
AMONG FULL THE TIME BUT ELECTED
BASED. A QUICKLY SPEAK TO SOME
THE LEGAL STANDARD THAT HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE OPPONENTS
ARGUMENTS IN THE BILL ANALYSIS.
IS WHY CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL
WOULD NOT IN ANY WAY ALTER THE
STRICT LEGAL STANDARD ON WHICH
COURTS MUST EVALUATE WHETHER TO
ISSUE INGENIERO. ALL OF THE DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS AFFORDED BY
EXISTING STATUTE WOULD STILL
APPLY. EXPORTING SHORT TERM VIEW
BUREAUS ME ONLY BE ISSUED AN
EMERGENCY CASES
IF A JUDGE FINDS BASED ON
TESTIMONY SUBMITTED UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY. REGARDING
FACTS PERSONALLY KNOWN TO THE
PETITIONER THAT THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIAL LIKELIHOOD THAT THE
RESPONDENT POSES A SIGNIFICANT
DANGER TO SELF OR OTHERS IN THE
NEAR FUTURE. AND THAT EXPORTED
YOUR WAS NECESSARY IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
G. BUREAUS ISSUED AFTER NOTICING
HEARING HAVE TO MEETING EVEN
HIGHER BURDEN OF PROOF.
ANYONE WHO FELT THE KNOWINGLY
FALSE HARASSING PETITION SUBJECT
TO FELONY PERJURY CHARGES AND
FINALLY ON AT THE COLLEAGUES AND
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS CAN
ALREADY ATTAINED EX PARTE
FIREARM PROHIBITING PROTECTIVE
ORDERS AGAINST INTERESTED IN A
COLLEAGUE. I WAS SPECIFICALLY
THREATEN THEM AS INDIVIDUALS
THE DIFFERENCE HERE THE QUESTION
WOULD THIS BILL IS WHETHER DOES
SEEM INDIVIDUAL SHOULD BE
TRUSTED AND EMPOWERED TO
PROACTIVELY SPEAK FOR SAFETY
WHEN THEY HAVE PERSONAL
KNOWLEDGE OF A PERSON. THREAT TO
THEMSELVES OR TO OTHERS WHERE
THE PUBLIC AT LARGE
I RESPECTFULLY URGE RIVAL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
HI TIFFANI PULLEYBLANK WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
A WHO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GET.
I LISTEN BIGELOW THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT.
WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO REMOVING
GUNS AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
AGGRESSIVE THEMSELVES OR OTHERS
I PROVIDED THERE ARE NON
DISCRIMINATORY CRITERIA AND THAT
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT TO PROCESS.
WE ALSO DID NOT OPPOSE THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE TV ARE OF
SYSTEM. I'M THAT WITH TEN
FOURTEEN BECAUSE THAT WAS
CRAFTED NARROWLY I'M SO THAT
ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PEOPLE
WITH CLOSE. OUR RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL ARE
AUTHORIZED TO SIX
TO SEEK EX PARTY AND ORDERS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL
WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND THE
CLASS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
AUTHORIZED TO SEEK EX PARTY
ORDERS AND. AS THE AS WE HAVE
HEARD IT SOMETIMES CO WORKERS.
CAN'T HAVE A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP
AND BUT DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF
THE WORKPLACE IN THE DYNAMICS OF
THE WORKPLACE I'M IT'S ALSO
POSSIBLE FOR FOR YOU KNOW CO
WORKERS TO HAVE BARELY HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE PERSON.
BEFORE SEEKING AN EX PARTE ORDER
AND OF COURSE THESE ARE ORDERS
WHERE.
THE ORDER IS ISSUED WITHOUT THE
PERSON EVEN HAVING KNOWLEDGE.
KNOWLEDGE THAT THE ORDER HAS
BEEN ISSUED.
.
AND SO THIS EXPANSION TO CO
WORKERS TO EMPLOYERS TO. BOB AND
TWO SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ON IS
REALLY PRONE TO ABUSE AND.
I APPRECIATE THE THE MOST THE
MOST RECENT COMMENTS ABOUT AND
JUDICIAL AND DETERMINATION THERE
BUT. YOU KNOW GIVEN THE CLIMATE
THAT WERE AND I THINK WE CAN
STILL. IMAGINES A PERSON HOLDING
AN IRRATIONAL FEAR BIAS AGAINST
A CO WORKER AYE BECAUSE OF THEIR
RACE BECAUSE OF THEIR RELIGION
BECAUSE OF THEIR NATION OF
ORIGIN. ON AND AND THIS WOULD
AUTHORIZED. AND SOMEONE WHO
HARBORS THOSE FEARS AND WHO IS A
CO WORKER AT THIS PERSON WHO
DOES NOT HAVE A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP TO SEEK AN EX PARTY
ORDER. AND AND THE. ONLY WAY
THAT THAT ARE THE WAY THAT THAT
PERSON WOULD FIND OUT THAT THIS
HAS BEEN ISSUED IS COPS WOULD
SHOW UP AT THEIR DOOR AND THE
MIND DEMAND THAT THEY SURRENDER
THEIR WEAPONS. AND THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT BEEN ACCUSED
OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THEY AND
HAVE NOT MAKE CRIMINAL THREATS.
AND THEY MAY NOT EVEN HAVE ANY
FIREARMS BUT IF AN OFFICER SHOWS
UP AT THEIR HOUSE AND DEMANDING
TO SEE FIREARMS DEMANDED THAT
THEY SURRENDER THERE'S FIREARMS
AND THEY MAY BE SUBJECTED TO A
SEARCH OF THEY IF THEY HAVE NOT
PRODUCED THOSE.
AND THEN FINALLY JUST WANT TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES AN EX PARTE ORDER THE
WHOLE RATIONALE AND EXPERTISE
ORDER IS THE URGENCY OF THE
ALLEGED THREAT.
UNDER THIS BILL A SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE WHO HAS HAD CONTACT
WITH THE STUDENT AT ANY POINT IN
THE LAST SIX MONTHS IS
AUTHORIZED TO SEEK AN EX PARTE
ORDER AND SO. THAT SEEMS IN
CONTESTS ARE INCONSISTENT WITH
THE.
WITH THE IDEA OF OF THE URGENCY
OF AN EX PARTE ORDER. SO.
.
AGAIN WORD NOT OPPOSED TO G.
VERA'S.
WHERE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
AUTHORIZES SEEK THOSE I'M HAVE A
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH A PERSON
THERE NUMBER THE FAMILY OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT?
ON BUT UNFORTUNATE THIS BILL WE
FEEL WHATEVER JUST
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACT AND WOULD
NOT PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU.
MEASURE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
COULD LOSE ABOUT THE FARMS
POLICY COALITION AND.
MY COLLEAGUE WITH THE ACLU IS
EXPRESSED A LOT OF OUR CONCERNS
COUPLE PLACES WHERE WE WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE IS THAT WE DO HAVE
ISSUES WITH NOT SO MUCH THE
CONCEPT OF DVRS BUT WITH THE WAY
IN WHICH THEY'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. DUE PROCESS THAT
OCCURS AFTER ONE'S RIGHTS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN AWAY IS IN FACT NOT
DUE PROCESS. IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ANY ONE
OF A MYRIAD OF EMPLOYEES SO FOR
EXAMPLE THERE ARE OVER TWO
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE.
ANY ONE OF THEM COULD SEEK A GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
AGAINST ANY MEMBER OR STAFF
MEMBER WORKING WITH IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
WHETHER THEY KNOW THEM WHETHER
THEY KNOW THEM OR NOT. AND WHILE
I I WOULD THINK THAT ALSO
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OF TESTIMONY IN
THESE CAN IN THIS IN THIS PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE ABOUT CONCERNS
RELATING TO THINGS LIKE IMPLICIT
BIAS. PA OR UNFAIR.
A POSITION SOMETIMES AND IT
CONCERNS ABOUT OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. I WOULD THINK
THAT ONE WOULD WOULD WOULD.
.
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS CAN EXPAND
BEYOND A NUMBER OF ISSUES
INCLUDING ONE'S POSITION ON
FIREARMS THE FINAL THING THAT
I'D LIKE TO NOTE ABOUT THIS
MEASURES THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING ABOUT A NOTHING UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW. THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT AN INDIVIDUAL FROM
GOING DIRECTLY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT I IN ORDER TO IN
ORDER TO.
REQUEST OR NOTE THAT THIS MIGHT
BE SOME THAT A GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT BE NEEDED. A I THINK AT A
TIME WHEN WE HAVE A LITTLE TO NO
REAL DATA IN TERMS OF OF HOW
MANY HAVE BEEN ISSUED HOW MANY
HAVE BEEN.
HOW MANY HAVE BEEN ISSUED UNDER?
A UNDER GOOD CIRCUMSTANCES AND
HAVE BEEN ISSUED CORRECTLY AND
HOW MANY HAVE BEEN ISSUED
INCORRECTLY I THINK THAT THIS
BILL.
.
DOES NOTHING MORE OTHER
POTENTIALLY VIOLATE THE CIVIL
RIGHTS OF OF CALIFORNIA GUN
OWNERS AND THEREFORE WE ASK THAT
YOU WOULD OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS THAT
MANY FOR THE RECORD DAN REED
WITH NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
ALSO. GIVEN ME TOO FOR GUN
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIANS HERE PA.
A WERE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I ECHO THE SENTIMENTS MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE ACLU FPC.
WERE OPPOSED TO EXPANSION ON
THIS.
HOWEVER WE ARE OPEN TO
DISCUSSING FURTHER OPTIONS.
WITH.
UTILIZING A PROCESS BUT DUE
PROCESS NEEDS TO BE THEIR THIRD
THE EX PARTE IS A HUGE ISSUE FOR
US AS THE REMOVAL OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT WITHOUT
NOTICE OR LITTLE TO NO HEARINGS.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK.
ANOTHER WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
KILEY.
I THINK THAT THE CONCEPT OF GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS IS A
GOOD ONE AND IS ACTUALLY A I
PRETTY SENSIBLE.
TARGETED WAY TO TRY TO.
REDUCE THE THREAT OF GUN
VIOLENCE I AM I WANT TO ASK A
FEW QUESTIONS ABOUT THE WAY THIS
IS. SET UP RIGHT NOW SO WE HEARD
A COUPLE CONCERNS ABOUT AYE DUE
PROCESS AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT IF YOU HAVE ONE OF THESE EX
PARTE ORDER IS THAT THE TWENTY
ONE DAY.
PERIOD BEFORE THEN THE PERSON
WHOSE.
LOSES POSSESSION OF THEIR
FIREARMS HAS THE CHANCE TO BE
HEARD IS THAT RIGHT. YES
WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO MOVING THAT
UP SO THAT THE.
THE HEARING OF THE POST
DEPRIVATION HEARING AFTER SOONER
LIKE IT. WILL AGAIN THESE ARE
ALL ON.
THE GUNS ARE TEMPORARILY
REMOVED.
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU HAVE A DUE
PROCESS HEARING.
MAYBE THAT'S PART OF A LONGER
TERM REMOVAL I THINK THERE WERE
ALL I'M OPEN TO A VARIETY OF
DISCUSSIONS. I DO WANT TO RIP
REFUTE.
I THINK THE OPPOSITION'S
ARGUMENT REGARDING.
PEOPLE WHO ARE. INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE CLOSE JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE'S
RELATED TO A FAMILY MEMBER
DOESN'T MEAN THAT NECESSARILY
CLOSE.
WE OFTENTIMES I PROBABLY SPEND
MORE TIME WITH THE PEOPLE IN
THIS BUILDING DIE EVEN DO MY
FAMILY UNFORTUNATELY.
SO THEY ACTUALLY GET TO SEE ME
A LOT ARE THEN.
MY OWN CHILDREN UNFORTUNATELY.
SO AGAIN I WE WE BELIEVE THAT
IT'S VERY SENSIBLE TOO AGAIN AND
WE'VE CHOSEN A SMALL TARGETED
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
SPEND A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME WITH INDIVIDUALS.
OKAY THAT I SEE THAT POINT AND.
I I PERSONALLY I'D LIKE TO SEE
THAT THE POST DEPRAVATION IF
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE SOMEONE CAN BE X. PARTE.
DEPRIVED OF THE RIGHTS UP LIKE
TO SEE THAT. THE THE HEARING
WHERE THEY CAN BE HEARD LIVE
MUCH CLOSER TO THAT THAT THE
DATE OF THE SEIZURE I THINK
INSTANCE TAKES A TEMPORARY
SITUATION.
RIGHT BUT SO WHAT TWENTY ONE
DAYS YOU CAN BE HEARD SEE IS
THAT MAYBE A FEW DAYS
AFTER THE SEIZURE THEN YOU HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD AND.
AND AND THAT'S ON THE
DETERMINATION IS MADE WHETHER TO
EXTEND IT TO YEAR I'M SO ALSO ON
THE POINT OF ON THEM IT DOES.
THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT THIS
HOUSING AND USE THAT MUCH SINCE
THE INITIAL BELL RIGHT AND
MOSTLY IT'S BEEN DONE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO. OUT WHAT ABOUT
THE IDEA THAT INSTEAD OF GIVING
NEW.
CLASSES OF PEOPLE THE RIGHT TO
PETITION THEMSELVES MAYBE WE CAN
SET UP A BETTER SYSTEM FOR
ALLOWING PEOPLE THAT I PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS DEAD PEOPLE THE BAY
THEMSELVES MIGHT AND ONE OF
PETITIONS FOR. WHAT WILL PEOPLE
HAVE THAT ABILITY RIGHT NOW?
RIGHT SO WELL I DON'T BELIEVE WE
NEED NEW LOG TO DO THAT.
I SEE SO GUY. I'M JUST I GUESS
I'M WONDERING HOW OFTEN. YOU
THINK SOMEONE'S GONNA THEMSELVES
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS OF GOING
TO COURT AND GO THROUGH THE
WHOLE PROCEDURE FOR PETITIONING.
I'M.
MIGHT BE EASIER IF WE PROVIDED
MORE INFORMATION TO PEOPLE ABOUT
AS YOU SAY SOME AND THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO DO NOW WHICH IS TO.
ALERT LAW ENFORCEMENT TO THE
EXISTENCE OF A POTENTIAL THREAT.
I AGAIN.
YOU WE CAN'T CURRENTLY.
LET PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT THIS
PROVISION I KNOW NEITHER OF THE
TWO COUNTIES THAT I'VE. THAT I
REPRESENT HAVE TO HAVE UTILIZED
A PROVISION.
STE SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY
JUST RECENTLY I ISSUE TEN GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS.
YOU KNOW GO THROUGH HER THROUGH
HER OFFICE A WORKING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. A AGAIN WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A SENSIBLE
EXPANSION IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED IN PARK LAND AND YOU AT
LAW ENFORCEMENT A COULD DOESN'T
THINK IF THEY HAD A GBR O. BUILT
THEY COULD DONE SOMETHING THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO.
IF WE HAD SCHOOL OFFICIALS WITH
THIS EXPANSION THEY COULD HAVE
DONE SOMETHING AGAIN THIS IS
ALLOWING ORDINARY PEOPLE TOOL
AND IT'S JUST SIMPLY THAT A
TOOL.
TO AYE TAKE MATTERS INTO THEIR
OWN HANDS TO GET. GUNS OUT OF
THE HANDS OF VERY DANGEROUS
PEOPLE WHO OBVIOUSLY.
GIVEN WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS CAN CAUSE A
GREAT AMOUNT OF DAMAGE IN A VERY
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
I THINK YOU AND FINAL QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
FOR ABUSE THE CONCERNS BEEN
REYES DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S
BEEN HAPPENING SO FAR SINCE
THERE BEEN SO FEW CASES BUT WHEN
YOU OPEN IT UP TO SUCH A WIDE
ACROSS THE PEOPLE. ARE THERE ANY
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE TO PREVENT
THIS FROM BEING ABUSED ACROSS
OPAL. AGAIN NO WE ARE THAT WAS
THE ARGUMENT WAS MADE AND.
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHEN THE BILL
WAS FIRST KERRY'S ARGUMENT A
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN I CARRY THIS
LEGISLATION. WELL WE WE HAVEN'T
SEEN IT.
I DON'T REALLY BELIEVE ARE
COMING IF YOU THINK GOING
THROUGH. A COM COURT PROCESS.
IS NOT.
IS EASY I MEAN I. I DON'T
REALLY LOOK AT GOING TO COURT AS
A PROCESS IT'S VERY VERY SIMPLE.
SO AGAIN I DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT
WILL BE ABUSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE ANY MORE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. YOU MAY CLOSE.
BUT AGAIN YOU KNOW OUR GOODBYES
RESTRAINING ORDERS HAVE PROVEN
TO BE A TOOL THAT CAN BE USED TO
GET GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
WRONG PEOPLE. WE'VE SEEN
UNFORTUNATE THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF MASS SHOOTINGS WHEN
GUNS ARE IN THE HANDS OF RON
PEOPLE.
THIS JUST MERELY EXPANDS IT TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE AROUND
INDIVIDUALS TO MOST PEOPLE YOU
GO TO SCHOOL WITH PEOPLE WHO TO
WORK WITH. I BELIEVE IT'S A
SENSIBLE EXPANSION RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIGHT ON.
GRAY IN A MINUTE AND.
WHEN WE FIRST EGGMAN SHOOTING
ALIKE COMMEND YOU ON.
.
COMING UP WITH THE BILL TAKING
GET BOTH THE NRA AND ACLU ON THE
SAME PAGE.
ON.
WE HAVE ANY HEALTH APPROACH.
SURE YOU KNOW THAT IS
REMARKABLE.
.
AND SO I AM ALSO IN THAT THEY
MAKE SOME VALID POINTS ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT.
.
THERE'S NO OVERREACH ORDERS IT'S
NO PROBLEM IS DUE PROCESS.
IN THAT SIR AND I AND I BELIEVE
YOU'LL LOOK INTO THAT AS IT
HOPEFULLY TIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. ON ENTERTAINS UP AND
AYE RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR.
MR MOTION.
ON AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I COULD VIDEO. CARILLO
AYE CATALOGUER DEATH.
CAN BOTHERED ABOUT BOATING
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
TO CUNNINGHAM ITEM NUMBER ONE
SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT.
THIS BILL WOULD CLOSE A
SIGNIFICANT LOOPHOLE IN THE
CURRENT SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY BY
REQUIRING A TEAR TO.
TWENTY YEAR REGISTRATION PERIOD.
FOR AN ADULT WHO SOLICITS
SOLICITS A MINOR VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THAT
ADULT KNEW OR REASONABLY SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN.
THAT THE PERSON WAS BOTH. ONE A
MINOR AND TO A VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THIS OFFENSE
DOES NOT REQUIRE REGISTRATION.
AND I JUST WANT TO BE CRYSTAL
CLEAR ABOUT THE THE LIMITED
NATURE OF THIS BILL WE WE HAVE
AMENDED THE BILL IT ONLY APPLIES
TO ADULT OFFENDERS NOT MINOR
OFFENDERS.
AND THE ADULTOFFENDER HAS TO
SOLICIT SOMEONE WHO IS BOTH A
MINOR.
AND A VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
WHERE THAT IS KNOWN OR SHOULD
HAVE BEEN KNOWN UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES?
I'M.
HERE WITH MISTER RYAN SHERMAN
FROM THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION TO BRIEFLY TESTS
FIND SUPPORT.
MORNING MISS CHAIR AND SHERMAN
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION OF WERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
WHICH SEEKS TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE CURRENTLY IN THE
CALIFORNIA SEX ARSON REGISTRY
THAT ALLOWS AN OFFENDER.
TO AVOID REGISTRATION IF THAT
OFFENDER KNEW OR REASONABLY
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT THE MINOR
THEY WERE ENGAGING IN SEXUAL
ACTIVITY WITH.
WAS WITH WHAT WAS A MAN OF
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
.
SIMILAR TO THE STATUTORY RAPE
LAWS. A SPECIFIC INTENT IS NOT A
REQUIRED ELEMENT TO ATTACH
STRICT LIABILITY FOR UP FOR
CERTAIN CRIMES.
AND SUCH LIKE SAID STATURE IRATE
WAS ONE OF THOSE AND WE THINK
THAT THIS WILL.
.
HELP EFFORTS
TO CRACKDOWN IN REDUCE THE
PREVALENCE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND OR SEXUAL MUSA MINERS. AND
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
SEAN ON WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
JIM MEMBERS JONATHAN FELDMAN
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
LUCIA MUCH LARABEE HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
NOT SETTLING WE HAVE THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ARE A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING GLORY KATHY SURE
FOR THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
CENTER FOR ADVOCACY IN POLICY.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WOULD
IMPOSE RIGID REQUIREMENT FOR
REGISTRATION FOR TWENTY YEARS
FOR CONVICTED JON'S WHERE THE
PERSON KNEW OR REASONABLY SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN THAT THE PERSON WAS A
MINOR AND A VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THIS IS NOT ONLY UNNECESSARY AS
A JUDGE COULD IMPOSE
REGISTRATION UNDER EXISTING LAW
BUT IT WILL RISK RESULT IN AN
INCREASED BURDEN ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WOULD HAVE
TO PROCESS REGISTRATION
PAPERWORK. AND TAKE RESOURCES
AWAY FROM THE FACT MONITORING OF
THOSE REGISTERED OFFENDERS WHO
POSE THE GREATEST RISK OF RE
OFFENDING. WE ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE.
MARCO GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
I WOULD ECHO BASHIR'S COMMENTS
BUT I WILL ALSO ASK YOU. TO
CONSIDER FIRST ON. THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRATION SYSTEM WAS
OVERHAULED LAST YEAR WITH SP
THREE. EIGHTY FOUR AND THAT IS
REALLY TOO EARLY TO US CHANGE
START CHANGING THE RULES.
ALSO I THERE'S NO RESEARCH
SHOWING THAT.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE.
BEEN ARRESTED AND CHARGED WITH
PROSTITUTION FOR SOLICITATION OR
ATTEMPTED SOLICITATION. ARE AT
RISK TO RE OFFEND SO IT'S
TARGETING A GROUP. THAT HAS NOT
BEEN FOUND BY ANY RESEARCH TO BE
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE PUT ON THE
STE KIND OF LIST IN FACT.
THEY ARE IF THERE IS SOME
PERSONAL INFORMATION IN THE
BACKGROUND OF THE INDIVIDUAL.
THEN AS THIS YEAR SAID. THEY
CAN'T THE JUDGE CAN.
REQUIRE REGISTRATION BUT
THERE'S NO RESEARCH SO.
SHOWING THAT SOMEONE WHO HAS
BEEN THEM BAREST AND ARRESTED
FOR PROSTITUTION IS LIKELY TO RE
OFFEND.
.
THE OTHER THING TO CONSIDER IS A
BE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
PLACING SOMEONE.
.
THE REGISTRATION EVEN IF.
IT'S TIER TWO FOR TWENTY YEARS.
YOU ARE ON PUTTING THE FAMILY IN
THE POSITION OF BEING SHAMED AND
SINGLED OUT THE COMMUNITY.
YOU ARE IT ENDANGERS THEIR
EMPLOYMENT WHICH THEN COULD LEAD
TO THE.
ECONOMIC MARGINALISATION OF THE
ENTIRE FAMILY.
IT.
FOR CLOSES MANY OPPORTUNITIES IN
LIFE.
THAT ON THEM YOU NEVER EVER GET
BACK.
SO I DON'T THINK.
AND I ASK YOU FOR YOUR NO BOAT
RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES NOT POSITION.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE WITH CUNNINGHAM
THANK YOU I'D JUST. LIKE TO
ADDRESS BRIEFLY A COUPLE THE
ISSUES RAISED I ACTUALLY THINK
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE TEARS THE
SYSTEM NOW. IS.
THE VERY REASON THIS BILLS.
APPROPRIATE.
AND MY CONCERN THE BILL IS THE
CHAIR KNOWS LAST YEAR BUT I
DIDN'T FEEL THAT IT WAS.
A PRUDENT BECAUSE OF THE
LIFETIME REGISTRATION NATURE OF
THE PRIOR SYSTEM BUT NOW THAT WE
HAVE A TIERED SYSTEM I THINK.
IT'S.
A REASONABLE.
MEASURE BECAUSE NOW TO TIER TWO
NOT A LIFETIME REGISTRATION
IT'S.
WE WE'VE SORT OF OVER ALL THAT
AND.
WAS GENERALLY VIEWED AS A MORE
MANAGEABLE WAY I THINK THIS TYPE
OF OFFENSES.
.
A PERFECT CANDIDATE TO ADD TO
THE TO THE TIER TWO I THINK NOW
THAT WE GOT THAT OUT OF THE WAY.
WE CAN START LOOKING AT SOME OF
THE GAPS IN OUR LAWS THAT ARE
MEANT TO. OF PROTECT FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN AND.
AGAIN THIS BILL THAT DOES NOT
APPLY TO PROSTITUTES THIS IS
JOHN'S THIS THESE ARE PEOPLE
SOLICITING. AND THE VICTIMS IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY YOU FOR UNDER
THIS BILL FOR REGISTRATION THE
VICTIM.
THE VICTIM HAS TO BE A MINOR.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT ARE THAT ARE.
GOING AFTER CHILDREN AND THE
MOST VULNERABLE AMONG US PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN TRAFFICKED.
ESSENTIAL IN A FORM OF HUMAN
SLAVERY AND AND.
.
SO I WOULD WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I
VOTE THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU
SEE CUNNINGHAM AND TAKE YOU FOR
FOR WORKING ON THIS.
FORTUNATE OF THE TEACHERS CAN
RECOMMEND A NO VOTE. ON A
CHUCKLE MISTER MOTION UC'S.
ON AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY.
LACKEY ICARLY YA.
CARILLO NO CATALOGUER DEV.
CATALOGUER TOUGH NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
SORRY THAT MEASURE FAILED.
THIS RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
I'M RECONSIDERING. ON
RECONSIDERATION JONES SAWYER.
IT MADE A GREAT SAWYER NO
LACKEY.
LACKEY I GOT RIO.
CARILLO NO CATALOGUER DEF. CAN
LONGER DEATH NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
AUTOMATIC.
MISTER GIPSON.
THE CHAIRMAN OUT OF TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO AT TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT. EITHER FOR OVER FIFTEEN
AND.
NUMBER SIXTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON THE.
CHAIRS DESIRE BY CAN TAKE OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE TWO.
FIRSTS.
THOSE GUNS.
A.
TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT EIGHT.
I'M SORRY. A. B. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO.
WHICH IS THE GHOST WHICH ONE IS.
GO SCOTT WHAT WHATEVER ONE.
ROB WHAT AWAY FOR ONE PERSON
COMING IN BUT IT'S OKAY WILL
MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO. WHICH SEEKS TO CLOSE
THE GHOST GARDEN.
LEUPOLD BY REQUIRING THE STATE.
OF BACKGROUND CHECK FOR
PURCHASING OF GOES UP SCUSE ME
OF GUN PARTS AND ALSO CREATING
NEW LICENSE STRUCTURE FOR GUNS.
PARTS DEALERS GOES GUNS ARE VERY
REAL ISSUE.
IN THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH I
REPRESENT IN THE COURT AS WELL
AS ACROSS THE STATE.
NOT TOO LONG AGO THERE WAS A
SHOOTING. IN.
MODES ARE SECOND.
MISTER QUIRK SECOND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WARY EYE MAN MURDERED
FIVE PEOPLE INCLUDING HIS WIFE
AND.
WITH THEY GOES GOD THERE WAS A
MAN THAT WAS PROHIBITED FROM
PURCHASING A FIRE ARM SO HE TOOK
TO THE INTERNET TO BUY GUN PARTS
HIMSELF AND BUILD HIS OWN GUN.
THIS WAS ALSO THE CASE IN SANTA
MONICA TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WAY
MEN ATTEMPT TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM BUT WAS NOT ALLOWED TO
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE FOUND HIM IN
ELIGIBLE.
HE THEN RESORTED TO BUILDING HIS
OWN GUN.
WHICH THEN HE USED TO KILL FIVE
PEOPLE INJURING SEVERAL OTHERS.
THESE GUNS.
COULD NOT EASILY BE PUT
EXCUSE ME COULD EASILY BE
PREVENTED IF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TWO WAS
ALREADY IN ACTIVE BECAUSE. THE
SHOOTER WOULD NOT BE.
ALLOW TO PURCHASE AND NOR WOULD
THAT PERSON.
PASS A BACKGROUND.
CHECK CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR BOTH GUN
SALES AND AMMUNITION YET IT IS
SILENCE ON THE OUR TREATMENT OF
FIRE PRECURSOR THIS BILL INTENDS
TO IMPROVE THE PUBLIC SAFETY BY
PROVIDING.
CREW BY PREVENTING CRIMINALS
AND THOSE WHO SHOULD NOT
OTHERWISE POSSESS THE FAR ARM
FROM GAINING ACCESS WHILE
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF GUN
OWNERS WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. IS MISS
AMANDA WILCOX WITH THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN AND ALSO WILL HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THAT THE BODY MAY HAVE.
AGAIN AMANDA WILCOX WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
I WILL BE BRIEF AS APPEARS THERE
IS SUPPORT.
.
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN SCORE POLICY
GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A BACKGROUND CHECK ON
EVERYONE WHO HAS A FIREMAN ALSO
THAT YOU JAY HAS A RECORD OF
THAT GUN IN CASE THE PERSON
BECOMES PROHIBITED OR IF THE
GUNS USED IN CRIME IT CAN BE
TRACED.
AND FORTUNE CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
A VERY VERY ALARMING AND
ESCALATING PROBLEM WITH.
GOES GUNS GUNS THAT ARE
ASSEMBLED FROM PARTS INCLUDING
UNFINISHED RECEIVERS THAT DO NOT
HAVE A SERIAL NUMBER.
AND.
R. APPEARS COMMONLY USED IN
CRIME APART AVOID OUR GUN LAWS
IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU'VE HEARD
OF SOME OF THE INCIDENTS OF THIS
MENTIONED.
WE TRIED IT AND THIS IS BUT I
ISSUE WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING TO
DEAL WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
A BILL PASSED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER THAT
GOVERNOR SIGNED WOULD REQUIRE
THOSE WHO ASSEMBLE MANUFACTURE
GUNS TO.
GET A SERIAL NUMBER HAVE A
BACKGROUND CHECK AND DOJ WOULD
HAVE A RECORD. THAT'S DIFFICULT
TO ENFORCE BECAUSE THAT.
RELIES ON THE THE PERSON MAKING
THE GUN TO TAKE ACTION AND I
THINK A BETTER FAR BETTER
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM IS TO
REQUIRE.
SELLERS OF THESE PARTS
TO FOLLOW CERTAIN PROCEDURES
INCLUDING A BACKGROUND CHECK IN
THE SCHEME THAT IS PROPOSED IN
THE BILL IS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
IS CURRENTLY UNDER DEVELOPMENT
MY UNDERSTANDING GOING VERY
WELL.
WITHIN HIM A BACKGROUND CHECKS
SCHEME THAT WE HAVE WHERE
THERE'S THE INSTANT CHECK AND A
RECORD.
THAT IS MAINTAINED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SO I I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD WAY TO GET
A HANDLE ON THIS PROBLEM AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
NADER WITNESSES OR.
ANY OF.
HOUSING QUICK BAY AREA STUDENT
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT.
LOUIS MO WITH SHIRE AGUIAR-CURRY
HAVE OF THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA
AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED WE'VE
SUFFERED THE IMPACTS OF THESE
GHOSTS GUNS AND THEREFORE
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THINK YOU.
MAKE YOU.
IRATE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THINK WE NEED TO MAKE WAY
.
THE CHAIRMAN OF IT. MEMBERS
SEPARATIST REPRESENTING GUN
OWNERS CALIFORNIA. AND PROBABLY
THE ONLY ONE HERE WHO HAS.
.
BEEN A MANUFACTURER OF FIREARMS.
FOR YEARS SO I'M I'M MADE
RIFLES
MANUFACTURED.
AND SO I HAVE A CERTAIN LEVEL
EXPERTISE THIS BILL IS CALLING
FOR. FIRST OF ALL IT'S INVENTING
TERMINOLOGY IN IN IN THE FORM
OF.
PRECURSOR PARTS AND AND ALL OF
THIS.
.
THERE ARE A COUPLE THINGS THAT
YOU HAVE NOT HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
MANY OF THESE PARTS.
ARE NOT ONLY USED IN.
MODERN SPORTING RIFLES OR WHAT.
THE STATE LEGISLATURE LIKES TO
CALL ASSAULT WEAPONS
THERE USED IN GUNS THAT ARE NOT
SEMIAUTOMATIC THEY'RE NOT.
THERE IN VARIOUS CALIBERS DID
VARIOUS KINDS THEY ARE GENERIC
PARTS INCLUDING TRIGGERED
GROUPS.
MAGAZINE RELEASES BOLTS STOPS
BOLTS.
BOB VERSION LOWERS ALL OF THOSE
THINGS WHEN IT'S NOT A
SEMIAUTOMATIC GUN SO WE'RE
CALLING TO.
REGISTER AND DO BACKGROUND
CHECKS ON GUNS THAT THAT.
I HAVE NOT BEEN THIS THAT THE
SUBJECT OF ANY SORT OF
LEGISLATION.
THAT NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO THAT
THE COMMENT EARLIER THAT THE.
PROCESS FOR REGISTERING
AMMUNITION PURCHASES IS GOING
ALONG REALLY WELL I FIND THAT.
KIND OF AN AMAZING STATEMENT
SINCE I IT HAS NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IN NO REGULATIONS
HAVE BEEN WRITTEN. IN ORDER FOR
US TO FIGURE OUT HOW IT IS THE
STATE IS GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF.
REGISTERING AND DOING THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR AMMUNITION
PURCHASES THAT HASN'T HAPPENED
YET.
IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH THIS YOU
WOULD BE REQUIRED SIR TO HAVE.
STORES IN THE COMPANIES THAT
SELL BLOCKS OF PLASTIC AND
ALUMINUM.
WHICH COULD BE CONSIDERED UNDER
THIS BILL AS A PRECURSOR PART.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO HAVE THE
SHAPES.
THAT.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WOULD NORMALLY
THINK ABOUT HAVING A PRE
MANUFACTURER PARTIALLY
MANUFACTURE PART HE COULD BE A
BLOCK OF ALUMINUM.
OR A BLOCK OF PLASTIC AND IT CAN
BE.
MADE INTO A FIREARM.
THE ABILITY FOR PRIVATE PEOPLE
TO MAKE PRIVATE FIREARMS HAS
BEEN WITH US SINCE UNITED STATES
BECAME A COUNTRY IT IS A RIGHT
THAT IS OPEN AND AVAILABLE TO.
ALL CITIZENS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY IT IS.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW AND IT HAS
BEEN HERE THE VERY FEW CASES
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP WARY.
GHOST GUN HAS BEEN USED IN THE
COMMISSION OF A CRIME AND THE
FACT THAT.
A VERY SMALL POSITION UP.
PERCENTAGE OF ALL CRIMES ARE
COMMITTED WITH LONG GUNS.
WOULD. INDICATE THAT THIS BILL
IS NOT REALLY NECESSARY IN IS
NOT GOING TO ACCOMPLISH
ANYTHING.
IF THE PEOPLE WHO COMMITTED
THESE CRIMES ARE ABLE TO TO BILL
GUNS FROM GOES GUNS THEY'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO GET GUNS FROM.
ALL KINDS OF OTHER THE GONNA
STEAL THEM THEY'RE GONNA BRING
IN FROM OTHER STATES ARE GOING
TO.
IT IS IT'S NOT AN ISSUE THIS IS
NOT GOING TO PREVENT ONE SINGLE
DEATH FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD THE AND
WE WOULD NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
THIS BILLS INCREDIBLY OVERBROAD
AS MY COLLEAGUE STATED.
.
I KNOW THE INTENT OF THIS IS TO.
FURTHER THAT THE SO CALLED
GHOST GUN LAW OR THE UNFINISHED
FRAMES AND RECEIVERS.
BUT THAT WAS NOT EVEN BEEN FULLY
IMPLEMENTED RIGHT NOW WE'RE
STILL.
GOING THROUGH THE REGULATIONS
WERE SO GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF EVEN SEEING HOW
THAT'S GOING TO BE ENFORCED.
AND WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
HERE I ARE NOT FIREARMS THE
PRECURSOR PARTS THEIR THEIR
CONSUMABLES
THERE'RE THERE'RE. ITEMS ON
FIREARMS DAY NEED REPLACING THAT
ARE OFTEN UPGRADE IT.
AND THEY'RE NOT FIREARMS
THEY'RE NOT TREATED LIKE
FIREARMS ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY
AND THERE IS A REASON WHY
THEY'RE NOT TREATED AS FIREARMS.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT
IS A FRAME THAT'S WOOD FRAMES
ARE TREATED AS FARMS BECAUSE IF
THEY'RE INTERTWINED REALIZE IT
PARTS ARE IN RECALL BUT AGAIN
THERE A CAN THESE ARE PARTS OR
CONSUMABLES THAT. THAT BREAK
THAT NEED REPLACING AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER.
AND THIS WHICH IS CREATING
ENFORCEMENT NINE.
RIGHT I MEAN HOW DO YOU IN FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BARRELS TRIGGER
GROUPS.
.
MAGAZINES EXETER AT THESE ARE
THESE ARE PARTS THAT IN SOME
CASES ARE.
PUT ON ATTACHED WILL FIRE HOW DO
YOU HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT SOMEONE
EVER COMPLIED WITH. WITH THIS
LAW THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
SIMILAR TO THE AMMUNITION
BACKGROUND CHECK IS MY
COLLEAGUES STATED HERE.
HOWEVER THAT'S NOT BEEN.
BEEN FULLY IMPLEMENTED IT HAS.
IT WILL BE VERY INTERESTING TO
SEE HOW THAT ACTUALLY PLAYS OUT
AND WHEN WE ACTUALLY DO SEE
REGULATIONS ON HOW THAT ACTS.
THAT BACKGROUND CHECK WILL.
WILL WORK IN REAL LIFE FOR THIS
IN A HOST OF OTHER REASONS THAT
WE STAND IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS ARE COMMITTEE CRAIG
DELUDE ABOUT FOR THE FIREARMS
POLICY COALITION FOR THE REASONS
ALREADY STATED BY MY COLLEAGUES.
IN AND PRIMARILY THE FACT THAT
THE ENTIRE REGULATORY SCHEME IS
BASED ON A SCHEME THAT THEY'RE
QUITE FRANKLY HAS NOT YET HAS
YET TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
I KNOW THEY'RE WORKING HARD TO
TRY AND MAKE IT HAPPEN BUT THEY
WEREN'T EXACTLY HANDED. A SOLID
PIECE OF LEGISLATION FACT IS
THEY WERE THEY WERE HANDED A
PILE OF CHICKEN MANURE AND TOLD
TO MAKE CHICKEN SALAD AND
THEY'RE DOING THE BEST THAT THEY
CAN BUT SO FAR. WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE
AND UNTIL WE KNOW THAT WE OUGHT
NOT BE BASING FURTHER A
REGULATORY SCHEMES ARE ON ON
THAT SAME SCHEME SO WITH THAT
WE.
WE WOULD ASK YOU OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN CAPULETS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION AN
OUTDOOR SPORTSMAN'S COALITION.
CALIFORNIA'S A CHAPTERS A
SPARKLE OF INTERNATIONAL ON
STRONG OPPOSITION AND I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT.
YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS ATTEMPTING TO DO A
GOOD JOB ON ALL THESE
REGULATIONS BUT THE ARM
PROHIBITED PERSONS.
PROGRAM.
IS UNDER HAS BEEN UNDER SIEGE
FOR A LONG TIME THEY HAVE A HUGE
BACKLOG AND THOSE ARE OUR REAL
PROBLEMS THAT NEED TO BE
RESOLVED. AND IF YOU MONITOR THE
BUDGET HEARINGS YOU YOU WITNESS
HOW BACKLOG DOJ AS A LONG GUN
REGISTRATION AND A LOT OF ISSUES
OF THIS WOULD JUST COMPLICATE.
AND ACTUALLY PUT MORE CRIMINALS
ON THE STREET IN OUR OPINION
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
NAME IN.
ORGANIZATION DEMOCRAT OPPOSED.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER. IN
OPPOSITION.
ARE A QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER GIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
.
I HAVE THE.
WITH ME AND AGENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OF VERY
BRIEFLY WITH THE CHAIRS
INDULGENT IF YOU CAN JUST TOUCH
BASE OF SOME OF THE.
I THINK OUTLANDISH THINGS OF
COMMERCE THAT WERE MADE BY THOSE
WHO OPPOSE IN THIS BILL AND THE
DOLLARS WILL WRAP IT WORK
VIEWPOINT SOME OF MY OWN.
OKAY MAKE IT.
THANK YOU.
SPECIAL AGENT SUPERVISOR BILLY
GRAHAM WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ADDUCED TO QUICK POINTS.
PART OF THIS BILL A PENAL CODE
SECTION SIXTEEN FIVE THREE ONE
SUBSECTION BE. DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO CREATE
A SOME WRITTEN GUIDANCE ON
PATROL PICTORIAL DIAGRAMS
DEMONSTRATING EACH CATEGORY OF
FARM. PICKER SUPPORT.
FOR THE SAKE OF CLARITY OF WHAT
ITEMS WERE IT WOULD NOT BE
NECESSARILY CONTROLLED BY THE
SLOW.
SECONDLY.
SOME THE ITEMS HERE.
UNDER THAT SAME SECTION. THAT
ARE DESCRIBED AS FIRE
PRECURSORS.
.
ONE OF WHICH IS THAT HAVE
SPECIFICALLY A POLYMER HANDGUN
FRAME THAT HAS RECENTLY COME ON
THE MARKET. IF THAT.
KIT IS BUILT UP IT'S GOING TO
TRIGGER SOME OTHER COMPLICATIONS
FOR FOLKS. REGARDING HANDGUN
ROSTER THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN IN
PLACE FOR QUITE AWHILE IT'S AN
AFFECTS GONNA LIKELY.
.
IF THEY MANUFACTURE THESE POOR
KIDS
IT'S GONNA HAVE A SCENARIO WHERE
THEIR.
CREATING AN UNSAFE HANDGUN AS.
DESCRIBED IN THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND AND THE PENAL CODE
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU MAY
CLOSE MISTER GRIFFIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AS. I PASS OUT A COPY OF A.
KNOWS NEWS ARTICLE THAT WAS.
DEPICTING A MAN THAT WAS
ARRESTED IN MY DISTRICT IN
WHAT'S WHERE HE WAS A SYMBOL I.
WHEN HE WAS ACTION PUTTING
TOGETHER GHOST GUNS A ARE OF
FIFTEENS THIS WANT TO COMMITTEES
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT INFORMATION.
WE MUST GET A HANDLE GOES GUNS.
THE GOVERNOR.
SENT THEM A MESSAGE IN HIS VETO
MESSAGE AND I BROUGHT THIS BILL
SIMILAR.
BUT THIS.
WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED INFORMATION
AND WORKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
JUST AS A MANY OTHERS TO A VERY
VERY FOCUSED WHEN IT COMES DOWN
TO GOES GUNS. AND WE DON'T WANT
THESE GOES GUNS TO APPEAR ON OUR
STREETS
EXPRESSING COMMUTERS IN WHICH I
REPRESENT BUT NO WHERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK WHAT SETS
US APART FROM. OTHER NATIONS
BECAUSE WE HAVE TAKEN A VERY
AGGRESSIVE AND VERY PROACTIVE
STANCE TO MAKING SURE THAT GUNS
Y. ARE NOT MADE WITHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE KNOWLEDGE
AND THE CALL GOES GUNS. TO
MAKING SURE THESE GUYS NOT WIND
UP ON OUR STREETS AND WE HAVE
SITUATIONS TAKE PLACE THAT
HAPPEN TO PASS OUR RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU AND IT CHAIRS
RECOMMEND AYE VOTE.
WEEK WE DO NEAT AS SOMEONE A
SIX ON PUBLIC SAFETY BUDGET. WE
DO NEED TO WORK. REALLY HARD TO
ENSURE THAT ONLY HAVE FUNDING.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO DEFEAT THE
SYSTEM THAT WE WE SET UP TO.
TO REGULATE THE ARMS THAT ARE
OUT THERE THAT WE.
WE ACTUALLY GET THOSE DONE AND
MORE PART OF IT GET RID THE
BACKLOG SO THAT.
THE LAWS THAT WE HAVE ENACTED
ARE ARE BEING ABLE TO WILL BE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT.
AND SO I WILL BE WORKING ON ON
THAT.
TO TO ENSURE THAT THAT THAT
HAPPENS
NOW THAT WE ULTIMATELY HAVE A
REALLY GOOD. CHICKEN SOUP YOU
KNOW.
SO CHAIRS RECOMMENDED I.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
OUR JOBS ARE AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
NO CARDIO. CARDIO I CAN'T LOG OR
DEATH.
CAN WATER DEPTH AYE KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT.
OF THANK YOU.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR. FORTY EIGHT.
JACK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THIS BASE WE HAVE INTERNET
ACCESS.
TO.
JUVENILES WHO ARE DETAINED IN
DETENTION CENTERS OF THE
GOVERNOR OF THIS BILL CAME
BEFORE YOU LAST YEAR THE
GOVERNOR. OF VETO THE BILL WHICH
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY ELEVEN AND
IN HIS VETO MESSAGE YOU WANTED
TO TO FOCUS ON.
LOCAL JUVENILE FACILITIES SO
WE'VE DONE THAT WORK AND THAT'S
THE REASON WHY THIS BILL BEFORE
TODAY I HAVE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SELF
INTRODUCED.
THIS IS A SUPPORT NO OPPOSITION
SELECT.
I AM LUCY SAUCEDO CARTER WITH
THE YOUTH LAW CENTER WE ARE
SPONSORING THE BILL AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AQ.
MY NAME IS PLAYED A STRIKE WITH
CALIFORNIA THESE CONNECTS IN A
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR I. THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT
LIZZY BEACON WHAT THEY SAY OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CANADA BECAUSE OUR
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
ANNA JOHNSON NATIONAL CENTER
FEES LIE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MARCO GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI TIFFANI PULLEYBLANK WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER GET
RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
YOU HAVE MOTION IF.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER I CHEN SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY NO CARILLO. CUTTING YOUR
AYE CATALOGUER DEATH. CAMERA
THAT I KILEY. QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
COOPER.
A. B..
THIRTY ONE OWE FOR. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
AB THIRTY WILL FOR MAKES CHANGES
TO THE FELONY MURDER RULE TO
MAKE IT MORE CLEAR.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL RECOGNIZE
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
DEFENDANT AND ACCOMPLICE IN THE
COMMISSION OF THE MURDER.
CURRENTLY LAWS NOT MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION AND RESULT IN THE
SAME SENSE FOR BOTH DEFENDANT
AND THE ACCOMPLICE CHARGE A
CERTAIN MURDERS. AB THIRTY ONE
OF FOUR SEPARATE SEVERAL OF THE
DEFENDANT AN ACCOMPLICE. IN THE
COMMISSION OF A MURDER AND
ASSIGNS LIABILITY. MORE CLEARLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE NO
OPPOSITION.
YOU CAN ONLY MAKE IT WORSE.
SURE CAMP UGH MORNING MISTER
CHAIR IF MEMBERS SHOT OFF WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION WOULD ASK
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT.
SEAN UNDER WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IT'S
PART.
RANCHER WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION SPORT.
THANK YOU THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MISTER COOPER YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OBSTETRICAL WORLD AB THIRTY ONE
OF FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
JONES SAWYER.
ACTIONS ARE AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE KILEY YOU. CARILLO I
CAN'T BLOGGER DEV. CAN LEVERED
UP AYE KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
COMMITTEE MATHIS
.
CHAIR AND HAVE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AND ADDRESSING
BACKGROUND CHECKS WITH VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTERS.
THEY I APPRECIATE THE. THE THE.
DISCUSSION WITH THE STAFF AND
WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR.
.
AND WITH THE FIRST AND THE
SECOND ALL BE QUIET NOW FOR AN
AYE VOTE ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS
ABSOLUTELY SURE.
THANK YOU ANY WITH NO.
IT MOVED AND SECONDED.
IT'S BEEN DONE UP ANY ANY BY THE
OPPOSITION.
IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF.
AND WAS IT IN MY FACE
CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATE WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHTY
NINE WE WE HAVE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS BUT WE DO REMAIN
OPPOSED. TO TRY TO KEEP THIS
SHORT IT DOES ALLOW BROADER
ACCESS TO A PERSON'S RAP SHEET.
INCLUDING THEIR ARREST RECORDS
VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTER COULD BE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BECAUSE OF
THEIR PRIOR ARRESTS FOR WHICH
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN CONVICTED OR
BECAUSE OF PRIOR CONVICTIONS
THAT ARE COMPLETELY UNRELATED.
TO THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF BEING
A VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTER AND I DO
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT MANY
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE PRISONS ARE
NOT RECEIVED TRAINING AS
FIREFIGHTERS THEY RISK THEIR
LIVES THEY FIGHT FIRES ON THE
FRONT LINES. I'M WHILE THEY'RE
SERVING THEIR SENTENCE AND SO
THERE IS NO LOGIC IN A POLICY
THAT WOULD AND THE USE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO FIGHT
FIRES AND THEN ALLOWED TO. ALLOW
THAT DISCRIMINATION AGAINST THEM
ON THAT WHEN THEY ARE APPLYING
TO BE COME VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTERS AFTER THEY LEAVE
INCARCERATION. I'M SO WE THINK
THAT THIS IS HARMFUL AND
STIGMATIZING TO.
PREVENT.
.
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE WHO
ARE FULLY TRAINED I'M FROM
ENGAGING. MEANINGFUL ACTIVITIES
AND FOR WHICH THERE FULLY
QUALIFIED SO AND WE DO THINK
THAT AB TWENTY NIN IS.
DISCRIMINATING AND WILL INCREASE
UNFAIR BARRIERS TO RE ENTRY FOR
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY IN.
I DID ASK FOR ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS NON.
ARE YOU MAY CLOSE.
JUST TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS.
IN IT AND FIRST OFF I'D LIKE TO
GIVE A LITTLE A FAMILY HISTORY
ON MY STEP FATHER GROWING UP
ACTUALLY RAN DE MER MONEY CAMP.
ON THE AND I'M QUITE VERSED ON
OUR.
INMATE POPULATIONS THAT RECEIVE
THE TRAINING.
I WANTED NOTE THIS IS SIMPLY A
MEASURE. ALLOWING THE CHIEF'S
THE ABILITY IF THEY SO CHOOSE.
TWO AND DO THE BACKGROUND CHECK
IT IS COMMON PRACTICE WITH THEM
EMPTIES EVERYBODY ELSE TO DO
LIVE SCANS.
NEW YORK HAS ALREADY PASSED
SIMILAR MEASURES THIS DOES NOT.
NOBODY DOES NOT.
.
THE THE THIS BILL IS NOT
DESIGNED TO GO AFTER. ANYONE
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO HAVE A RAP
SHEET OR HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED.
QUITE FRANKLY WE ENCOURAGE THEM
TO COME FORWARD ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH TRAINING
AND.
HAVE IT DONE THE FIREFIGHTER
PROGRAM.
THIS IS VERY SIMPLY A.
PUBLIC SAFETY MEASURE TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ON WHAT'S GOING ON
AND ALLOW THOSE SH CHIEFS THE
ABILITY TO KNOW WHO'S ACTUALLY
ON THEIR FORCE.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
YOU ODD THE CHAIRS REGULATE AYE
MAINLY BECAUSE I DO KNOW WE DO
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH.
MORE TRAINING.
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED A
FIREFIGHTER TAKE NEEDS AND
GETTING THEM READY AND THEN THEY
GET OUT.
AN ACID TRIP PLY FOR FULL TIME
FIREFIGHTERS STATUS AND DON'T
MAKE IT THROUGH.
AND AND BECAUSE OF THEIR
PREVIOUS RAP SHEET WE DO NEED
TO.
TO TO COME UP WITH A METHODOLOGY
IN WHICH WE GO THROUGH THEIR
BACKGROUNDS THEY COME OUT OF OUR
ACADEMIES ARE AND I'M JUST
MAKING THIS UP AS I GO ALONG.
WHO MAKE UP OUR OWN?
FIRE ACADEMY FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WILL WE.
KIND OF.
GO THROUGH AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GO TO ALL THE TRAIN BUT
MORE IMPORTANT MAKE SURE. THAT
THEIR BACKGROUNDS DON'T IMPACT
AS THEY BECOME EMPLOYEES I DO
BELIEVE FIREFIGHTERS AND.
AND AND POLICE OFFICERS NEED WE
NEED TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
SCREENING.
AND SO THAT PEOPLE WHEN THEY
HIRE THEM THEY KNOW WHAT THEY
HAVE THE REAL PROBLEM IS. DATE
WE HAVE TO GET PEOPLE MORE
OBLIGED TO HIRE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SERVED THEIR TIME.
AND GET THAT STIGMA OFFER THEM
THAT THEY WERE ARKAN WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A PROBLEM AND
THAT'S A THAT'S A LARGER ISSUES
FOR THE CHURCH RECOMMEND AYE
VOTE. BUT I WILL TELL YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE PROBLEM
OF GETTING FORMERLY INCARCERATED
HIRED INTO THE. FIRE SERVICES.
AB TWENTY EIGHTY NINE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE GUBBIO CAVIAR
AYE CATALOGUER DEATH.
CAN WATER DUBBED AYE KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU.
I HAVE A.
LIZ GOT REAL.
I DON'T KNOW TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT.
I MEAN BILL NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT I DON'T NUMBER
EIGHTEEN.
THE EASIEST ON THE SOFT TOOK A
LONG TIME OKAY.
SEC.
I'LL SECOND THAT ONE.
ALRIGHT WELL.
APPRECIATE THE BREVITY I'M HERE
TO PERCENT AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY
EIGHT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
YES.
WITNESS.
UP OBERNOLTE COM HELPLESS
TICKLISH SPACE ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT OF BILL APPRECIATE DOT
ALL DIFFERENT WAS CHAIRMAN.
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
AFTER.
ALTHOUGH SHE SET UP A RECORD
BUT.
IT YOU'RE ACCEPTING A MESS
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IS NOT YOU SITE
AND WE HAVE THE ASSOCIATION FOR
LOS ANGELES DEPUTY SHERIFFS.
AND LOS ANGELES PROBATION
OFFICERS UNION HOSPITAL SIX
EIGHTY FIVE BOTH IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WE SHOT MUCH LOWER ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
AND WE BELIEVE THAT AND SOME
AGENCIES IT MAY RD INCLUDE THIS
THAT AS PART OF THEIR EMPLOYEE
DISCIPLINE PROCESS.
AND.
STATS WILL WE OBJECTED ISSUE
CRIME IN BEING ADDED TO STATUTE
IT'S OUT CODIFICATION WILL
UNNECESSARILY AT TIME COSTS AND
COMPLICATION WITHOUT
COMMENSURATE BENEFIT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND A WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THE
MEMBERS DESIRE TO PROVIDE MORE
EMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS FOR PEACE
OFFICERS FACING TO SUPPORT ANY
ACTION. ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ARE ROUTINELY. WE ARE
ROUTINELY CRITICIZED FOR NOT
ADDRESSING CLAIMS OF EMPLOYEE
MISCONDUCT. IN A MANNER BENNETT
BENNETT BEFITTING THEIR SERIOUS
NATURE.
AND AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT COMPLICATES THE EXISTING
EMPLOYEE DISCIPLINE PROCESS A
POTENTIALLY MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO DISCIPLINE OFFICERS
AS APPROPRIATE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NO VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
CHAMBERS JOHN OF THE VELVET
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION I COULDN'T HAVE SAID
IT ANY BETTER THAN MY COLLEAGUE
AND STATE SHERIFF'S ALSO POST.
THANK YOU.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
ASSOCIATION I FIND MYSELF OF.
IT COMES FROM WITH ODD FELLOW
WITNESSES SPENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I WOULD JUST
SECOND WHAT THEY HAVE SAID BUT
ALSO BAD THERE'S A PUBLIC
PERCEPTION. THAT THIS MIGHT BE
UNTIMELY AND INSENSITIVE TO
WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR
COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW. BAT BY A
WELCOME THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BUT I THINK ABOUT IT
WOULD BE MORE APPROPRIATE TO SAY
EDUCATION IN ADDITION TO IT
DISCIPLINE IF DISCIPLINE IS
WARRANTED.
THAT THIS.
THIS IS JUST.
.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON OUTSIDE
OF THESE CORRIDORS AND WOULD ASK
YOU TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT VOTE NO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
OPPOSITION.
AND QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I'M I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY YOU KNOW THE
BREVITY OF OF MOVING FAST.
LET ME JUST SAY THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS NOT AND
HAS NEVER BEEN. TO BE USED IN
SITUATIONS INVOLVING ANY CASES
OF POLICE VIOLENCE.
THERE WILL NEVER BE A CORRECT
MOMENT TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
ESPECIALLY. AS WE LIVE IN A TIME
IN WHICH SOCIAL MEDIA SHARE SO
STORIES FROM THE PUBLIC
DIRECTLY.
I THINK IF WE ARE TO ADDRESS
ISSUES THAT ARE BEING.
SEEN ACROSS OUR NATION RIGHT
NOW SPECIFICALLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO VERY RECENTLY. WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THE WAYS IN
WHICH WE HELP OFFICERS VERY VERY
EARLY ON.
THIS IS A THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT ONE COMMUNITY SAYS.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT OFFICERS
ARE TRAINED THAT THEY HAVE THE
EDUCATION AND RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED. EARLY ON SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE ESCALATION THAT
WE'VE SEEN ACROSS OUR COUNTRY IN
THIS MOMENT.
AND SO I HOPE THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE IS ALSO FEAR AWAY FOR
OFFICERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE STRESSES
AND ISSUES THAT THEY FACE ON THE
JOB. WE KNOW THAT.
THERE ARE HIGH LEVELS OF
DIVORCE WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
HIGH LEVELS OF PTSD WE KNOW
THERE ARE HIGH LEVELS OF.
OF ALCOHOLISM AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THESE AGENCIES HAVE
THE AUTONOMY IN AUTHORITY TO SAY
NOT ONLY ARE WE GOING TO
DISCIPLINE BUT WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO PROVIDE RESOURCE IN EDUCATION
BASED TRAINING. THAT WOULD ALLOW
YOU TO ACTUALLY.
RECEIVE THE EDUCATION THAT YOU
NEED TO BECOME A BETTER OFFICER
NO ONE GOES INTO THIS FIELD.
WANTING TO DO HARM. YOU GO INTO
THIS FIELD TRYING TO PROTECT AND
SERVE THE COMMUNITY. AND WE AS
LEGISLATORS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AND OBLIGATION TO
ENSURE THAT OFFICERS HAVE THE
EDUCATION THAT THEY NEED IN THE
COMMUNITY FEEL SAFE.
WHERE THESE OFFICERS ARE
PATROLLING? SO AT THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO DO THAT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THERE IN IOWA THANK YOU ON THE
WE WORKED LONG AND HARD OVER THE
WEEKEND. ON.
BUT THE WORDING OF THIS AND AND.
AND I WILL TELL YOU OF THE EIGHT
AUTHORED VERY SENSITIVE TO
MAKING SURE THAT. ON THIS BILL.
WOULD NOT SUPPLANT IF SOMEONE
RAPED SOMEONE IF SOMEONE KILLED
SOMEONE.
SOMEONE BEAT SOMEONE.
.
THERE IS NO TRAINING FOR THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S A CRIME IS
LOW TRAINING THAT IS OFF TO
TABLE. THIS IS ABOUT ON WORKING
WITH OFFICERS SO THEY DON'T
ESCALATE TO THAT LEVEL WORKMEN
OFFICERS SO THAT WE CAN.
TRAIN THEM ON. THINGS THAT.
THEY CAN REVERSE.
BOB ON A DAILY BASIS SUB PART OF
DISCUSSION WE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THE WITH THE
PROPONENTS OF WITH BODY CAMERAS
FOR EXAMPLE. OF AS YOU SEE AN
OFFICER OUT THERE NEW TRAINEE IN
THEIR SUPERVISORS WATCHING THAT
OVER THE CAN USE THAT. THAT THAT
THAT CAMERA TO SAVE YOUR POSTURE
THE WAY YOU LOOKED AWAY YOU
YOU'RE APPROACHING SOMEONE.
THIS IS WHY IT ESCALATED INTO
CONFRONTATION AND STARTED
TEACHING.
HOW THAT THEY CAN BETTER SERVE
THE COMMUNITY WHILE MOST
IMPORTANT THEY MAY NOT SEE
THEMSELVES?
AS THEY'RE TALKING TO SOMEONE
AND I AND I GIVE THE EXAMPLE OF
SOMEONE BEING TIRED THEY JUST
HOLDING.
HAD TO HANDLE THE GOT INTO
TALKING TO A YOUNG AFRICAN BOY
IN HIS MIND IS BACK IS HURTING
FROM THAT HEAVY BELT AND HE'S
TIRED.
FROM UP UP AND AFTER AMERICAN
YOUNG MALE THAT IS SOMEONE ABOUT
TO SHOOT ME.
AND TO BE ABLE TO SHOW THAT AND
TRAIN THEM NOT TO FIRE THEM.
A TRAIN NETWORK WERE ABSOLUTELY
NOT TRY TO.
TO TO.
HAVE JUST SUPPLANT.
IF SOMEONE IS.
BRUTALLY BEATEN SOMEONE OR KILLS
SOMEONE SAY JUSTIN RETRAIN THAT
IS NOT THE MESSAGE.
AT THE AUTHOR BIO BORDERS WAS
SUPPORTERS ARE TRYING TO PUT OUT
THERE INSTRUCTORS SO THAT'S WHY
WE'RE GOING FROM SHALL THE MAY.
I YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW MANY
TIMES WE WERE WORD SMITHING
THIS.
A IF YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW WE CAN
WORDSMITH THAT SO THIS DOES NOT
SUPPLANT.
GREGIS ACTIONS
OF I'M SURE THE AUTHOR WILL BE
WILLING TO TILT TO LISTEN AND IS
SUPPORTIVE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT THE SAME THING TO HAPPEN
EITHER.
SO THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDED I'VE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY. LACKEY NO CARDIO.
COVER YOUR AYE CATALOGUER DEATH
CAN WATER DEPTH AYE KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSED.
MISTER LACKEY.
ITEMS NINETEEN ELEVEN.
BILL NUMBER NINETEEN ELEVEN
BILL NUMBER NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
BILL NUMBER TWENTY TWO FIFTY
FIVE. ITEM NUMBER FIVE NUMBER
SIX NUMBER ELEVEN.
I MEAN.
YOU DO WHATEVER ORDER YOU AJ
JUST ANNOUNCING WHICH ONCE YOU
HAVE
.
THEY GIVE IT IF IT'S OKAY WITH
THE.
COMMITTEE CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
START WITH AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
FIVE.
YEAH.
WHEN OUR SECOND IT. YET.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU EARLIER
CHAIR MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY FIVE
IT'S A BILL THAT'S AIMED. AT
ASSISTING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IN THEIR INTERACTIONS
WITH CANNABIS DISTRIBUTORS AND
DELIVERED DRIVERS.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
UP PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND
APPRECIATE THE STAFF'S TIME.
WORKING WITH ME TO BETTER REFINE
THIS BILL.
NOW THE PROP SIXTY FOURS
LICENSING SYSTEM IS IN EFFECT
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND LICENSE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES.
ARE SURE TO INCREASE.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROVIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
WITH THE GUIDANCE.
WHEN THEY ENCOUNTER CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTOR DELIVERY DRIVER.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES AND OFFICER
TO WRITE A CITATION OF A
DISTRIBUTOR DOES NOT HAVE
PHYSICAL MANIFEST WITH THEM.
OR IF THEY FAILED TO SUBMIT THE
REQUIRED INFORMATION TO TRACK
AND TRACE.
THE BILL AUTHOR ALSO AUTHORIZES
A CITATION OF THE LICENSE DOES
NOT HAVE THEIR DELIVERY REQUEST.
UNDER CURRENT LAW LICENSEES ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE THESE ITEMS
WHEN TRANSPORTING CANNABIS.
IT HEARING TO THESE REQUIREMENTS
PROVIDE A CLEAR DISTINCTION
BETWEEN ILLEGAL OPERATOR AND
THOSE BREAKING THE LAW.
WE WANT OFFICERS TO BE CHECKING
FOR THESE ITEMS SO THEY CAN
EASILY DISTINGUISH BETWEEN.
A LICENSE.
AND A LIST ACTOR
WE ALSO WANT TO BE SURE
LICENSEES KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO FOLLOW THE REQUIREMENTS.
EXCUSE ME THAT'S WHY.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY FIVE ALSO
CRIMINALIZES COUNTERFEITING OF
SHIPPING MANIFEST.
I NOW TURN TO.
SHAUN RENTAL OF THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND
TEN MORE LYMPH RIVERSIDE JUST
DISTRIBUTION COMPANY.
STIR CHAIR MEMBER SHAUNA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE AND.
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
BASED OFF THE THE.
MOTION I'LL BE BRIEF AND JUST
KNOW THAT THE.
AMENDMENTS ALLOW ITS TO
ACTUALLY.
ABOUT TO BE MORE ENFORCEABLE BY
JUST GOING AFTER THOSE FOLKS
THAT ARE VIOLATING THE
PROVISIONS
AND SO.
WE LIKE THAT APPROACH PIN IT
ALLOWS US TO WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH THE BCC AND
OTHER BUSINESSES IN THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF OTHER COMMITTEES THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT SERVICE SO. ARE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
ENERGY.
I VOTE ON THE MEASURE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RETURNABLE ON
BEHALF OF RIVERS TRIGGERING A
LICENSE CHEMISTRY PARA
CALIFORNIA. AND I'LL BE BRIEF AS
WELL IN BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE
OFFERS A SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW BY
PROVIDING CLARIFICATION TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT REGARDING CABS
TRANSPORTATION VIOLATIONS. AND
WORKS GENTLY SUPPORT OF ANYTHING
THAT WILL REDUCE TO BLACK
MARKET.
AS WE ALSO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
DR. THANK YOU OTHER. ANY OTHER
WITNESS IN SUPPORT GOOD
AFTERNOON AIR NORWOOD ON BEHALF
OF THE CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR ALL OF US WORK AND ALLOWING
AND. TAKING OUR INPUT ON ON THE
SCREEN PORTENT BELL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD. AND APPRECIATE THE
MOMENTS AS WELL AND IN SPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THAT FEAR JASON BRYANT ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU OFFER.
THANK YOU.
ARE A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAKE LOVE ASK YOUR ABOUT. A.
DO OF MOTION. SECOND SECOND SO
CALL FOR A VOTE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDED I AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. AYE LACKEY
AYE CARILLO.
CAN LONGER DEATH. CAB LONGER
THAT I KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
GEN NOW IF WE COULD NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX NINETEEN TWENTY
NINE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB NINE TO TWENTY NINE.
IT WOULD CALL ON THE CD SEE ARE
AN INSPECTOR GENERAL TO EVALUATE
THE CORRECTIONAL REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS.
CDC ARE WOULD BE REQUIRED IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL CALIFORNIA
REHABILITATION OVERSIGHT BOARD.
THE CONTRACTS.
WITH OUTSIDE INDEPENDENT
RESEARCH ORGANIZATIONS TO
EVALUATE WHETHER SELECTED
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS ARE COST
EFFECTIVE.
THIS EVALUATION WILL BE OVER TEN
YEAR PERIOD FROM JULY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. TO SEPTEMBER
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY NINE AND
WILL PRIORITIZE THE EVALUATION
OF REHABILITATION PROGRAMS WHICH
ARE FUNDED THE STATE PLANS.
AND WHICH SERVE THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF INMATES.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE RELEASED A
REPORT OUTLINING VARIOUS
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS ALONG
WITH THEIR INTENDED GOALS AND
MADE RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE.
HOW THE STATE PROVIDES IN PRISON
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS?
THIS BILL IN BODIES TO OF THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IN ITS MOST RECENT REPORT THE
CALIFORNIA REAL THAT
REHABILITATION OVERSIGHT BOARD
STATED. THE BOARD WOULD LIKE TO
REITERATE THE IMPORTANCE OF
MEASURING PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
AND OUTCOMES.
AND TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE
LONGER TERMS ABSURD LONGER TERM
OUTCOMES AFTER OFFENDERS HAVE.
BEEN RELEASED TO THE COMMUNITY.
THE GOAL OF THIS ANALYSIS IS NOT
ONLY TO MAXIMIZE STATE DOLLARS
MORE PORTLY TO ENSURE EVERYTHING
IS BEING DONE. TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE SERVED THEIR SENTENCE AND A
RE ENTERING THEIR COMMUNITIES I
HAVE WITH ME JONATHAN PETERSON I
GUESS WOULD. ADD GAP WOULD DO.
AND THE NEED TO HILL WHAT THE LA
OVER JUST BECAUSE SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL FRAMEWORK FOR THE
BILL.
YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JONATHAN PETER SOME OF
THE LEGISLATIVE.
MOVE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
SECONDED BY.
CATALOG OF.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I'M ALSO JOINED BY
NEED A WE WHO WAS THE CAUGHT ON
THE REPORT THAT THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE IN ORDER
TO INCORPORATE THE RECOMMEND TO
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
REPORT. INTO OUR ANALYSIS AND
WERE HAVING ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
EVALUATIONS AND WHAT'S INCLUDED.
AND.
IN EVIDENCE BASED EVALUATION
VERSUS THE COST EFFECTIVENESS
EVALUATION.
THANK YOU.
A ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATHIS SOME HALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS TIM
CAMERA I'M ON BE AYE HERE ON
BEHALF OF SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND REPRESENTING OVER
NINETY SIX THOUSAND AYE WORKERS
WITH IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
BARGAINING UNIT THREE EDUCATORS.
THAT WOULD BE TEACHING MANY
HIGHS APPLICABL REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS
MEMBERS WE HAVE OUR OPPOSITION
BUT I MANY YIELD MY TIME SO THAT
OUR BARGAINING UNIT THREE CHAIR
BRUCE TEAL'C CAN ACTUALLY SAY
OUR SIDE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN JONES
SAWYER MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS BRUCE TEAL NAM
BARGAINING UNIT CHAIR FOR UNIT
THREE. REPRESENTING THE TEACHERS
IN THAT THAT.
ARE IN THE CDC ARE.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF SEIU LOCAL
ONE THOUSAND REPRESENTING OVER
NINETY SIX THOUSAND PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING OUR
BARGAINING UNIT THREE EDUCATORS.
MEMBERS WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED
TO ENSURE STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS
ARE COST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICACIOUS.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL ONLY FRUSTRATE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THOSE PROGRAMS
OUTCOMES.
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
THIS REPORT IS LIKELY TO LEAD TO
INACCURATE INFORMATION.
AND DESPITE THE LA O. AND
AUTHORS ASSURANCES ADDING THE
WORD FIGHT VALITY TO THE BILL
LANGUAGE DOES NOT RESULT IN.
OUR CONCERNS BEING RESOLVED.
WITH EVERY PRISON FACILITY
OPERATING DIFFERENTLY DUE TO
ADMINISTRATIVE PRIORITIES AND
UNIQUE SITUATIONS SUCH AS
PROTESTS AND RIOTS.
THIS REPORT WILL NOT PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE RELEVANT INFORMATION
YOU ACTUALLY NEED.
KNOWING THE CHALLENGES WITH
PROGRAMS AT EACH INDIVIDUAL
FACILITY.
INSTEAD.
A PROGRAM WILL LOOK LIKE A
FAILURE SIMPLY BECAUSE DATA
SUGGESTS
INMATE ACTS TOOK LONGER THAN
ANTICIPATED TO COMPLETE THEIR
COURSEWORK.
NEVER MIND THAT INMATE AXE WAS
HOSPITALIZED FROM A PRISON RIOT
GUN SIDEWAYS.
OR.
OTHER INTEREST.
INSTITUTION PROBLEMS.
MEMBERS BILL IS NOT ONLY
ANNETTE.
IT'S POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS TO
THE OVER ARCHING GOALS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ADRIN MOM IT WITH THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS
ASKED ME LOCAL TWO OF SIX WE
REPRESENT THE POSITIONS IN STATE
SERVICE. WE OFTEN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST TIFFANY
RIGHT WITH US THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAKE CLOTHES FOR SLACKING.
I WOULD JUST OF REMIND EVERYBODY
THE CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE HAVE
I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR THE CHANCE
TO ACTUALLY WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO IF GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY.
WHAT ASK YOUR SUPPORT?
AND.
AND I'VE TALKED OPPOSITION OF
TALK TO YOU KNOW I'VE TALKED TO
MY AUDITOR'S AND EVERYTHING. AND
SO I THINK TO SPECIFIC POINT IS
MAKING SURE.
THAT WE GET GOOD INFORMATION
QUALITY INFORMATION GOING AND SO
WE CAN MAKE OUT OF A VALID.
JUDGEMENT ON ON THESE PROGRAMS
OF AN INCIDENT NICER BUT
SOMETHING THAT MAY HAPPEN.
WHICH WAS BROUGHT UP TO ME WHERE
OUT YOU HAVE A A A A CLASS.
A CARPENTER CLASS OR OR
UNDERWATER WELDING CLASS.
AND BECAUSE OF THEM VALUES ARE
USED TO COLLOQUIAL THE SHOCK
COLLAR DECIDES HE DIDN'T WANT.
OF PEOPLE TO SHOW UP FOR WEEKS
AT A TIME.
IT MAY LOOK LIKE.
A PROGRAM TO FAILURE BECAUSE
PEOPLE DIDN'T COMPLETE THE
COURSES.
BUT THAT WAS A RESULT OF
SOMETHING INTERNAL.
WITHIN THE SYSTEM WHICH IS A
DIFFERENT CULTURE.
THEN OUTSIDE OUR SYSTEM AND TO
BE SURE THAT WE EVALUATED BASED
ON WHAT ACTUALLY GOES ON.
IMPRISON.
ACTUALLY WE GET ACCURATE
INFORMATION LIKE AND I BELIEVE
THAT'S WHAT.
.
PEOPLE WHO WORK WITHIN THE
FACILITY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT'S WHY YOU HEAR ABOUT THAT
WORKING WITH THE PRISON WARDEN.
TO EVALUATE IT SO THAT YOU YOU
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT SOMETHING
EXTRAORDINARY THAT WE.
WOULD EVEN THINK ABOUT
HAPPENING.
OF MIGHT HAVE A JOB A A
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON THAT. ON
THE OF THAT PROGRAM AS I SAID TO
ONE OF MY MEMBERS I HAVE NO IDEA
WHETHER OR NOT.
ROCK CLIMBING HELPS
REHABILITATE PEOPLE BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO FIND OUT.
NO LIKE TO HAVE IT EXAMINED
OBJECTIVELY WITHOUT ANY PRE BIAS
OR WITHOUT ANY KNOWLEDGE AND I
THINK THAT'S IF YOU CONTINUE TO
WORK.
WITH. THE PEOPLE WHO WORK INSIDE
I THINK YOU'LL GET BETTER
RESULTS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT WHAT WILL
WILL GET TO A POINT WHERE WILL
UNDERSTAND WHAT PROGRAM ACTUALLY
WORK WHICH IS WHERE WE WANT TO
GET.
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDED ALLY.
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
AUTHOR WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU.
THANK YOU.
ON A. B. NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. ITEMS ARE AYE LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE CARILLO.
CATALOGUER DEATH.
CAN MODERATE OF NOT VOTING.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN ELEVEN.
I DON'T OF THE FIVE.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
NINETEEN ELEVEN AND VOTE BY THE
WAY.
AB NINETEEN ELEVEN CALLS ON THE
COUNTIES.
BY TWENTY TWENTY NINE TO TAKE
FORMS ALREADY MANDATED BY
EXISTING LAW FOR CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT.
AND MAKE AVAILABLE IN ELECTRONIC
VERSION. THAT CAN BE TRANSMITTED
INSTANTLY INTO THE APPROPRIATE
AGENCIES.
THIS WILL ENSURE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES.
I COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OFFICES ARE COMMUNICATION WHEN
INVESTIGATING THESE CLAIMS.
THIS BILL COMES FROM THE
DEVASTATING STORY.
OF AN EIGHT YEAR OLD.
GABRIEL FERNANDES A PALM DEL WHO
WAS BRUTALLY BEATEN. AND
TORTURED.
BY HIS MOTHER AND BOYFRIEND.
SEVERAL DIFFERENT CALLS WERE
MADE TO BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES.
AND SOMEHOW GABRIEL STILL FELL
THROUGH THE CRACKS.
THIS UNFORTUNATE HAPPENSTANCE IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
UNCOMMON TODAY.
AND ESPECIALLY MOST
DISADVANTAGED REGIONS WITH MANY
CHILDREN MOVING IN AND OUT OF
THE SYSTEM.
FOLLOWING THIS CASE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AUTHORIZED A BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION. TO RECOMMEND
IMPROVEMENTS FOR HANDLING THESE
CASES.
FROM THAT COMMISSION CAN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ONLINE DATABASE
REFERRED TO AS EAST CARS.
WHICH MAKES THE CURRENTLY
MANDATED FORM THAT MUST BE
FILLED OUT UPON INTAKE OF AN
ALLEGED CHILD ABUSE ELECTRONIC.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
FOLKS IN LOS ANGELES.
WORKING ON THAT EACH CAR SYSTEM.
AND THEY COULD NOT STRESS ENOUGH
THE IMPORTANCE OF THEIR
ELECTRONIC INFORMATION SHARING.
AND HOW IT IS TRANSFORMED.
THE WAY AGENCIES COMMUNICATE
WITH
EACH OTHER WHEN DEALING WITH
THESE CASES OF CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
DATABASE IS NOT AND I EMPHASIZE
IS NOT A LAW ENFORCEMENT
DATABASE.
THIS IS NOT SIMILAR TO CAL
GAINES.
THIS IS A DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES DATABASE
THAT IS VERY SPECIFIC.
THAT IS WHERE ONLY SPECIFIC
IDENTIFIED BUT PEOPLE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAVE ACCESS TO.
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT THELACK OF
NOTIFICATION THAT WOULD GO. TO
THE PARENTS OF SUSPECTED CHILD
ABUSE OR NEGLECT.
BUT IT AS A DISTRO WITHIN
INVESTIGATION.
ALERTING SUSPECTS UNDOUBTEDLY
ALTERS DETERMINING TRUTH.
MUCH OF THE CONCERNS ARE COMING
FROM THE SIDE. OF THOSE WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN
INSTANCES WHEN ALLEGATIONS ARE
UNSUBSTANTIATED AND THE DUE
PROCESS FOR REMOVAL OF THE
ALLEGATION.
WHEN WE FOCUS SOLELY ON THAT
ASPECT WE MISSED THE OPPORTUNITY
TO OFFER THE HELP THESE
CHILDREN.
WHO ARE BEING ABUSED?
THEY'RE ALREADY SAFEGUARDS IN
PLACE IS THIS MANDATED PAPER
FORM HAS BEEN STATUTE FOR MANY
YEARS.
THIS BILL UPDATES THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT TO TRANSMIT
INFORMATION MORE QUICKLY MORE
EFFICIENTLY.
BY USING TODAY'S TECHNOLOGY.
AND.
I.
I HAD SOMEONE HERE TO TESTIFY
WITH ME TODAY WITHOUT A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY.
AND SO.
THEY WILL BE UNABLE TO TESTIFY
AND SO THERE YOU HAVE IT.
UNDER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN.
POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE RESPECTFULLY MUST
OPPOSE AB NINETEEN ELEVEN.
I WANT TO START BY KNOWLEDGE AND
THE TRAGEDY OF THE DEATHS OF
GABRIEL FERNANDEZ THIS WAS OF
COURSE A TRAGIC EVENT AND AND WE
WANT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
FIGURE OUT IF THERE ARE WAYS
THAT THE. THE STATE CAN BETTER
PROTECT ITS CHILDREN IN THE
FUTURE.
BUT THE CHANGES PROPOSED IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ELEVEN WOULD
NOT HAVE PREVENTED GABRIEL STAFF
WHICH HAPPENED AFTER ALLEGATIONS
OF ABUSE HAD BEEN INVESTIGATED
AND DETERMINED TO BE UNFOUNDED.
AND HAPPENED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHERE THEY ALREADY HAD AN
ONLINE DATABASE SUCH SUCH AS
WOULD BE REQUIRED UNDER THIS
BILL.
AB NINETEEN ELEVEN PROPOSES
CHANGES THAT WOULD PUT ALL
CALIFORNIANS AT RISK OF HAVING
CHILD ABUSE OF ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST THEM ENTERED INTO A
DATABASE. WITH LITTLE OR NO
OVERSIGHT AS TO HOW THE
INFORMATION CAN BE ACCESSED WERE
USED AND WITH UNDEFINED EXCUSE
ME UNDEFINED STANDARDS AND
PROCEDURES FOR THE REMOVAL OF
INFORMATION WHEN IT IS FOUND TO
BE UNSUBSTANTIATED.
THE CREATION OF AN A GOVERNMENT
DATABASE TO COLLECT UNTESTED
ACCUSATIONS OF IT IS TO BE DONE
AT ALL. REQUIRES THE UTMOST CARE
IN SETTING STANDARDS AS TO HOW
THE INFORMATION COMES TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE DATABASE.
HOW THE INFORMATION MAY BE USED?
WHEN IT SHOULD NO LONGER BE
RETAINED AND WHAT THE PROCEDURES
ARE FOR CHALLENGING THE
INCLUSION OF THE INFORMATION.
WE'VE SEEN THE TYPES OF ABUSES
THAT THAT OCCUR WHEN SUCH
STANDARDS ARE NOT EXPRESSLY LAID
OUT WE'VE SEEN IT WITH THE
STATEWIDE CHILD ABUSE CENTRAL
INDEX WHICH FOR MANY YEARS
INCLUDED THE NAMES. OF MANY
WRONGFULLY ACCUSED PEOPLE AND
GAVE THEM NO WAY TO GET THEIR
NAMES OFF THE LIST.
WE'VE SEEN IT WITH CAL GANG
WHICH ALSO KEPT INFORMATION ON
PERSONS WHO DID NOT BELONG IN
THE SYSTEM.
AND WHICH ALLOW THE INFORMATION
TO BE USED IN WAYS THAT WERE NOT
AUTHORIZED.
YET AB NINETEEN ELEVEN REQUIRES
EACH OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES TO SET UP SUCH A
DATABASE.
AND FOR THE MOST PART LETS THEM
SET THEIR OWN STANDARDS AT FOR
HOW THEY WILL OPERATE.
THE POTENTIAL FOR ABUSE INDEED
THE LIKELIHOOD OF WIDESPREAD
ABUSE IS CLEAR.
WE ASK YOU TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS BY VOTING NO
ON THIS.
THANK YOU HER INDIA.
MISTER TREMORS ON I'M HERE IN
THE CONCERNS POSITION JOIN OF OR
SOME GAP THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS.
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE BEEN HAD
MEETINGS WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF
THE SPONSORS OF THE BELL. MOM
AND WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
THE SITUATION LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WHICH WHICH IF WE HOPE DOESN'T
HAPPEN OTHER KINDS THAT WE KNOW
DOES HAPPEN SOMETIMES.
BUT OUR ISSUE IS THE FACT THAT.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS COSTLY
INEFFECTIVE IT WOULD ASK EACH
COUNTY TO CREATE A BRAND NEW
DATABASE YOU ALREADY HAVE
EXISTING DATABASES FOR ALL ORDER
ACQUIRED ACROSS REPORTING. AND
SO THE SUBJECT BECAUSE OF THE
WORD OR YOU DO AND VERY COSTLY
SO WE HAVE BEEN ASKING THE
AUTHORS OFFICE OF WE COULD DO IT
USE OUR EXISTING DATABASES
COMPLY WITH A BELL. SOBRE STONE
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING THAT.
AND IS ALSO SICK OF IT MANDATE
ON COUNTIES ON AND EIGHT EACH
COUNTY IS DIFFERENT ON RESOURCES
AND SO WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO.
MENTION THOSE THINGS ON TO THE
COMMITTEE AND WE STILL HAVE
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY RYAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND ALSO
BROKEN REPRESENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
ALSO WITH THE CONCERNS POSITION
OF FOR ALL THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BUT ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE SLACKER.
THURMOND VERY FEW BILLS.
SINCE I MIDDLE ELECTED.
THAT HAVE MORE MEANING THAN THIS
ONE TO ME.
BECAUSE I AM PERSONALLY AWARE OF
THE TRAGEDY.
THAT.
THAT TOOK PLACE THAT I JUST
IDENTIFIED.
AND I GET FRUSTRATED OFTEN.
WITH THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THE FOCUS.
AND I KNOW WE ALL GENERALLY
HAVE.
A RESPONSIBILITY TO DO OUR BEST
AND THAT'S ALL ANY OF US CAN DO.
BUT I.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT THIS
BILL.
YRSHIRE SURE WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN.
SO THAT NOT ONE MORE CHILD HAS
TO SUFFER.
THE WAY THIS YOUNG MAN DID
UNCONSCIONABLE.
AND WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LESSEN THE LIKELIHOOD.
OF THIS KIND OF TRAGEDY TO TAKE
PLACE.
EDWARD.
LEADING.
DIRECTIONS.
BETTER EASILY. WORKED THROUGH.
GET IN THE WAY OF PROTECTING
CHILDREN.
A VOTE AGAINST THIS BILL AS A
FAILED OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN.
IF THAT IS SOMETHING THIS
COMMITTEE CAN'T SUPPORT BUT I
DON'T KNOW WHY WE'RE HERE.
LAST YEAR I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER.
LACKEY AND I AND AND I KNOW
YOU'RE VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
ISSUE PASS ABOUT ANY OF THE
BILL'S GOING FORWARD SO IT'S NOT
JUST THIS ONE I KNOW YOU.
IT IT FROM THE HEART.
.
AT I KNOW WE WE WE HAD
UNDERSTANDING WE CAN AGREE TO
DISAGREE.
ABOUT WE'RE NOT DISAGREEABLE.
AND AND SO I.
I VALUE YOUR COMMENTS AS VICE
CHAIR.
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE YOUR
INPUT.
.
AND.
IF WE HAD BUT IF I HAD MORE TIME
TO TO A WORK WITH YOU TO THIS.
TO MAYBE PUT ANY INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ON.
SO THAT EVERY SYSTEM ACROSS
LINES ARE WORKING TOGETHER MORE
IMPORTANT SO THAT.
GARRETT ANY ABUSES ON ON.
WITH PUTTING PEOPLE IN THE
DATABASE BECAUSE WE NEED TO NOT
ONLY WORRY ABOUT. INDIVIDUALS
BUT INDIVIDUALS ARE WRONGLY.
PLACED ON ON THE DATABASE AND WE
NEED TO PERFECT THAT ALSO.
AND AND SO SHE GOT FREE RIGHT.
.
THE TRAGEDY THAT THE SYSTEM THAT
WAS IN PLACE IN LA. DIDN'T WORK.
AND.
JUST LIKE WHAT HAPPENED SOME OF
THE SHOOTINGS WE HAVE WHERE YOU
HAD.
LAW ENFORCEMENT KNOWING WHAT TO
DO GETTING INFORMATION THEY
DIDN'T RESPOND.
THAT'S A TRAGEDY AND WE NEED TO
REPAIR THAT ALSO.
SO.
I'M FOR.
TRYING TO REPAIR THE SYSTEM.
.
IN NO WAY ANYONE.
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
IS TRYING TO SHIELD
OR OR TO HELP.
PEOPLE LET KILLED YOUNG PEOPLE
OR OR HARM HIM ANYWAY.
AND AND I UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO.
HAVE TO SAY NO. TO THIS PROPOSAL
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO SAY
NECESSARY IS NOTING ANYTHING YOU
BRING FORWARD IN THE FUTURE.
I DOES GOOD IF IT FAILS HERE
TODAY AND WILL BE VERY VERY
DIFFICULT INTO YOU.
BUT I WANT YOU KNOW YOUNG
CHILDREN BECAUSE OF A
DISAPPOINTMENT AND IS NOT.
BECAUSE.
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT CHILDREN.
BECAUSE WE WANNA MAKE SURE WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
WE DO THE RIGHT THING.
WITH THAT CADRE.
SECOND.
BUT AB NINETEEN ELEVEN THE
MOTION IS DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE CARILLO.
PATIO KNOW KABBALAH GRETA.
CAN MODERATE OF NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
MAJOR FAILS NASSERITE
CONSIDERATION.
TAKE IT.
ON RECONSIDERATION JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY. AYE AYE
MIKEY AYE CARILLO.
GARVEY YA KNOW TABLADA.
CATALOG ART OF NO KILEY. KILEY
AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SAN DIEGO.
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING.
YOUR PRESENTING ON YOUR MEMBERS
ONLY YES.
ITEM NUMBER.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY FOUR THEY
HAD A MUCH OF A VERY REAL SENSE
I'M LOSING MY VOICE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AMENDMENTS AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY FOR. A FOR THE
CONCERNS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
MAKE SURE THESE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS. AT
SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWED THE SCOPE
OF MY BILL TO ENSURE THAT IT
ONLY CAPTURES THE WISER
ORIGINALLY CHARGED AND CONVICTED
AS A FELONY.
THERE LATER REDUCE A MISDEMEANOR
NOT IDEA WHY THAT IS RACIALLY
CHARGED AND CONVICTED AS A
MISDEMEANOR. TO BE CLEAR NOTHING
GETS ELEVATED IF THE ORIGINAL DO
YOU WHY IS NOT A FELONY. ALSO
THE AMENDMENTS DO NOT TAKE AWAY
A JUDGE'S DISCRETION TO CHARGE
IN ORIGINAL DUI OFFENSE AS A
MISDEMEANOR.
SO THIS IS A VERY PERSONAL TO ME
BUT THIS WILL MAKE THIS.
BELL WILL MAKE CERTAIN THAT
REPEAT DO AYE FELONS THOSE WHO
HAVE KILLED OR SERIOUSLY INJURED
SOMEONE. DO NOT DO SO AGAIN
THANK YOU EXPECT WE ASK WHAT
I'VE OF.
IT'S.
IT IT'S UP FOR VOTE ONLY.
RECONSIDERATION.
SO WE OUGHT TO VOTE ONLY.
GENERATION.
JUST MILES NO WE'RE DOING TO
VOTE ONLY.
GOT WORK RAFFIA. NEVER START
WITH A VOTE ONLY.
I DON'T OVER TWENTY SIX.
OUR ARE ALL ON THE.
OKAY.
GO I DON'T NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TH.
SEVEN.
CUNNINGHAM IS THERE A MOTION.
YEAH PACIFIC VOTE.
SEC.
ON AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THE
MOTION MANY LENOVO.
THE MOTION IS DE PASSES
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER.
CHEN SERRANO LACKEY LACKEY I
CARILLO.
CARILLO NO CATALOGUER DEATH.
CAMERA OF NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NOW THAT MEASURE FAILS.
I DON'T KNOW BUT.
TWENTY SEVEN AB THIRTY ONE MAYBE
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE FONG.
SIR MOTION.
IS THERE A MOTION.
PROPOSAL.
I MAYBE NINETEEN THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
NO JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO.
CARILLO NO CATALOGUER DEATH.
COME LONGER DUBNO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SAID THE AGA.
FOR THERE ARE NO.
I DEMO TWENTY EIGHT AB TWENTY
FOURTEEN WAS PULLED BY AUTHOR.
FOR AN ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTEEN.
THEIR MISSION.
THERE.
JONES SAWYER. KNOW JONES SAWYER
NO LACKEY. LACKEY I CARILLO.
HAVE YOUR NO CATALOGUER DOT.
GALLAGHER TOUGH NOW KILEY KILEY
AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AB TWENTY
FOUR OR FIVE PATTERSON.
IS THERE A MOTION.
JONES SAWYER NO CONCERN NOW
LACKEY LACKEY I CARILLO.
CANDIANO CAM OTHER DOWN.
CAN LEVERED UP NOW KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SAID THERE WERE NO.
THAT MEASURE FAILED ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY ONE AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
TWO HARPER.
IS THERE A MOTION.
WELL IT.
JONES SAWYER NO JONES SAWYER NO
LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO.
BECAUSE THEY ARE NO CATALOGUER
DEATH. CAN LOOK IT UP NOW KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NOPE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO NO.
THAT MEASURE FAILS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY TWO AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN PATTERSON.
IS THERE A MOTION.
JONES SAWYER NO JONES ARE NOW
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE GARCIA.
KELLY ARE CAB AUTO. CAM OTHER
DEAF NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
THAT MEASURE FAILS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY THREE AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY THREE HARPER.
JONES SAWYER NO JONES SAWYER NOW
LACKEY. LACKEY I GOT REAL.
CARILLO NO CATALOGUER DEATH.
GALLAGHER DUBNO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SUB EDUARDO.
THE MEASURE FAILS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR FONG.
JONES SAWYER NO JONES SAWYER NO
LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO.
CAMBIADO CATALOG OR DEATH
CATALOG IT UP NOW KILEY KILEY
AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NOTES SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
THAT MEASURE FAILS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY ONE PATTERSON.
MOVE WITH THEM.
JONES SAWYER NO JONES SAWYER NO
LACKEY. LACKEY I CARILLO.
CAN WE ARE NO CAM OTHER DEATH.
CAN LOOK IT UP NOW KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK KNOWS SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
THE MOTION FAILED.
WE'RE GOING TO DO REMAINING
ISLANDS OF.
.
THE DAY OF THE DAY.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE HITS AND
DISPENSED WITH.
I REMEMBER TO THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL AB SEVEN TO. SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY MR LOW GABRIELLE.
CARILLO AYE CATALOGUER DATA.
GALLAGHER DEV AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER THREE. THIS MEASURE
WAS ALSO ON CALL ON AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TWO BY MR LOW. CARDIO
CARDIO AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE SAN DIEGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER BEFORE AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY THREE GALILEO.
CARILLO AYE KILEY.
KILEY ICE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEMIDVIKING BE NINETEEN LEBANON
RECONSIDERATION MISTER SANTIAGO
NOT VOTING TO KNOW.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY NINE BY
MISTER LACKEY ITEM NUMBER SIX
CARDIO.
GARVEY ARE NOT LOADING.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY TWENTY
EIGHTY NINE MISTER KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR BY MISS RUBIO COVER
YOUR.
CAVIAR ICE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
I DON'T NUMBER NINE WAS ON
CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER TEN WITHHOLDING
COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY FIVE.
CARILLO. CAVIAR AYE KILEY.
KILEY I SAN DIEGO. SANTIAGO AYE.
AND A NUMBER TWELVE AS A
CONSENT.
ITEM THIRTEEN ON CONSENT.
ITEM.
FOURTEEN ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY TWO KILEY.
KILEY NOW.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT KILEY.
KILEY NO.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN THIS
MEASURE WAS ONCOL AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT BY FELLOW
MEMBER MELENDEZ.
SANTIAGO.
FANDANGO AYE THAT MEASURE PATH.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE ONE AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY TWO BY MISTER
TING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
I DON'T TWENTY TWO THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL AB THIRTY SIXTY FOUR
BAKER. GABRIELLE.
BECAUSE THEY ARE KNOW SANTIAGO
FANDANGO KNOW THAT MEASURE
FAILED.
ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B. THIRTY
ONE OH FOUR BY MISTER COOPER
KILEY.
KILEY NOW.
ITEM TWENTY FOUR THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
NINE BY MISS RUBIO.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE BY MISTER GLORIA THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL. GALILEO.
GABRIELLE I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
OTHER MEANING ITEMS HAVE BEEN
DISPENSED WITH REPORT ONLY TWO
ITEMS TWENTY SIX TO THIRTY FIVE.
AND THAT CONCLUDES THE MEDIA
PUBLIC.
HOLD ON WAS CARILLO.
YES ON THE RECONSIDERATION NOT
VOTING.
OKAY WE STAND ADJOURNED.
WHO